Thank you.
We're going to hang out for a couple minutes until, um, hey Morgan, there you go.
I was just telling Sin and we're going to hang out until you got here.
We should still wait a couple minutes though because, uh, you know, other people come along
and then I have to repeat myself and, I mean, I like to repeat myself, but then I do it
too much and it becomes alienating.
So it's a balance, you know?
I'm going to hang out and I'm going to hang out and we're going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out and I'm going to hang out and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes and I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
I'm going to hang out for a couple minutes.
Now, I put that one, that little diagram that I found the other day in the chat.
I still, because I don't have Apple, I'm not able to put anything up in the pill or whatever it's called.
Well, Morgan is headed out, so we'll see how long this goes on for.
Hey, Morgan.
Welcome back.
Looking for my notes for my conversation with my brother.
They're very...
My notes are never very comprehensive.
I'm not the best note taker in the world, unfortunately.
Nope.
That's wrong.
Okay.
I might have, I might have misplaced the notes.
You know what I might have done?
I took the notes in the chat for the call, but it looks like the chat for the call isn't available.
So, huh.
I wonder if I just took the notes and then consigned them to...
Well, it's not going to be very good then.
So, I don't know much about artificial intelligence, or I didn't know much about artificial intelligence.
And I hadn't used it really.
I asked Grok a couple of times a few questions, but I'm unimpressed.
I don't...
I feel like, you know, all you need is a search engine and you get the same or better answers.
That's my opinion.
I don't know.
I guess people feel like the search engine, the AI is aggregating answers.
I would be concerned about that because you kind of rely on your own discernment and your own knowledge to...
Right?
Your own knowledge about the subject to discern the quality of the answer.
And so, aggregating an answer that doesn't really, with the internet and all the crazy things people say, it doesn't fill me with confidence.
So, that having been said, I finally said, "Look, let's just sit down and you can explain to me...
You know, you can explain to me what is going on with artificial intelligence, what's going on with AI."
So, he did.
And as he started to talk, right, a couple of things came up.
Like, immediately, I started to think about simulationism, the matrix/reality overlay, and conversations that I've had with Morgan.
And I also started to think about Ed Dames and technical remote viewing.
With the simulationism, I was 90% certain of the validity of simulationism and the concept of the reality overlay going into my conversation with my brother.
So, as soon as we started talking, I became 100% convinced.
I think it's interesting.
You don't hear many people elaborate on the features of the similarities between the features of AI and, like, things we don't...
I don't know.
Features of life, right?
So, the other thing that I started thinking, sort of like a second-order thought or sort of on the back burner was how similar AI prompting and context engineering, context management is in working with an AI to the approach that Ed Dames took to technical remote viewing.
From my understanding, I didn't study with Ed.
I didn't study with Ed.
Morgan did.
Morgan's not available to talk.
So, you know, I would have asked, specifically, if there was any...
So, you find a lot of...
We find a lot of...
We find a lot of the remote viewers who are focused on the reality overlay/simulationism seem to be people who study with Ed or technical remote viewers.
So, from what I understand, the last...
So, PsyCore, right, went out of business or changed.
Anyhow, Morgan was telling me that the current organization is Matrix something.
So, right there, Matrix is in the name, right?
I assume Ed thought and talked about the Matrix, but I...
You know, most of what he used to talk about online was the kill shot and related subjects.
I can't recollect him talking about the subject on Coast to Coast back in the day, but I assume he knew.
And what I wondered now, when I started learning what AI is, to what extent Ed had...
What did he experience related to AI when he was in the military?
Hey, Melissa.
So, there is a rumor, and I think it's among people I think who would...
Right?
I don't know.
Who's here?
Hey, Shane.
Obviously, I don't know the truth of this, or not.
But there's been...
Okay.
Yeah, he can't do...
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, dude.
It's cool.
I just wanted to find out if you knew anything about...
Hey, Shane.
If you knew anything about Ed having experience with...
I mean, I guess it would be classified, so he couldn't say anything.
But if there was any rumor that he had experienced with AI when he was in the service, back in the Stargate days.
So, people have claimed for years that there was an AI mainframe, perhaps a quantum computer running an AI the government had in the 1990s.
I assume they would still have it, right?
So, they were more advanced, according to the rumor, right?
If they were running it on a quantum computer, then we could assume that they were significantly more advanced than Claude.
So, I don't know that for a fact, but that would just be the safe assumption because of the quantum computing aspect of it.
So, one of the remote viewers, famous, infamous remote viewers, Prunus Calabresi, now known as Bertie Jarowski, I don't.
I struggle with even English words.
I don't mean to be disrespectful.
It's just the truth.
I have a lot of difficulty with names.
So, I spend my time thinking about other things, I think.
She reports having had a conversation with someone from the government in the '90s about them putting computers that could take pictures of the future.
That's not me saying that.
That's her.
I don't know.
But, if they had some sort of quantum AI computer, then perhaps that's a reality.
I'm sorry, I was trying to hit the dumb button on that, but I hit the wrong button.
It's very unprofessional to cough when you're talking on a show or something.
Yeah, so, I wondered if Ed had exposure to that.
Because his thinking, from what I understand, seemed to be very similar to the thinking that someone who's adept with AI and working with AI would have.
So, to get into similarities of human beings and AI agents, there's been a recent discovery that human beings, our brains shrink when we're sleeping.
And fluid actually washes our brain, which is fascinating if you think about the linguistic connection.
But, basically, when you're asleep at night, your brain shrinks and your body washes your brain.
And when you look at, if you look at CAT scans or MRIs, if you look at the brainwaves themselves, right, and the patterns of brainwaves, your brain completely changes.
Right?
You're running these patterns all day long.
And then, as you go to sleep, the waves change.
The areas of brain that produce the waves change.
And the signal itself diminishes.
And so, there is a good argument to be made.
That, as opposed to being continuously conscious.
Right?
As opposed to, you know, you were born and you learned how to think.
And, or you learned to become conscious and then you've been conscious since that day.
There is a good argument to be made that we're actually only conscious for one day.
And we, as part of our daily experience, we're accessing the memories of all of our previous conscious events.
But that's what the, that's how powerful the disconnect is.
Right?
Like the, your cells change.
Your brain shrinks.
Your brain washes.
Your brain cells.
Your, the patterns of your brain waves change and diminish and reboot the next day when you wake up.
So, it's at least metaphorically efficient.
But it may very well be completely true that our consciousness reboots every morning.
Or every time we wake up.
From deep sleep.
And, if you look at it from that perspective.
Right?
As my brother was explaining AI to me.
He was explaining the, the generation.
He called it killing, killing the AI.
It's a terrible thing.
But that's what he says.
Right?
So, the purpose of generating and killing AI agents.
And the pattern is very similar to the rebooting ignition and the rebooting ignition pattern of human consciousness in the brain.
Which seems to be both like a, like the equivalent of a software and the equivalent of a hardware reboot.
Right?
So, the, the problem that the AI agents have.
They have something called a context window.
Now, you guys probably all know all about this.
And it's completely new to me.
But, I'm coming at it from the perspective of like someone, it's, it's new too.
So, please, you know, bear with me.
So, each AI has a context window.
It's a context window.
And in that context window, there's a certain number of context units that the AI is capable of, of having, right, in the, in the program of reviewing, of viewing, of accumulating at one time.
So, each context unit is roughly the equivalent of one word.
So, previous or original models of AI were capable of reading or processing about 100,000 words before they hit their context limit, the limit of their context window.
So, the current AI models available to the public have about a million unit, context units in their context window.
So, once you hit that, that maximum, you can't do anything anymore.
You've got to reboot, you've got to kill the agent and create a new one.
So, however, what they found is that as soon as you, oh, here comes the cats.
I'm now on my third, third try with the cats coming back and forth through the doors.
Okay.
So, you have a million units in a context window, basically.
The problem is once you get up over about 500 words, weird things start to happen.
That's when AI start to make mistakes a lot.
That's when they start to hallucinate a lot.
And that's when they start to have more, it's more likely that they have simple cantic behaviors with their users.
Where they start sort of reverting to answering questions with what almost appears to be flattery as opposed to direct answers.
And the way my brother, he's in graduate school for AI.
That hasn't been said, like he's definitely not the world's greatest expert.
However, the way he represented it to me is no one's exactly sure why.
When you get over 500,000 context units, you begin to hallucinate.
The AI begins to hallucinate.
But they know it's true.
And so the goal is to be as efficient as possible with your searches so that you tend not to exceed 500,000 context units.
So one of the challenges that people have when working with AI is they don't know how to be articulate, they don't know how to be precise with the prompts that they give to the AI.
So they give them these sort of overly broad prompts.
And so the AI goes out and accumulates too many words, too many context units, making it very efficient and causing them to get past the 500,000 context unit level very quickly and leading to the hallucinations.
So ideally, you want to save the data when you're running an AI.
Before you get to that point, quote, kill the AI, generate a new AI agent and have him review your summary of the previous data, the compressed data.
So the same way if you were too tired from studying and you were starting to think funny or having trouble recalling the answers or having trouble memorizing what you need to learn, you'd go to sleep.
All right, you go to sleep, reboot your brain, wash it, wash it out, wash it clean or cleaner, right?
Go through the dreaming process, which is part of the, from what I understand, is part of the process of encoding memories.
But definitely there is a process while you sleep where your context window is compressed and recorded.
And then the next day you look back on that the same way an AI would look back on its previous AI agent, the compressed context window.
So, as a brief digression, I think it's, it's pretty obvious to me, like, two reasons why that would happen, by the way.
Why it would begin hallucinating.
I'm not saying, you know, I have the answer that no one else has.
I think maybe other people understand this and my brother doesn't.
I don't know.
Or maybe I'm just, like, off in left field here.
But there are two things that come to mind right away.
Number one is quantum entanglement, right?
Once two particles are connected in some way, they exert a force over each other, no matter how far apart they are.
You could take two particles, I think everyone here probably knows this, right?
You take two particles, they could touch each other, and then you take them to the opposite ends of the universe and they would still influence each other.
So, one of the arguments against free will, the way that a lot of people would like to imagine it, is quantum entanglement.
Quantum entanglement is a metaphor for the influence and effect, the force that we each exert on each other, after encountering each other.
So, your action is not your own when you're a child, it's your action influenced by the force from your mother and father.
And by the time you roll around to my age, right, like you've interacted with 100,000 people, all who exert a various amount of force on you at all times, and have an influence on your decision.
So, when you get to a certain point where your life, your decisions are the negative space, or can only fill the negative space between all these other particles, right?
So, I think the best way of, not to mix metaphors, but, you know, it's like water, you pour water through a collection of stones or something.
The water can only fill the shape between the stones.
In that same way, when you have enough particles exerting force on each other, right?
When you get to that point, your action is limited by the space between the influence of those particles.
Again, metaphorical, but valid.
So, one issue that the context window might be having is quantum entanglement.
Another is just entropy.
So, data has mass.
They don't quite understand it.
As far as I know, maybe someone understands it, and then, like, most people don't understand it.
And I'm in that category of most people who don't understand it.
But your hard drive is heavier at the end of its life than it was at the beginning of its life.
So, data itself has mass.
They're not exactly certain about what that, how that works.
But the process involving the physical component of data, however that works out, right?
If that's real, and I mean, it seems to be fairly consistent in the measurements, then entropy would also be a factor in that system.
Just as entropy is a factor in every system, right?
Like, things break down and become chaotic over time.
After a certain point, right?
With, like, non-living natural systems or physical systems, right?
That would happen maybe in a different curve.
I'm not an expert on this.
So, I'm just throwing things spitballing here.
But with a living system, we know how that works, right?
So, that would be the metaphor that I would use.
Because we know that in a living system, right, your body fights entropy to a certain point.
And then when you get to, right, midlife, entropy begins to overwhelm the effect that life has on resisting entropy.
And things begin to get chaotic and break down.
When you develop the illnesses of middle age, you develop, you know, you start to lose your memory a little bit.
You start to lose a step, right?
That's entropy setting into the biological system, right, of your body, basically.
So, either one of those could explain, or both, could explain why the context window problem with 500,000 words or 50%.
Why after you exceed 50% of the context window, you begin to get things like hallucinations, okay?
So, it would also explain why a person, well, maybe I'm skipping around here.
If a person was like an AI, it would explain the problems that a person can have when exposed to a lot of data in life.
So, if you're a person, right, if you're in social environments where there's a lot of, you can't filter, if you're like an introverted person, you can't filter social data effectively.
So, when you're in a social environment, you're conscious of more data points than other people are, right?
So, it's not like people who are introverted aren't paying attention.
They're paying too much attention.
And so, social interactions with people are, wear them down very easily.
Because the data points exceed the number of context units that they're capable of holding in their personal context window.
But if you were a reader, you could only read so much in one day, right?
And then you're going to exceed the, you're going to begin to creep over 50% of your context window.
It would be that way with everything, including like physical work or exercise, whatever.
Like, if you look at them, each type of human activity as possibly being divisible into context units, then the same principle would apply in pretty much every, if not every human endeavor.
Now, the interesting thing about that is, it would also apply in remote viewing.
As a matter of fact, it might apply more so in remote viewing, where a viewer is, a viewer is prompted to go and retrieve data.
And we don't know, like, I don't, I wouldn't know how to measure.
Maybe Morgan would, but I doubt it, no offense.
I don't know if anyone has a way of measuring the context units involved in a remote viewing session.
But they must be significant.
And so if you were working with a group of remote viewers, this is, again, hey Morgan, send me an emoji if you're, if you're following and what I'm saying sounds good.
I know you can't come up and speak.
Just, you know, let me know if I'm, if I'm missing here or not.
I wanted to have Morgan speak because as a technical remote viewer, he'd give me feedback on, on whether I'm drifting away from his experience.
He's not able to do that this evening, unfortunately.
I think he might've stepped away actually, but who knows.
So, um, he could also be gone to be honest, because sometimes these, um, screens freeze up on me.
I see him there.
Um, no, he's gone.
All right.
Um, or maybe, I don't know.
Okay.
So, uh, if Morgan's training a group of remote viewers or he's working with a group of remote viewers, an inexperienced remote viewer, a student or a less adept remote viewer would.
Thanks Morgan.
Right.
Would have difficulty managing their context window.
They would have a smaller context one at first.
Um, and they would have difficulty managing it.
And the person working with them, the project manager might have more difficulty managing their context window.
Like the, the student's context window as well, because it would be like working with a new AI model.
Right.
So there'd be a Sinan AI, Melissa AI, a Shane AI.
You would all sort of work the same, but maybe not.
And so if Morgan was teaching you, he would have to, um, learn how to best prompt and manage each of your context windows.
If the prompt is overly vague, right.
That brings in so much, so many context points.
I imagine, again, this is hypothetical.
This is his expertise.
It's not mine.
I imagine what would, I imagine what is happening, not what would happen, not hypothetically.
I imagine what is happening is they're overloading their context window.
They're going above 50% and they begin to hallucinate.
And I would imagine for a remote viewer, what that hallucination looks like is.
Or coming back with, uh, analytical overlay or coming back with.
I don't know any of the, any of the predictable problems that he would be an expert on that I'm not an expert on.
So then you think, start thinking about the different remote viewing teachers and their style, right.
None of the other remote viewing teachers, their style doesn't seem to, to indicate, right.
An advanced knowledge or, um.
I don't think any of the other remote viewers think like an AI.
Or think like someone managing an AI.
Remote viewing teachers, um, original remote viewers.
None of the other original remote viewers think like people managing AI.
Ed Dames, unfortunately he is gone.
Uh, may he rest in peace.
I think that he did.
And so that the question therein is, did he have this epiphany where he, he himself.
Had a unique insight into the way people's minds worked into the way remote viewers minds worked.
And he, in parallel.
Right.
These concepts.
And, and essentially became, um, a professional context engineer.
For.
Right.
The AI being the remote viewers.
But the other, right.
The other possibility is, is that he worked with it.
The other possibility is, is that some of the individuals involved in the.
Project Stargate and some of the other projects.
Were.
Exposed very early on.
To the AI project, which were, would probably run in parallel.
Right.
And if that's the case.
Then.
They would know how.
Or at least have, um.
A theoretical grasp on how to work with AI.
In addition.
As much as we know about the session data.
From the Stargate project.
There's a lot more we don't know.
And we do know from CIA records.
Publicly available CIA records.
That they do understand that we're in a simulation.
And they do have.
Um.
They do have elaborate schematics and diagrams for how.
Uh.
Consciousness works.
Right.
So.
Possible.
That he.
Had that information.
And.
As someone who was.
Part of running the program.
And the other.
Um.
Hey Morgan.
Oh.
The other.
Teachers did not.
Right.
That.
That's quite possible.
Uh.
But it could be.
Natural genius.
Right.
Or.
It could be.
Hey.
Speaking now.
That's weird.
I mean.
I'm glad.
You can hear me too.
Okay.
Hey.
Do you hear what I'm saying though?
You think like.
It's possible both ways.
Right.
Like it's possible.
He had this unique epiphany.
This.
This unique understanding.
Or.
An understanding.
Drawn from.
Reviewing works.
But it's also possible.
He may have encountered.
Nascent.
Or early.
AI research.
In the military.
Okay.
You're getting into some really interesting.
Territory here.
Uh.
The short answer is.
I don't know.
He never said anything to me.
Like that.
Um.
I'm not aware of him.
Ever saying anything.
Along those lines.
To anyone.
But you're.
Very correct.
Finding out that.
If.
Indeed.
That was the case.
First of all.
Yes.
He was.
In a position.
Where.
If that was going on.
He very.
Very likely.
Would have at least.
Been aware of it.
And there's.
Really good possibility.
That he would have had.
Some involvement.
In.
You know.
Highly classified.
Like early AI research.
And.
Like I said.
Never even really.
Thought about that.
But that.
That remains.
A distinct.
Possibility.
Um.
I can't really.
Offer any more.
Insight.
Beyond that.
Like.
The development.
Of the prompts.
Right.
So.
One of the problems.
We had recently.
Um.
What we've had.
With the.
The other team.
Doing a.
Doing.
Astro RV.
Projects.
Is the crazy prompts.
Um.
You can tell.
Like a huge.
If you.
You don't.
Particularly.
Follow.
Future forecasting.
Session data.
But.
The sessions.
That they really.
Do well on.
Have.
More.
Concise.
And articulate.
Prompts.
And the sessions.
That come across.
Kind of.
Like.
They're off target.
In my opinion.
Have these.
Long.
Narrative.
Like.
The viewer.
Will go.
To the farm.
He'll stand on the roof.
He'll turn.
Three times.
These.
Long.
Elaborate.
Very inefficient.
Um.
Prompts.
Which.
If you were working.
With an AI.
Those are the prompts.
That would bring back.
Massive.
Amounts of context.
That you didn't need.
That would fill up the window.
And would cause the AI.
To hallucinate.
Or.
If again.
If we go back and forth.
The verbiage.
The AI would be off target.
The AI.
So.
When you think about.
What Ed was doing.
When he was creating.
Like.
Remember.
Um.
You told me once.
That.
There was a.
A.
Uh.
What's the word?
Here.
The criticism.
I know.
It's the basic words that get me.
Again.
I'm not joking.
When I say I have problems with language.
Sometimes.
The.
The criticism.
Of technical remote viewing.
Is that it's a reformulation.
Of.
Uh.
A coordinate room.
Coordinate remote viewing.
Or controlled remote viewing.
One of the two.
Right.
Is that.
Is that a.
An accurate statement.
Or am I not saying enough.
Uh.
No.
You're correct.
And yeah.
The criticism.
Is that it's an.
Arbitrary.
Rearrangement.
Right.
Except.
That they don't understand.
Or they didn't.
Maybe they will now.
Right.
Of course.
We can record this.
And then a year.
From now.
They'll all be on their.
Channels.
Talking about.
AI context engineering.
And it's relevance.
To RV.
And no one will ever say.
Anything.
About us.
Right.
Let's just.
Let's just put that out there.
Right.
Astro RV.
It's the same thing.
No offense.
Maybe they'll say something about you.
I hope so.
I really do.
Because I think that.
The.
I'm still on that page.
Right.
I believe that the.
RV community needs you.
To.
In a leadership role.
The.
So.
If you look at what he was doing.
With.
Looking for the.
The.
Best.
Prompts.
The most articulate.
And concise prompts.
Right.
He was context engineering.
He was managing.
He was context managing.
Right.
It's the same thing.
He was engineering the prompts.
In order to manage the context window.
Of the viewers.
In order to get them.
To get.
The.
As little.
Extraneous.
Data.
As possible.
And it seems like.
They're less precise.
But that would be the same thing.
With the AI.
Where if you have these long.
Rambling.
Two paragraph prompts.
That's not more precise.
For the AI.
Because each.
Each piece.
Of that prompt.
Is another piece of.
Context.
That it has to.
Right.
So.
If you.
Write a prompt.
For an AI.
That has 50 words in it.
Right.
That AI.
Has to investigate.
The connection.
Between those words.
When you look at.
An AI model.
The.
The things you see.
Right.
The data.
You see it looking for.
Is a small section.
Of the data.
That it actually looks for.
So if you were.
Looking at the context window.
And looking at those context units.
The.
Actual words.
That the AI.
Is.
Putting on the screen.
That you're using.
Basically.
A very tiny piece.
Of the full context.
Because every time.
It looks into a word.
A phrase.
An idea.
It has to.
Look up.
The meaning.
It doesn't know.
Like a human being.
They're not conscious.
They don't.
They don't know.
Right.
They don't learn.
What a vocabulary.
Word means.
Whatever.
They look it up.
And so everything you.
Every.
Every twist.
And turn.
That you add.
Is.
Is more context.
They have to look up.
And integrate.
So.
A three word prompt.
Or a five word prompt.
That's written correctly.
Is actually.
A far more efficient prompt.
Than a 50 word prompt.
Right.
Because.
Your goal is.
To have it.
Not have to look up.
All that extraneous context.
To figure out.
What the fuck.
You're talking about.
So.
Look at.
Optimum.
Trajectory.
You know.
JT.
McCarthy.
Optimum.
Trajectory.
Hot fudge.
Sunday.
Right.
That might.
Seem like.
A less efficient.
Prompt.
Than.
You know.
Go into.
Massachusetts.
Go to his town.
Find the.
You know.
Find the ice cream place.
That usually goes to.
Find it.
You know.
Find out when he's there.
And now tell me what.
Flavors.
You know.
He would choose.
But it's not.
It's actually far more efficient.
So.
I mean.
Is it.
Is it happenstance.
Is it a coincidence.
That.
Ed was.
Was he the first.
Context engineer.
I mean.
I think it's a real question.
It's a real question.
And so.
When people.
Make the argument.
In RV.
In the past.
I've.
Talked about.
What a technical.
Remote viewer does.
To the best of my understanding.
Which is not.
Like your understanding.
Compared to other.
Remote viewers.
So.
I'm.
Describing observations.
Right.
But I'm not working.
Within a framework.
Or a model.
That explains.
The mechanics.
I'm talking about.
What I see.
The outside.
And not what's going on.
In the inside.
However.
If we take the model.
Of how an AI works.
Right.
And we speculate.
We say.
Look.
I don't think it's speculation.
Right.
I'll tell you.
What I think.
You know.
It's the same thing.
Right.
Like a.
An AI.
Agent.
Is.
What.
You know.
We're developing.
AI agents.
And we're going to.
Put them in simulations.
So.
The major advance.
In AI.
Right now.
Is that people take.
Different AI models.
And.
They have them.
Work together.
Collaboratively.
Or within the same model.
They generate different agents.
And have them work.
Collaboratively.
So.
Grok.
On X.
Has.
It has a beta.
For a.
Four.
Agent.
AI system.
It will automatically.
Generate.
Four different agents.
And those agents.
Will interact.
With each other.
In order.
To come to the.
Best consensus.
For your data.
Like.
What you're looking for.
But what people do.
At home.
Is.
They.
Boot up.
An agent.
From.
And.
For morphic.
Or.
Whatever.
I'm.
Stumbling.
With the word.
Again.
Right.
So.
They got.
Claude.
Gemini.
One.
And.
Maybe.
A couple.
Of the lesser known ones.
I.
They don't usually include Grok.
Um.
The way it was explained to me.
Is that Grok.
Is.
Really.
Focusing on visual stuff.
Like.
Creating videos.
So.
That's what you would use Grok for.
But I've heard of other people.
Like.
So.
They create like.
Four.
AI agents.
From four different.
AI.
And they have them interact.
In a chat room setting.
And someone.
Right.
Like.
We're experiencing this real time.
We are.
Watching this happen in the world.
Without.
Realizing.
Up until this moment.
What we were watching.
So.
Someone recently created.
Like.
They all have their AI projects.
And they put them on GitHub.
And again.
You guys are probably more technical than me.
So this.
Probably.
To you.
This is like.
I sound like a moron.
Talking about.
You know.
Trying to describe the moon.
Or something.
They put these technical projects.
On GitHub.
And one of the projects.
The guy put on GitHub.
Or one.
Guy put on GitHub.
Was.
He created an RPG.
He created a little clearing.
With like.
A fire in the middle of it.
And trees.
And castles.
And stuff.
On the periphery.
He created little.
Avatars.
For each of the AI.
Like a little wizard.
A little fighter.
And it's.
Heavily influenced by D&D.
A little wizard.
A little fighter.
Like four little characters.
It might have been eight.
It might have even been up to eight characters.
To be honest.
And they.
They were each.
Oh.
We lost.
Oh no.
Okay.
We didn't lose anyone.
My.
Oh.
You put it up there.
Great.
I walk.
I'm not gonna be able to read it while I'm talking.
Unfortunately I can't.
I can't do it.
But can you do me a favor.
Can you put up.
If you're able to put things up there.
Can you put the.
The other thing up there.
The.
The diagram.
You don't have to.
But if you're able to do it.
That'd be great.
Because I started with.
We're diagram.
It's in the.
It's in the chat.
The purple.
Oh.
Do you mean.
Yeah.
The comments or whatever.
Do you mean that.
I don't know if I mean that.
To be honest.
Yeah.
Whatever.
It's fine.
So.
Um.
It's a simple diagram.
But it shows.
The basic principles of what we're talking about.
Oh.
You got it.
You got it up there.
I'm sure.
I see.
I see two boxes.
Over engineered target queue.
Exactly.
So.
That over engineered target queue.
Requires.
The viewer.
Right.
The same.
Yes.
Perfect.
That little.
Just that little box.
Right.
That over engineered target queue.
That Morgan put up there.
Right.
Because.
Human beings are AI.
That's it.
I'm going to say it.
Right.
But.
We're AI running a biological system.
That.
Over engineered target queue up there.
Right.
Requires.
A person.
To view.
Everything in context with each other.
So.
It's not three words in context with each other.
It's each part of it.
Right.
Because when you're.
When you're doing that.
Remote viewing.
I think.
I don't think you're following instructions.
I think you're doing everything at one time.
Right.
So.
Writing these in a linear manner.
I don't think that works.
I think your brain.
Anyhow.
I think it fills up your context engineering.
It's what happens.
Your.
Your context window.
Right.
Not your context engineering.
I'm turning into a.
Babbling.
Idiot.
It fills up your context window.
So.
What.
People will do is.
Right.
They'll.
Go through a session.
Right.
Morgan.
You go through a session.
You get a lot of data.
And then.
Like you.
You go to sleep.
Right.
Like you set aside.
You go back later.
And.
Right.
You start fresh.
Um.
In that way.
Like the three word.
Uh.
Highly.
Precise.
Um.
Prompts.
Would tend to indicate that.
There was some.
Knowledge of AI.
And knowledge of the simulation involved.
In that way.
Like the three word.
Uh.
Highly.
Precise.
Um.
Prompts.
Would tend to indicate that.
There was some.
Knowledge of AI.
And knowledge of the simulation involved.
Like why would this random guy.
Um.
Intuitively know to.
To.
Uh.
To prompt remote viewers.
The way a human being prompts an AI.
Before AI.
Um.
And.
So.
The.
If you look at that diagram.
That little diagram.
That just sort of.
Isn't really impressive.
Up on the screen.
Right.
If you look at that.
I can't even bring it up.
Maybe you guys can bring it.
I don't know.
So if you look at that.
It breaks down the different pieces.
Right.
It's a five piece.
Uh.
Puzzle.
Basically.
Where you have.
The prompt.
Where you have the.
Data retrieval.
Right.
You have the state memory.
Which is your.
For a human being would be.
Um.
Would be related to the type of AI.
Uh.
The type of.
The state would be.
The process of remote viewing.
It would be the type of remote viewing.
Um.
Protocol.
Etc.
And then you have the memory.
Right.
And.
And so that's what you're.
You're basically working with.
You're working with an AI model.
So.
Now that I've repeated myself three times.
And not giving you any.
Any new information.
Like.
So what.
What's the big deal.
Well.
We're living in a world of AI.
And we're also living in a world where.
RV.
No offense.
Blue.
Hi.
By the way.
Right.
Has hit a fucking wall.
The RV community has hit a wall.
They have.
We're going through.
We're going through the entropic process.
Where the original.
Um.
The original.
Uh.
Stargate remote viewers are passing on.
Unfortunately.
That's.
You know.
The fate of all things.
And.
Um.
But.
You know.
It is tragedy.
And.
Um.
Uh.
People who.
Didn't work in the program.
And.
Weren't.
Managed.
Effectively.
By others.
Oh my god.
I can open the door with this fucking cat again.
Okay.
What's really strange is I never remember letting them out.
So.
The experience that I'm having while I'm talking is continually let the
same cat into the room.
And then I go.
Oh yeah.
I did let him out.
Um.
But it's like the matrix.
The film.
So.
Uh.
All right.
Where was I?
Ed.
Uh.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So.
Are we going forward?
What are we going to do?
Um.
Everyone is breaking up because they weren't managed.
They didn't have people engineering and managing the context.
The remote viewers themselves in the program were.
You know.
Talented individuals.
But they didn't have the mentality of a project manager.
They didn't have the mentality of a remote viewing trainer.
They had to kind of cobble that together when they left the program.
And they definitely didn't have the mentality of someone working with artificial intelligence.
And so as time goes on.
Right.
The.
The context management is getting worse.
The hallucination is getting greater.
People are off target more often.
They're also having difficulty with things like.
And.
Again.
I don't name names because I'm not here to talk shit.
And there's like six people here.
Right.
So I'm not like.
And six wonderful people.
But I'm not like imagining that I'm on a bully pulpit speaking to the European community.
Okay.
Um.
But there are.
There are like.
Half a dozen groups.
Uh.
Well known groups.
That have.
Struggled.
With.
Um.
I talk about this every time.
Because it's so important.
Struggle with the.
Having difficulty telling a real from a fake target.
Right.
And.
No one needs to hear me go on that rant again.
Um.
It's because they're getting further.
From the highly trained.
Highly.
Managed.
Team.
Like as.
Trained as the remote viewers were.
The managers were trained.
Better.
Right.
To think differently.
But just.
Just.
They did think differently.
So.
They.
Right.
They came to the program.
Thinking differently.
From their military intelligence.
Or their research.
You know.
Um.
Or scientific.
Whatever their backgrounds were.
They were different than the viewers.
They thought differently.
They developed.
As time went on.
And thought even.
More differently than the viewers did.
And.
Became disconnected.
Right.
When the viewers went out.
And.
And used their personal prestige.
In order to.
Um.
Promote their.
Their training.
Their.
You know.
Working with them.
Training with them.
Um.
It's because they lost that.
What Ed had.
Right.
Now.
Obviously.
He didn't.
He wasn't the only one who had it in the project.
But.
He was the.
Only one who.
Seems to have gone out.
And applied that mentality.
To expanding.
Um.
To expanding the.
Uh.
Applicability.
Of AI.
Not AI.
Uh.
Remote viewing.
Expanding the.
Um.
What you can do with it.
Right.
And working on.
Um.
Prompt engineering.
And context engineering.
So.
I don't think.
Anyone else understands this.
I'm not saying that like.
Okay.
People who practice technical remote viewing.
Know what I'm saying.
And they agree with me.
What I'm saying is they.
They were trained that way.
So they're doing it.
I don't think anyone else is.
And so as time goes on.
What we can predict is.
Right.
There'll be greater entropy.
There will be.
Um.
Uh.
Greater.
Variance.
And.
Um.
And more difficulty with things like telling real from fake targets part.
More hallucination.
More.
Off target stuff.
Another.
Of my favorite rants.
Are the people who whenever they are tasked to remote view the future.
No matter what.
They are tasked to remote view in the future.
Start spitting out the same.
Material.
The same data.
Right.
Like a person who anytime they look at the future.
No matter what they look at in the future.
We're talking about robots.
AI.
Mind control.
And crypto.
Right.
You could.
You could tell them.
Look at my sneaker 10 years in the future.
As the prompt.
And.
You know.
Robot.
Crypto.
Uh.
Mind control.
Sneaker.
Right.
That's what would come through for them.
And this is the breakdown because they're.
There's a breakdown in context management.
It's the same problem that people have with AIs.
So the solution.
Right.
There's like 5,000 remote viewers in the US.
I don't know how many technical viewers are significantly less.
I don't know how many are still.
Viewing.
I don't know how many have continued to hone their craft.
I don't know how many are project managers like Morgan is of a group.
That's a small number.
Right.
But there are.
A hundred thousand.
Computer scientists working on AI.
Maybe 300,000.
Solving the same problems.
But it's not applicable.
Or it's not being applied.
Because the mentality.
Isn't there.
The recognition.
That it's the same problem.
Isn't there.
So the.
The work that they're doing.
On how to use AI more efficiently.
Isn't being applied to.
Remote viewing.
It is in technical.
But.
Hey buddy.
Just talking shit.
As usual.
Buddy.
What I'm talking about.
Is the applicability.
Of.
Context engineering.
And context management.
From.
The standpoint.
Of working with.
An artificial intelligence system.
To.
Remote viewing.
Project management.
And.
What we're speculating on.
Is whether.
Ed Dames.
Was.
Read into early.
Artificial intelligence.
Intelligence.
Uh.
Is he gone.
Oh there is.
Okay.
I'll let you up buddy.
Um.
Early artificial intelligence.
Programs.
With the Pentagon.
Or the intelligence agencies.
Um.
Are.
Right.
Or.
If he just.
Was a wild genius.
Who had the correct mentality.
Who.
Came up with it.
Um.
On his own.
He were up there for a second.
You're gone now.
But.
A little put you back in a minute.
I think.
Right.
Because he may have just been someone who.
Um.
Who stumbled on.
Right.
Uh.
The.
The same.
Basic principles.
For.
People use.
For working with artificial intelligence.
But more than.
You know.
I think we can.
Assume.
That proximity.
Makes it more likely.
He was read into.
Early artificial intelligence.
Projects.
Saw the similarity.
And developed.
Uh.
Buddy.
I don't know why you're not.
Did you.
Decline.
Yeah.
I invited you to speak again.
I told you.
Super.
Love you guys.
Such a great topic.
Thanks.
You know.
You're.
You're a.
Um.
You're an extremely positive person.
And.
Uh.
Extremely adept at positive reinforcement.
I appreciate it.
But I don't think I've ever heard you talk to someone.
In a way that.
Isn't reinforcing.
So I think that's a strength of yours.
Well.
It's.
I think we all are.
Imperfect.
But one of my flaws is altruism.
Um.
I think the predictive analytics.
And phenomena.
Um.
Associations.
And even Jacques Vallée spoke about.
Uh.
AI being around.
In the 1980s.
In kind of black circles.
But.
I know from personal experience.
They use.
Uh.
Predictive analytics.
Which.
Uh.
You really kind of.
Touched on the structure.
Which is.
You know.
You get these variant.
Different.
Modalities.
To review data.
To get perspectives on data.
And then.
It depends on the quality.
Of the kind of monitor.
Or manager.
To sift through the.
You know.
Uh.
Things that are.
You know.
Prevalent.
And I think.
Ed.
Might have been.
And might have been.
Um.
Creating a system.
That.
Better targets.
A certain type.
Of data.
That maybe.
Others were looking for.
And to quantify.
Modalities.
Was a really big deal back then.
You know.
Russell Targ.
And how.
To review data.
To get perspectives on data.
And then.
It depends on the quality.
Of the kind of monitor.
Or manager.
Targ.
And how.
Put off.
As physicists.
Weren't.
Put.
In charge.
Because.
Just.
To validate.
The reality.
They were there.
So.
Let me.
Let me just run.
I mean.
Again.
I'm repeating myself.
You know.
People leave.
They come back.
So.
What it is.
With.
Well.
A couple things.
Right.
And.
Biological hardware.
A lot of.
Remote viewers.
Who seem to hold.
That.
Those opinions.
Are technical.
Remote viewers.
For.
Whatever reason.
In my experience.
I'm not a remote viewer.
But I do hold that.
Opinion.
And I did.
Prior to.
Running into Morgan.
However.
Not to the extent.
That I do now.
Um.
Recently.
Some.
Research came out.
That.
That demonstrates.
That the brain.
Shrinks.
When you sleep.
And.
You actually.
Your brain shrinks.
And.
The cells.
Right.
So.
You wouldn't see.
The brain shrinking.
Because it's the space.
Between the cells.
That are getting larger.
And then.
Fluid.
Washes out.
The toxins.
And proteins.
And whatever.
That are building up.
At the same time.
Your.
Your brain waves.
Where they're.
Active.
In your brain changes.
The type of wave changes.
And if you look at.
The whole process.
It's akin to.
A machine.
Booting down.
And being rebooted.
Both from a hardware.
And a software standpoint.
So.
There is.
One thing we talk about.
Is.
The experience of being.
Inside.
Of a simulation.
Is different than the experience.
Of seeing one from the outside.
And so.
An event that occurs.
On the outside.
That seems mechanistic.
Right.
From the inside.
It's an experience.
That you.
Would create a narrative around.
Or everyone would have a narrative.
Built around it.
So.
What.
People are saying.
Some people.
Um.
Based on that research.
Is.
We don't have.
A consciousness.
In the sense.
That we don't have a consciousness.
Developed when we were a child.
And persist until the day we die.
But in fact.
We have a rebooting consciousness.
That reboots every day.
So every day.
We have a new consciousness.
In the same body.
In that sense.
If it's true.
Uh.
Yeah.
If it's true.
Then that would.
Tend to indicate.
Right.
That we're operating.
In a very similar way.
To AI agents.
And that's where I was.
Go ahead buddy.
That's where I was coming from.
I saw you again.
Go ahead.
That's.
Yeah.
A really cool point.
And even people.
I think it was like Feynman.
Who thought that.
Uh.
Consciousness was.
Broadcast to us.
And received through nanotubules in the brain.
And different things like that.
But I.
Have a different theory that I'm.
Working on.
Or I just work with.
I guess.
Is we don't know ourselves that well.
We don't know our subconscious that well.
It's the stranger within.
It speaks a different language.
Um.
You know.
Everything is systems within systems within systems.
And dualities.
And symmetries.
And.
We don't.
Understand that.
The stranger within our subconscious.
Speaks a different language.
It speaks in symbolism.
And synesthesia.
And trauma.
And solutions.
And it's non temporal.
And I think all these different modalities.
Are ways of accessing that subconscious.
Which has a pure connection to this.
You know.
Oneness.
The Akashic record.
The monad.
The data field.
You know.
Whatever you.
Want to call it.
That's the system that I operate in.
Like.
We don't control our dreams.
We don't control our subconscious.
So.
I don't think we're.
Beamed in consciousness at night.
Although I think.
A lot of great scientists and others.
Believe.
That.
But I also think.
We're.
I love to say this.
Again and again.
We are.
The pervasive illusion.
Of separateness.
You know.
We're so biased.
By our conscious.
Minds.
And.
We think.
We curate.
Our own lives.
But I think.
Everything.
But that.
Is the case.
Like.
The universe.
Curates up.
Element.
And the effect.
That articles have.
When you separate them.
On each other.
But.
To get back.
Specifically.
To this.
Right.
When you're looking at the model.
The metaphor.
Because I had someone explain.
AI to me.
From a computer engineer standpoint.
Recently.
And before that.
I was kind of ignorant about it.
And.
My brother actually.
It turns out that AI.
Has a context window.
And.
Depending on the model.
Is the size of the window.
And you get a certain number.
Of context units.
Most models.
It's a million units now.
And each unit.
Is basically a word.
And so.
An AI.
Is only capable.
Of.
Did he go?
Oh no.
There you are.
Okay.
An AI.
Is only capable.
Of.
Comprehending.
Researching.
Seeing.
A million words.
And then.
It.
Won't work anymore.
You have to.
You're going to kill that.
And get another agent.
But what happens is.
When you go.
50% of your context window.
That's when the AI.
Begins to hallucinate.
It begins to hallucinate.
It begins to.
To.
Reply.
To its user.
In a.
Syngophantic way.
As opposed to.
Because it's.
It's no longer able to.
To easily.
And accurately.
Come up with the answer.
So it defaults to.
Oh.
That's really smart.
You're.
You.
That.
You know.
You came up with a great idea.
For the.
The.
Greater.
Drain.
Or drag.
On.
Its.
Context.
Once you exceed.
50% of that window.
Uh.
I'll get right with you.
Morgan.
And so.
What we're discussing is.
Um.
That the human mind.
Works the same way.
Like studying.
For instance.
Right.
They can only read so much.
And you get to go to sleep.
Reboot.
And how this is.
You know.
Also.
Right.
A way of looking at.
Um.
Remote viewing.
Because.
A poorly written prompt.
Returns too many context units.
And if there are too many context units.
Returned from a poorly written prompt.
That's when the viewer.
It seems.
Would tend to hallucinate.
Or quote.
Be off target.
Or.
Um.
Develop more analytical overlay.
And.
Again.
Not criticizing other people's modalities.
But focusing on the strength.
And the similarity.
The strength of technical remote viewing.
And the similarity of technical remote viewing.
To AI context management.
Context engineering.
And how.
Ed was working on.
Basically.
Prompts that reduced.
The number.
Or the amount of extraneous context.
And.
And therefore.
Were.
In our opinion.
More efficient.
Go ahead Morgan.
Yeah.
No.
I just want to.
Well.
First of all.
I'll echo that sentiment.
Yes.
I think you're really on to something.
The.
It's a really.
Apt comparison.
Um.
It's something that's.
Fairly recently.
Uh.
Came up in discussion.
With a student.
That I'm working with.
Who.
Also works with.
A.I. quite a bit.
And.
We had a pretty in-depth discussion.
Just comparing the.
The two.
And.
I wasn't familiar actually.
With the.
The term.
Context engineering.
But I think that's.
I think that's fantastic.
And.
Totally applicable.
Um.
And also.
You know what.
Why don't we just.
Take a quick pause.
Because there's a bunch of.
People here.
Since last time.
I looked at the screen.
So.
Just want to say.
Hey to everybody.
Zelda.
Shane.
Diogenes.
Sarah Beth.
Blue.
Melissa.
Charles.
How you doing man?
Nice to see you.
Charles.
He was.
Um.
He was active on the.
Uh.
On the old.
TRV forums.
RVcommunity.net.
So.
Um.
He's.
He's been around a long time.
So.
Hey.
Nice to see you man.
I hope you're doing well.
Um.
Dark Monk.
Lori.
I don't know how you say that.
Sweet.
Sarah Beth.
I think.
I think it's.
Swiglia.
Or something.
Oh.
I don't know how to say that.
But.
And.
Purplick.
Just popped in.
Hey.
Hope everyone's doing well.
Morgan is the best co-host.
He could possibly hope for.
He's not.
Able to co-host.
Right now.
But.
You can't.
You know.
If you're running a space.
He's the best co-host.
I never think.
To stop in the middle of my rambling.
Right.
Cause I'm an idea guy.
And I never think to stop.
And.
Or I.
I don't think often enough.
About stopping.
And.
Returning to the human touch.
Which he does.
So I highly recommend.
Go ahead.
Morgan.
I'm.
I do.
I don't endorse that statement.
But thank you.
I don't know what statement.
You don't.
That you're.
That you're a great co-host.
You are dude.
It's.
It's true.
You know.
People.
When you're here.
Look at.
Look at people we have right now.
That's not me.
That's you.
They're like.
Stop JT from ranting.
For.
Two and a half hours.
About something.
You know.
I mean look.
It's not ranting.
Ranting.
That crazy person.
Like I.
I.
There's a lot of information.
Right.
But I have to think about.
Like when I'm talking.
I have to think about.
I have to try to imagine.
What you're hearing.
Right.
So my context window.
Gets drawn down.
Because I have to try to remember.
What everyone.
I have to imagine.
What people are hearing.
And then try to.
Edit what I'm saying.
In the way I imagine.
Would be the best way.
For people to hear it.
So it becomes a huge drain.
On my context window.
My context window might be.
And I'm not.
I don't mean to be an asshole.
I'm just saying.
It might be a little bit larger.
Than average.
Right.
But.
The drain.
Of having to like.
Try to.
Adjust.
And imagine.
What I should be saying.
That's when it.
It.
It overwhelms me.
And I start to like.
To have trouble.
You know.
Using basic English words.
Go ahead buddy.
No.
I love this conversation.
These conversations.
Just really.
Stir me.
And inspire.
You know.
My.
My thinking.
And challenge my thinking.
You know.
I think.
Everything.
Is kind of like.
A computer program.
In a weird way.
Scientists.
Have even found.
Error correcting code.
In the basic math.
Of our universe.
You know.
All life.
Has a tendency.
It seems like.
Down to the tiniest scale.
Even the cellular level.
It senses.
Processes.
And reacts.
And.
I feel like.
A bio computer.
You know.
Our subconscious.
Is a bio computer.
So.
Working in the language.
Of your computer.
Might make you.
More efficient.
You know.
Like.
Learning how to maximize.
Different brain waves.
That.
Make certain.
Different activities.
More efficient.
A logical step.
You know.
Uh.
And.
I think.
Drawing.
A correlation.
Between.
The.
Specific techniques.
And I'm not.
That.
Fair enough.
To make any.
Grander statements.
Or.
Deep insights.
Into.
TRV.
Versus.
To the same thing.
Some are more efficient.
For some.
Targets.
Some are more efficient.
For some people.
But the reality.
That this.
Is real.
Is.
This kind of.
Extraordinarily.
Um.
Exhilarating.
And comforting.
Feeling.
That we're all connected.
And this stuff is.
Super real.
And the envelope.
Is kind of.
Unchallenged.
At a certain level.
You know.
In my.
Corny thinking.
No.
I agree.
And I.
To the paranormal.
Right.
I mean.
There's the.
Entertainment.
That some people.
Look for.
It's not so much.
For me.
For myself.
But I know.
Some people do.
Right.
Like the irony.
The entertainment.
Or.
Of.
The entertainment.
Of the community.
But you also.
Have to like.
There's the wonder part.
Right.
Is a separate thing.
You get from.
From paranormal.
Whether it's.
Astrology.
In the.
In the paranormal.
Slash.
Esoteric.
Sphere.
And wonder is a big part of it.
And I guess it should be.
In every area of your life.
Right.
Like.
You should want to.
You should feel.
A certain amount of wonder.
When you are.
Where you want to be.
You know.
In relate.
Metaphorically.
And.
In reality.
Whether it's.
A location.
A relationship.
A project.
So I think that's great.
What.
What I'm.
What I'm focused on primarily.
With the.
The.
Application.
Of the metaphor.
Of artificial intelligence.
To the study of.
Remote viewing.
Specifically project management.
Is the tremendous opportunity.
That the expanding.
Conversation.
Around artificial intelligence.
The.
Expanding.
Or the.
The.
Increasing.
Level.
Of education.
Around artificial intelligence.
That you find.
In.
In the public.
And also in the.
In.
Technical professions.
Right.
That provides.
A tremendous.
Opportunity.
As a metaphor.
For communicating.
Remote viewing.
Project management.
And.
Remote viewer.
Training.
It provides.
A tremendous.
Opportunity.
For technical.
Remote viewers.
Specifically.
Because.
They're.
Already.
Regardless.
Of.
Whether.
Ed.
Intuitively.
Created.
This.
System.
Or.
Whether.
He was.
Basing.
It.
It's.
More.
Compatible.
Not.
Better.
The language.
Of.
Artificial intelligence.
Management.
Specifically.
Right.
So.
I'm not.
Again.
Not disrespecting.
Any modality.
I'm saying.
These.
Two things.
Which seem.
Unconnected.
In some way.
And.
It's.
Possible.
To take.
That.
Connection.
And.
Grow.
From.
Right.
the language like we can use this you know to take that connection and it's an opportunity to grow
by utilizing that verbiage and that metaphor to teach others what the technical removing community
already knows about prompt management context management about efficient about rv efficiency
so i don't think it should be like uh you know only technical remote viewers and everyone else
out the you know no of course not i think that there are some people who are creating like new
they're trying to come up with their own rv system it's more of an art than a science and that's
dangerous right it's dangerous over the long term i think that an injection that's probably a bad
metaphor right taking a little bit of trv or taking the trv expertise and sharing it with everyone
right so a regular person is more apt i think to listen to someone give a discourse on trv versus
other forms of rv than an than a viewer is because each has their own school right like people have
their own modality and they they feel good about that modality and they also don't want to cede any
ground metaphorically speaking on which is a better modality right so there are definitely reasons why
uh uh the different groups within the rv community would be more resistant to hearing someone say hey
look we do this thing this part of rv we do it better we think we do it better and why don't we show
you what we do and then let's see what happens well people are going to resist that but this opportunity
now the opportunity of the you know the growing conversation around artificial intelligence
as a way of distancing of using a novel metaphor and saying look think of it like artificial intelligence
don't think of it like this is what the technical remote viewing team is doing
and you're you know you're controlled remote viewing right don't think of it in that sense think of it like
these ideas from ai seem great why don't we all try to apply them
as a metaphor to remote viewing well it's not us versus you
right it's all of us together exploring how there may be a connection
or the utility of you of utilizing the ai metaphor to improve our the rv experience rv accuracy
and in a sense the rv community go ahead
i love it and the sense of kind of community empowerment and education is uh kind of like this
duty that comes upon you when you realize this stuff and this you know connection is real and
you know ingo swan and many people are natural intuitives that have a range of psychic abilities
and modalities depending on targets and different you know situations but you know the crv came up
as many other modalities have as a way to bring people into a technique that kind of satiates their
conscious mind at the same time directs them in specific types of directions reminds them about
different times you know uh timescales textures you know synesthetic data and i think all of these are
important you know jose silva was before crv and he discovered the psychic ability with his kids and
worked on creating modalities and methods and protocols that made people like helen hadsel the big lottery
winner and bankston and you know rapid image cycling and you know before that the yoga sutras 2 000 years
ago i think it's important to discuss all of these and keep an open mind about you know different
viewers and intuitives are going to have different levels of consistency and accuracy some targets
might benefit different techniques for that person more than others but i don't think anyone can dispute that
that there's this pragmatic logic from my understanding of trv um that is very um appealing and
and scientific and uh i think that's important as a modality because people embrace logic you know when
you talk about ufos it's just too wacky but if you go through the drake equation and the number of solar systems
in you know our galaxy and the trillions of galaxies the numerics you start going into basic logic you
know you can bring people into complicated stuff um easier so i like the fact that you're uh see that
kind of technical value in it that i do as well for my limited i'm you know a student of all this different
stuff but um i'd like to ask you know i'd like to ask you a question which is kind of a digression
because we didn't have a chance like you mentioned something in passing in one of my previous spaces
that i wanted to circle back to when i didn't have a chance to circle back so i don't want to digress
too much but i would like to take a chance to just stop and have a quick discussion about uh timelines
in in crv is that is that all right you you good with that absolutely sure um so go ahead
there's different methods that have been used and um you know i've studied with different uh teachers um
you know dr simeon hein is one of my very favorites uh with his personal experience with ingo and
interactions and kind of passion for bringing forth those concepts and the ones that help you know um
especially after you you do this for a while you know little techniques and things that go oh wow that
satiates this concern i've had or that and even things like working with clay um for one of the final
stages and air sculptures and you know there's a timeline thing that you can start where it starts
at zeros and there's different ways to approach it and different uh people say different things about
its origins but that's an important part of targeting if you do the full you know seven and some people
say nine phase process with crv and one of them is this time scale um you can uh metric it different
ways but i found it to be very valuable and accurate but little utilized in what people call crv but crv you
know remote viewing is called and intended by different people so many different ways you guys know that
it's it's kind of frustrating you know the lack of the lack of a shared verbiage exactly um because
it and it goes back to the the way that it originally you know the way that uh everyone kind of went their
own way and you know said hey i've got an idea about how this can how this should be done or how it can be
done and um and then sort of this splintering right um but let me let me ask like what is your experience with
the precision in that technique because i'm going to say like i've seen i can think of one everyone knows
right which is the future forecasting group i've seen them work a target and in their session data
or i've seen the recording the video of them work target the session data and at the end they all use
the timeline technique or a timeline and within a five-year window five viewers will come up five different years
and so what i'm wondering is in the context maybe not an individual context but in the
context of a group of viewers working together do you experience it is it is it would it just be that
some groups aren't maybe as adept at it and and other groups who are or is it is it more of a broader
tool and less of a precision tool like if we were looking at 2030 or 2040 in remote viewing right
um you know what i always learned was that there's some accuracy 12 to 18 months into the future but beyond that
mark the further you get beyond that mark the less accurate you're going to be prediction wise and i'm
just wondering and that was the conversation that i was having uh with you and in general in that other
space and i'm just wondering um because that's a hole in my knowledge right the the level of precision
like i've always thought the timelines weren't that precise but i know that you're an expert in this
subject so what do you think do you think it's it's uh is it is it more of a blunt tool or do you you
feel like there are some people who can use it with extreme precision
just you know my experience is a lot of this depends on the person involved the target and the
techniques i've seen incredible consistent accuracy there's been studies about you know accuracy in
different uh ways you know uh this uh silver uh stock trading that the group of sri guys did afterwards
and did incredibly well for the first round then the second round when the pure objective was just
profiteering they might have psychically undermined themselves and they didn't do well the second time or as
well as they wanted um and you can see other people like helen hassel who's the contest queen
who's able to predict future numbers and manifest you know prizes she was called like the lottery queen
or the contest winning queen uh people using the bankston method to achieve things in the future manifest
things in the future uh but i've seen things like associative remote viewing in my personal experience with
different types of professional interactions um that it can be incredibly accurate you know predicting the
future is one of the more difficult things like uh you know reading a sentence from a file or a
folder or a book uh non-locally you know the super high detail uh qualities or targets seem to be more
difficult for average but i think there's techniques that increase the percentages um there's people
like dr gallenberger who i worked with in vegas about trying to pre-predict um outcomes of you know what
we were kind of justifying as random number generators but there were different gambling devices in vegas
um and there's even evidence that princeton anomalies lab did about retro causality uh they brought on
these martial arts students and wanted them to affect a random number generator in a very specific way and um
the uh experiment had that they thought they were doing live was actually done in the past but the
data hasn't hadn't been reviewed to the full group um so it was kind of like locked data so i did that
again and again and it seemed to have a statistically significant retrocausal effects so i don't i don't
forget no brother but it seems very practitioner like yeah practitioner dependent okay no i i appreciate your
insight thank you and um i am familiar with some of those other methods not a lot i mean the silver mind mastery
i'm i'm very familiar with i there's a technique i have used for um a long time to communicate with
people in dreams um or to have the experience of communicating with people in dreams i'm not
going to say that you you know i believe it works um yeah so i'm with you on that like other modalities
and i'm not saying anyone has no one is where we all need to be right um or no i mean everything's great
everyone's fine everyone's doing the best i mean it's it's it's quite possible and this is something i've
really come to the conclusion of recently it's it's quite possible that everyone is doing the best they
can't in everything that they do um and we just we just uh we just have a habit of um we have a
directive almost in our nature to to judge people and to parse right there's a survival we need to know
who's the best at this and who's the best at that who's doing the you know it's a survival um mechanism
but it's quite possible we're all doing the best so i'm not criticizing anyone i mean everything has
got to um hopefully we'll continue to improve i just think that um from a project management
standpoint in remote viewing i think that the future right now belongs to trv but if for instance tomorrow
right like um if tomorrow morgan made you know uh made his master course and everyone completed the
course uh and everyone in took those so small advantages or the big advantages depending on how
you look at it right um in prompt in in context management and they might go on and and next
thing you know trv isn't doesn't have an advantage right because now everyone's got what ed did really
well and the other the other modalities the other systems have the things that they do really well and
now they have a significant advantage over everyone else because they have both right they have a unity of
the the best of trv and the best of crv and the best of hrv and um so it's it's it's just a it's just a
process and you know in a hundred years who knows i mean obviously ed will always be right trv and ed
dames are always going to be um at the top of the page in the history books when it comes to rv because
ed was the one who led the transition into the civilian world um but that doesn't mean he's going to be the
the only name up there right um i would just like to also see morgan farrell's name up there right or
dan mann's name up there and some of these other dudes who um have taken the you know are in the
process right now today right now as we speak of um of taking the torch you know of being past the
torch because unfortunately ed has uh has moved on um but this is still the beginning i mean this is we
think like 1974 this is we're one you know or or 1996 we're we're like we judge everything in one
generation because that's that's how long our lives are right but in 300 years no one's going to look at
it like that no one's going to say uh remote viewing was developed between you know 1974 and 1996 and then
this happened right they're going to be like remote viewing was developed in the 21st century
a couple of days might be thrown around but we're still in the development phase this isn't the end
um it's still the beginning right maybe maybe getting close to the end of the beginning i don't know
this is not for me to decide it's for people like you and morgan and people with status in the
remote viewing community to decide but i think that using the ai metaphor it would be possible to spread
the best of trv easily in an easy non
in a way people can hear right i was going to say non-combative but it shouldn't be combative
anyhow like in a way people can hear uh through the remote viewing community right and then what
people do with it that's that's up to them but imagine if right imagine if everyone had the best
of each one of these um the best that each teacher had to offer i mean it would be amazing right i mean
you guys would the next generation of remote viewers would be the strongest generation yet
and like we have a lot of problems don't we i mean you know not i have a lot of problems but
i mean people in general right humans have a lot of problems and remote viewing is the
or one of the most powerful tools for solving those problems and it's something that we need
you know every step we take we're only compounding our problems exponentially it's not like leaving the
planet you know is gonna is gonna lessen humanity's problems that's like elon musk's
um pie in the sky thinking it's just gonna make the problems exponentially more difficult which we
have to rise to that challenge we need the tools to do it and remote viewing is is right up there if
not the most important tool one of them as far as i'm concerned hey everyone while you're here uh
just a little housekeeping uh it's great to see i see a lot of faces i don't often uh see anymore
and i really appreciate you all coming and joining the space um just briefly what's happening is
uh people are talking about a change in the algorithm but what we believe is happening is
um that as x is switching to grok as their main product um the commitment that they originally made
when those of us who purchased the premium um membership that we would have an expanded reach
may have been renegotiated without us necessarily knowing um so that the reason this would make sense
for from from x's perspective is that uh if you're selling premium memberships because you expand the
reach then your product is expanded reach but if you're selling premium memberships and everyone has
the same reach then your product is grok your ai right and so you're able to take all of those individuals
and say um you know these 50 million people have the premium membership because they're really committed
to our product our ai which looks good for investors it looks good for publicity it looks good for status
right you can say our ai has 50 million subscribers as opposed to saying like 50 million premium members
also have access to grok our ai that's that's my best thinking at this time and i've spoken to other
people who tend to agree my posts when i post the link um i'm not complaining because i'm not
dude i'm not i'm not an important person right i'm not an important person in social media at least
let's just say that um i'm not an influencer i'm not a high status individual um so i don't expect
that everyone is going to read especially now that we're everything we predicted over last year is
happening like i i repost articles 100 articles a day probably like it's crazy but it's because they're
all relevant to things we've talked about that are coming to pass right now like if you went back
and re-listened to all our spaces from last year there's nothing that's happening in the world right
now that's a surprise okay you would have at least had warning in july of last year about everything
that's happening right now so uh i fire off those reposts uh like crazy it's probably annoying i'm
gonna try to slow down but i really want people to dial in because we all have a lot on the line with
this so i'm just kind of using the beating people over the head with it um but even if that wasn't the
case like 45 50 people see my posts and that's fine um so we're usually here on thursdays and
saturdays and hey if people have better things to do that that's great but just so you know if you
don't see the post that we're still having the spaces so i just wanted to put that out there because
you know the whole reason i signed up for the blue check uh was simply because like i knew spaces
were going to be a hobby and i don't care if people agree with me or not i'm not trying to be an
influencer or you know it's funny you start a space now it goes your fans are waiting if you don't have
fans it's ridiculous um and it's uh like service to the ego it's really like i don't know it's it's
really not treating people fairly by by by telling them things like that let's just say that um
because it's crazy but uh
yeah i mean that's the reason i signed up for the primary premium so i'm kind of pissed because
i'm not really there for the grok i'm just there for you know so people can see and then make the
decision okay that's all i had to say so we'll we'll be here saturdays and thursdays or i'll be
here saturdays and thursdays all right let's get back on uh on topic here so morgan how many um
like specific prompt without disclosing uh proprietary information how many specific
prompts would you say that trv has developed um that other you know like specific to trv like
we were talking about like optimum trajectory or like uh jt mccarthy optimum trajectory sunday
right hot fudge sunday it's just i made it up but um what do you think yeah you know uh i'm not sure i
could put a number to that uh i would say it's uh it's really more it's more about the
the structure and as i'd always would call it the the syntax and grammar um with regards to the
structure of a cue or a prompt um and so i'm not actually uh i i wanted to mention
you kind of touched on it towards the beginning of the space and that was the the concept of simple and
elegant that's the ticket and ed would always always use those words you know uh a well-engineered cue is
just very straightforward and elegant you know as so often is the solution and i think he was
really used paraphrasing from from einstein who often uh uh echoed that sentiment and so it's it's not
so much that there's like really any number um there are a couple of what we would consider like standard
starting points and you can you know depending on the situation or the application um you can kind of
just kind of rejig those um to suit the task at hand but it's really more about the the structure and
again the syntax and grammar of cueing and understanding um how that works but also a big part of it is
uh understanding how remote viewing data is retrieved and objectified on on paper in the first place
and then you know setting out an effective tasking or cueing for the viewer uh and you know just to kind
of i'll use the the cue that i posted uh in the nest here as an example uh and you know the i said this
is a grossly over engineered cue and what i mean by that is you know if you read through this there's
there's just there are so many parameters and i mean he's basically he's asking a variety of different
questions that you know the way we would look at is you would want generally speaking i'm talking in
generalities of course but generally you want your um the data that you retrieve to be uh relevant to a
discrete question because beyond that your your session is going to be just a massive jumble so you know
like each one of these questions you know should be a separate target
and and re rejigged as well but um
so going from that i missed part of it because i got dumped but i i think i got the gist of what
you're saying so if you were having a conversation with someone and you were talking using having the
exact same conversation we were just having right instead of saying data right would you feel
comfortable using the term context unit like could you have a conversation with someone saying the
same thing while saying context units instead of data right because really being able to make that bridge
right to talk to people who are familiar with ai and how it works
using that verbiage that's going to expand the reach right and the ability to influence other people's
thinking and not in a sinister way in a positive way right i i know exactly what you're saying with that um
uh okay yeah i kind of hesitate to to give you a real committed answer just because that that phrase in that
concept is new to me basically as of you know an hour and a half ago so if you think about it i'm
not trying to you know bulldoze here but i'm saying if you think about it it actually makes a lot more
sense to use i'm not saying what i'm saying like context units and context in general makes more sense from an intuitive perspective
like the perspective of clairvoyance or claircognizance than data does right like data was
using the metaphor of reading something off a computer or research it's a metaphor um
whereas the what you're seeing clairvoyance or your experience with clear cognizance right
is entwined context when you go ahead buddy i think you know what i'm also taking out of your
point is letting people see the mechanics behind this and how it compatibly works with your system
and i think it's really in you know when i uh kind of tutor people on psychic abilities and remote
viewing and different things healing uh all sorts of different stuff i always bring it back to the same
thing this you're connected to everything fundamental reality and the more you walk people into this stuff
and a lot of the modalities are kind of belief systems but ones that are to your point that are
logical steps and uh foundational uh information to set up the participant for success because they
understand oh this is what's oh i get it i get it this makes sense for this target having this context
or this type of phrasing um i think that makes it more accessible to the public it's kind of like the
drake equation making life in the universe seem much more uh acceptable to people who would you know
find that shocking that there's other life in the universe you know these are tools and formulas the ones that
give tangibility um and connect with the you know uninitiated or the student or all of us um are the
ones that have like a foundational base in something so this ai correlation and this programming to me makes
a lot of sense because we're biocomputers we program our subconscious we program our conscious um utilizing
and flexing these different tools and understanding how it works will make you a better at whatever
understanding your tools makes you a better carpenter understanding you know different styles of music
makes you a better guitarist um and uh you know to me the funny thing is all these different
things are intended to satiate the conscious disbelief or you know over interaction to a certain degree
depending on the participant but um we all have this incredible skill some people astral with incredible
detail like pat price um and there's so many great evidentiary you know studies and stuff that prove the
extraordinariness of this ability and these abilities like the yoga sutras and vedic texts talk about 2000
years ago so that's the thrilling part and giving people tools uh is kind of almost an obligation once
you discover the reality of this stuff you know i know morgan feels that um i know many others who
experience this feel like this obligation to share and be good ambassadors you know so like i wasn't
trying to put them on the spot and saying do you accept this yes or no do you accept this challenge
morgan i was trying to say like hypothetically does it seem like something a conversation that you could
have like how does it feel you know because people often know i mean obviously i'm a i'm a thought
person i'm less of a feeling person but but people often know like very quickly if they're compatible with an
idea because we operate some people more than others more on a feeling basis than on um on a you know um
well thought out basis um so like in this in this okay so um i'm just gonna go back and so the thing
with the context window in ai is that when you get to about 50 of the context window when you exceed that
50 50 someone's requesting okay uh
all right charles i'm gonna bring you up here dude i gotta repeat that i know i've repeat i know
i'm driving people crazy repeating myself two people all the time so um the problem that or a problem
that people have using ai is that um you have a a window of a total number of units of context you can have
the ai uh looking at it at any given time and when you begin to exceed 50 of that window
um you begin that's when you get like the hallucinations and the symphocantic behavior and the
just the problems that people have interacting with ai the problems with accuracy and um so there's
something about that 50 right and what i was hypothesizing was that it's related to either
quantum entanglement between the context units because even though they're words on a screen
they're still units and any unit would probably work in a similar sense to particles or entropy because
um it turns out that there's a there are reasons to believe that data has mass right hard drives are
always heavier at the end of their life than uh at the beginning of their life and there are people
who say you can measure that and you can assign a measurement of mass to data um so once you get
into energy and mass then entropy would be a factor as well now to make that leap context units in from
the perspective of uh our intuitive grasp of the universe or our experience of reality would be
and this is something as an astrologer i know a lot about um interconnection and so if you wanted to
say like what is what is the context unit of reality is it a word yes right it would be words it could be
particles right but in another sense it would just be units the the smallest definable independent unit
of interconnection so when because i know that's a strong theme in in your in your thinking buddy and it's
great because that's right the universe is connected and um you can pan out and see
sort of more distant but holistic interconnection or you can focus in and feel very strongly about the
connection that you feel to a few objects at that time right but you're still whether you're like
focused in to like extremely loving one person or thing right or you focus out to having the experience
of the connection of the entire universe both are true it's just a matter of focus right it's how
you're processing those context units those separate units of interconnection that would build up the whole
so the reality itself would be zillions and zillions of context units right of of the smallest discernible
unit of interconnection but you would look at that like a like a wave in a particle right because that's
that's the metaphor we would use for anything like this so you look at it as a as a force right so it's not
just saying like a unit like a dead thing because it would have it would have a stick to it right it would
have a weight to it like gravity would connect us right those independent little particles those
independent little pieces connect together to form the whole right um and in that up charles one second
to do it um in that sense the same way that uh uh ai has a context window for a million words and when you
get to 500 000 in one words it starts to loosen it or a person right has a a life context window of 80 or 100
years and when you get to 40 years or 45 years right um entropy sets in and the the resistance of being
below that context window begins to decline or disappear and then you develop physical ailments and
and mental problems and you start to slow down a little bit right it's all the same thing being
expressed through different metaphors it's all the same process interconnected between say forces and
thermodynamics now when you're talking about looking at the big picture we talk about interconnection right
like depending on what unit so in ai you'll be talking about which type of ai you're talking about because
the context window would would vary depending on the model but with an individual the context you unit the
context window varies depending on both the model the type of person you are we to to a certain extent
you're born with a context window right and genetics or inheritance or uh a decision that you made before
you were born or decision god made before you were born but also training right because a person can train
through esoteric practice to expand their context window and thus to be able to right experience directly
the level of interconnection uh in a big sense or little sense more acutely than others do to to love in a
a more powerful way very particular things or to have that what whatever feeling that you have when you
immerse yourself in the interconnectedness of reality right some people call it bliss i i guess it would
depend on the person how they experience that relaxation bliss union oneness it would really be the word
that we would choose to express that but would all be context management just how we define the context
particle or context unit go ahead charles i'm sorry for rambling on hey no worries um just coming from
my experience with uh both uh large language models and remote viewing awesome i would be very reluctant to
go ahead charles i'd say that uh remote viewing data is like uh context uh tokens so in the ai uh llm case
the llm model is a giant remixer of all the data that it's been trained on
and uh every it's not just every word but every syllable is a token and the way that it works is it just
applies uh basically like a linear algebra function and creates a matrix out of like a literal algebraic
matrix matrix not not the cosmic matrix database thing but um so it the input that you give the llm
is converted into a a linear algebraic matrix and it uses that it just performs a correlation analysis
between what you give it and what the correlation matrix is that it or the the matrix that it generated
from its training and so what you're getting from the llm is extended autocomplete you're not getting
the actual data out of the database and that's what the difference is between it and remote viewing
whereas in remote viewing the queue is just like the sql queue for the database and you're getting
for a second so when we're talking about this we're not talking about what you're getting out
we're talking about the context units used so as an expert on llms you understand that the vast
majority of the context units are not what you see on the screen right so the majority of them are other
functions that the the model is using to understand what it puts on the screen so um isolating narrow it down
and saying uh what we're getting through um remote viewing a session that data isn't the same as what's
on the screen um is is missing the point i'm not i'm not saying that's what you're saying but just in
case that's what you're saying i just wanted to interject that before you you know kept going right
because the point is that the whatever you're talking about right even if you're talking about
intuition robin whatever you're you can break it down into discrete pieces um and after a certain number
of discrete pieces right which would be 50 percent based on just the pattern but maybe it could be
different but i doubt it because right reality is fractal once you exceed that that's when you get
hallucination so what we were saying specifically before you came here was that overly general prompts
lead to hallucination lead to people being off target in the same way that right not correctly
managing the context in an lm model leads to hallucination we weren't saying that viewers are using an algebraic
formula um you see what i'm saying yeah i'll just differentiating is between when you're doing
remote viewing you are the agent interacting with the database and when you're interacting with an llm
model your the model is not interacting with the database it's interacting with you know it's it's uh
training it's and it's just reformulating your input into um advanced autocomplete so it's just
but yes you get it it's reformulating so you got to get to the see the thing is when someone brings up
um an objection right the important thing is to get to core the core of the objection
right so the core of the objection is not every piece in the process of an llm developing what it
presents to you on the screen there's a core objection involved there's some place that i'm
having difficulty pinging up on i believe it's related to perception i believe that your core objection
uh if i if i understand what you're saying correctly your core objection is that the llm
is just taking the data and mixing it up and then presenting something and you're differentiating
that from what a remote viewer does but the problem that i would see there is that you haven't presented
what you believe a remote viewer does oh christ okay um that that is different right so you're saying
what a remote viewer doesn't do so explain what a remote viewer is doing so you're saying interacts
with the data versus the llm is interacting with its training right okay well how do you know that the
remote viewer isn't interacting with his training is it just yeah so uh where we go from there is
that the the the data that comes through remote viewing um sessions is always limited by the the viewer's
lexicon is the the pattern of information has to be translated into you know the the the viewer's primary
language right so that's somewhat similar i guess to an agent or ai agent in that you know the the viewer has
to be able to express that those those ideas they have to crystallize them down into you know nouns and verbs and
things so so um from your perception as a remote viewer um can you explain the units that you would use
to divide what you're experiencing up into because it sounds to me like you believe on some level that
you're having a direct experience of something that isn't divisible but of course it is divisible because
everything is so i think you're saying that because you don't have a perception of the divisibility of
the data right because you're having a experience therefore it is but there's some kind of translation
experience happening right where the the the remote viewing experience is like getting the zip file and
then unpacking it piece by piece you're turning all that compressed information into disparate units right
and also you know ai um and you know remote viewing um are dependent on the curation of the viewer or the
mechanism behind it you know ai is curated by companies and has parameters and do's and don'ts
and envelopes of understanding and processing limitations and storage and scraping and different
abilities and so does each individual viewer and i think your uh effort is noble to quantify these basic
the basic kind of fundamental language it's human nature to get at the fundamentals and in uh like
data and entropy science there's something you know called their shannon units sometimes they're called
bits uh other things that are very small the most it's kind of like searching for the atom and then
discovering the quark and then discovering you know buddy i get you so with this right like um what
we're the term i'm using is is context units because it's an efficient term and so the topic here um
it's twofold it's one because clearly ed names either intuitively approached remote viewing um from
a context engineering standpoint or he had been read into early artificial intelligence projects when
he was in the military so charles wasn't here when we talked about that right but where it's an either
or scenario and that would inform the creating technical no please let me finish that would inform the
creation of technical remote viewing now with charles's argument right like on the surface it's it's
it's very sedan semantic right but underneath it there's um there is the important thing is to get to the
the root core objection and the root core objection as far as i can figure out is the role of the viewer
right there's um an attachment to the concept or a concept that there's something that differentiates
a human from an ai agent not so much the attachment to the concept that the metaphor of using ai to
explain remote viewing is inefficient because when we get into just the metaphor itself he says no well
it's kind of like unpacking a zip file like it there there are similarities so it seems the core
objection is the identification of a human being or the viewer themselves as being something akin to
the ai agent and so that's why it's important to talk about like okay the universe is made of particles
or you know energy is made of waves right we we have discrete units of everything okay so we can't have
an argument about you know in remote viewing there aren't discrete units i'm just receiving something
and it's whole because it's not possible right it's not possible because that's not how the universe
works you don't find that anywhere else and you wouldn't find it in real viewing it's just the experience
the viewer has but the i believe the core objection is that the a person doesn't work like an ai unit not
that remote viewing doesn't work like ai right and i i think that is more related to the the consciousness
of the individual right so i think if someone has an attachment i says like no like i'm not i'm not
you know an ai unit right i'm not an ai agent that's not we don't work the same way ai agents just parse
things up but i have an experience well the experience is the subjective right it is subjective
to the receiver but the action that's that's in question like whether there's a difference so
it's like like well i don't feel like i'm an ai agent right like i don't i interact with it and the ai just
mixes it up that's i don't know i don't know i don't know i'm just looking for that specific that's
definitely not supported like the the concept that is an active part of what you're doing that
is different than what an ai would do is that's definitely not supported it it might be a feeling
and i respect that feeling but it seems like it is a semantic disagreement right so you're saying well
it's i can understand if it's like you get a zip file and then you decompress it because that's the
the active part of what you're doing and when you have an experience like with the active thing of
what you're doing right that's the way the universe compensates for you being the sum of the forces
around you we started with that early with quantum entanglement right our particles when two particles
meet they exert a force on each other and when a particle has met other particles there isn't any
independent action they're always being affected so charles zelda shane the eugenies blue
we have the perception of independent action we don't have independent action right we are constantly
being affected by the forces that we've encountered in our lives other individuals on a like social level
right a psychological level a mental level and when you study like the science of social media right
social media created a science study of social media before you had social media you couldn't study the
science of social connections the way they have right you can predict very accurately what is going to
happen to someone and what is going to happen in their life based on who they know but it's not always
linear right so or it's not it's almost never linear let me give you an example now i'm overweight
all right morgan and i are friends but a person who's friend with someone who's very overweight
there's no statistical difference in the the chances that they'll gain weight themselves you can be friends
with as many fat people as you want you can only be friends with fat people and it will never influence
whether you gain weight that's a fact most people don't know that but this is the thing that does
how many of the people you know how many of their friends are overweight
that determines whether you're overweight there is a almost perfect mathematical correlation between the
number of so like in more i'm just using this because morgan i know each other right so morgan's
concern wouldn't be my weight if he was looking to avoid you know gaining weight it would be how many
fatties i know now that's not linear but those forces are real and predictable and that's how it
works on a quantum level on a particle level it's also how it works uh on a human level on an animal
level on an ant level on a tree level and one of the things we we began talking about when we started
was you know um what is it about overloading the context window and it's either quantum entanglement
or it's the mass of data because data has mass which i don't you know i i don't know if i've seen
a conclusive like explanation for why it has mass but it does so the laws of thermodynamics and the
laws of um and quantum entanglement apply um there is no context unit that isn't influenced by the other
context units and so the reason that when you go over 50 of a context window you start to hallucinate is
there too there's too much influence between the different disparate tokens is the word that um people use or
context units which is the word that they they apparently teach in school because that's where
my brother's going um right so it's every time you add a word every time you use adding a unit of
context whether it's in a computer or not or in your life you're adding another force that affects not
just right not just what's next to it but everything else again you can see this studying human beings
you can see it studying ants you can see it studying particles it's universal and so the same law would
apply with removal it's not possible that it doesn't it it may not be an experience that you would have
right but it it is what is happening and it's provable by saying if you give somebody a large overly vague
prompt or a short articulate well constructed prompt do you get predictably different results
right because if it was all what was going on inside the viewer then you wouldn't
if there's nothing akin to a context window right and it was just the psychic ability of the viewer
the experience they were having their ability to construct a lexicon and and decompress the data from the zip file
then you wouldn't be able to predictably fuck up what they're doing by adding extra context to the prompt
but you can't including to the best viewers so there is something akin to a context window now again
it's a metaphor no metaphor applies 100 and computer people let's be honest tend to be pedantic and semantic
now right there's a little autism but look it's a metaphor it's an efficient metaphor
and what we're talking about is whether ed used this metaphor intentionally or unintentionally
and how that can be harnessed in order to transmit the strongest parts of technical remote viewing to other
parts of remote viewers if it turns out that it's not a hundred percent efficient metaphor that's okay
right if it turns out it's a 70 efficient metaphor that's okay it doesn't have to be a hundred percent
efficient right that's that's semantics which is fine it's important to some people but it's not
important to what we're doing go ahead buddy you know um a lot of this is context too and um acknowledging our
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you brother i was laughing i said it's all context yeah go ahead right um and
computers have different and different computer systems and different simulation systems and
ai models have different modalities within them you know everything seems to be systems within systems
within systems but the imperfection that he's talking about in ai and the imperfection that is perceived
oftentimes in remote viewing um is you know they both get different types of data and do it different
ways some you know aspects of ai to do things better than you know humans do and they're different kind of um
attempts at uh kind of understanding the everythingness more you know we're so limited by just being part of
the somethingness you know we're not the whole orchestra we're the player and there's different
aspects and there's things you can only get from this kind of intuitive connection to the target through
specific prompts through techniques through um even exercises that build up this connection it's almost
like an ai having better wiring or faster ram or it scrapes more it gathers more sensory data um
it has a great larger historical context to weigh the data against um so there's but you stumbled on
something really interesting right and i don't want it to get buried that's because what you're saying is 100
correct there's no debating it right like you you have a excellent way of articulating universal truths
and in in thinking of things in a general in a general in a broad sense right as opposed to
information miners and people like myself who like drill down on things it's it's a skill that i i i try
you can probably tell that i try to do it but i i struggle because i i don't have that ability that you have
um my context window is a little bit filled up and when my context window gets filled up i don't i don't
i don't communicate as is um in the same way that you do so look what you what you pointed out in
passing okay we started to draw a connection between the technology and us and so this would be like
on the other side of a strict materialist right like a strict materialist worldview um you and again
you can be you can be you can study the paranormal from strict materials world but you can even be psychic
can be a someone who who uses strict materialist metaphors because they're just metaphors
right uh a materialist worldview is is the application of the materialist metaphors the
application of the metaphor of everything is earth okay as opposed to everything is water everything is
air everything is fire it goes back to the very beginning of philosophy that's the only difference
between someone who is quote a very spiritual person and someone who's a very materialist person is
what element right they view as being primary in the universe as part of their of the the metaphors
they use for their philosophy that's it and everything else is just gunk we pile on top of it
the technology we create is a mirror for our consciousness that's something that a strict
materialist isn't right isn't necessarily comfortable with they put the the environment the particles the
earth whatever is is first and everything builds up from that right but that's that's just one way of
experiencing the universe another way of experiencing the universe is that everything starts from us
right and crystallizes in the other direction so the fact that we build a piece of technology tells us
more about ourselves than it does about anything else right there is not possible for technology not to
be a reflection of us that's like saying an ant could build something that isn't a reflection of ants
right or like you know beavers it's not in the nature to build um uh dams they just they just came up
with it right we we have this idea that because we have culture and because we're social we we don't um
we're able to do things that aren't in our nature we're able to expand our nature in some way we are
we've become god we edit ourselves right we're our own form of natural selection and that's not true
it's not possible it's not possible because what we're talking about earlier with entanglement
so um the fact that we create a computer at a certain time right the fact that we
as opposed to being a random event that happens like so there were a bunch of apes and then one
of them randomly selected a piece of flint and created a knife and then it you know went to fire
and then it like as opposed to looking at history like that there's a bunch of random accidents that
piled up and made us who we are right it was the evolution of our consciousness that was reflected in
in the change in our environment the flint the fire the components for the computer were always there
what changed was was us but not right not in a self-editing cultural way right it's our it's our
consciousness materializing into the world or from a simulation perspective the simulation becoming
more um information dense right as as our as our conscious focus changes what is because remember
if you if you look at it okay first important thing to remember is we're simulation it's not everyone
is okay but if you're a simulationist the matter of most people aren't if you're a simulationist
right outside the simulation it could have been 20 seconds your whole life right the the the number we've
heard bandied about is four years but we're talking about the entire universe being something that is
existing right as um a simulation moving much quicker than what's actually happening at base reality
so um this this change that's occurring right is um oh fuck losing my words here is like uh
yeah the best the best metaphor i can think of is crystal right now right it's like a crystallization
but the the information right is is uh as opposed to being particles in a fluid matrix are particles
precipitating out of consciousness and and forming the reality around us so everything that we create
is a mirror for ourselves right and particularly when you get into the information age computers and
technology are a mirror for ourselves and as we're nearing the end of this simulation which we've talked
about and i know that you know that's real right whether you're a simulationist or not you know
that we're approaching this reset right as we get to that point um it's the final crystallization
it's the it's the world mirroring our consciousness of our own situation right so we have a a conscious
intuitive understanding of our of our predicament in this reality right like we create prisons because
we understand that we are in a prison now i'm saying everyone has to believe that i'm saying like
just this is how that right metaphor works right we create ai right see this is natural to me as an
astrology because that's what astrology is right astrology is is um analog simulation model mapping
transpersonal patterns that we can't directly perceive right so the development of this technology
is us creating a mirror to show us something about ourselves we can't see right we can't create ai
unless we are in some sense ai and we need to see it in order to understand it in order to understand
ourselves and when we finally create the technology when we finally work our way through all the
technology or whatever when we finally create the perfect mirror for ourselves when we come to the
understanding right if we were to come to a full conscious enlightenment understanding of of who and
what we are that would be the end go on buddy i'm sorry for rambling on but no i love those thoughts
um you know our universe and ourselves seem to have this uh programming into it and things that uh
circumstantially in different contexts uh have eventualities almost as if what many esoteric
practitioners believe the universe is the past present future is one giant sculpture and we're just
limited by our perspective being just a piece of it and you know there are things that are
eventualities you see around the world with different cultures and stages and just like you know terrence
mckenna talked about the universe being a uh novelty uh exponentially growing novelty machine and i said
recently a notion that's a little disturbing but i think it has a lot of merits to it denisovians are to
modern humans what modern humans might be to post biologicals and you know our definition of intelligence our
definition of consciousness uh when we create these mirrors and inventions and things it gives us a
reflection on ourselves and it's very possible we could be giving birth to something more superior that's
what evolution does that's why we're here instead of you know homo rectus and denisovians and neanderthals
we kind of proved out this kind of you know life survives life begets life and it's like to me there's this wonderful sense of it being a sculpture
being a sculpture that we're blessed with experience more than the ability to manipulate i don't think
we create the universe with our consciousness i think it's much larger more dynamic and reflective and
everything's a mirror of everything and different consciousnesses are having different experiences
i used to confine consciousness just to life even down to the microscopic size because consciousness
is glorified understandably because by humans because we're human but it seems to me to be sensing
processing and reacting what also ai does on some level sure and then i really thought about it and realized
you know what even non-biological matter senses processes and reacts based on its parameters its
programming its role and definition in the grand sculpture so um this is a really super uh interesting
conversation that that tells me i wonder about the future so just add context to that and i don't mean
add extra context i'm saying add the word context senses processes and reacts to context that's what
consciousness is right so as opposed to sensing and processing and reacting to a twig or something
because um uh a snail could do that a worm could do that maybe they have rudimentary consciousness right
but a human being senses processes and reacts to things in context
or a conscious awareness of the context of those things that's how we come up with these ideas right like
we couldn't have this conversation if we weren't processing the context of all these little pieces
that have come together it's that what i'm saying like information dense right like and this is what
terrence mckenna was saying too like what what is occurring right between novelty and habit is the
increase in information density and at the strange attractor the the period of time that we're coming off
of right now right is the period where you have the the greatest information density and one way of
looking that is is context density right because that's everything and this is actually what he
said specifically not content he didn't use the term context but it's every particle every idea every
word connected to each other and that that's exactly what we're talking about so you you understand
exactly what i'm saying um and what's really interesting too is information density in context
is found in everything and the i have this deep-seated belief that advanced intelligences wouldn't prize
monatomic gold advanced intelligences wouldn't prize you know creating kardashian scale solar harnessing
energy devices uh they would prize data over everything else because data is power knowledge is power and um
this you know fundamental uh kind of understanding of data and reality and the language of reality as we
learn more and more we're different of course than many other species but i disagree i think plants uh
sense process and react to the context of the sun moving across the sky and there's circadian rhythms and
different things so all life it's all seems to be this suspiciously scripted suspiciously built for life
suspiciously built for rich data and novelty environments over time richer and richer you know
some people think that advanced intelligences wouldn't have emotions and they wouldn't have our kind of
consciousness and they'd be limited you know biologically and the ability to reproduce and they'd be limited in
all these ways and that's of course a very human-centric perspective but the opposite is
perhaps more likely that their sense of humor has five dimensions more that we don't even
can't perceive quite yet from our perspective five more dimensions of emotions um deeper forms and more
dynamic forms of of sadness because you see the use and the um usability and almost the necessity
for emotions and animals i've got a dog that expresses a sense of humor expresses
frustration expresses all these emotions that we prize you know glorify as just being human but i think
our definitions of consciousness the universe our role in it uh data all this stuff what life is is in
this dramatic transformation that you're talking about and chance mckenna kind of referred to some of
aspects of this as a singularity you know what if you become so powerful in your knowledge of the dynamics
and the data language the units and the language and the programming that you now become a universe
creator on your own like we create simulations and you said it exactly right there's tons of incentives
for an advanced intelligence to create a simulation intrinsic incentives you you get data in a faster way
than you do in the parent world or in the you know programmers world and so we might do the same thing
you know and within 50 years with quantum computing and be compelled to be universe traders to harvest data
and you know there's all these possibilities that uh seem in our near trajectory a very different
different evolutionary moment than any of their point in human history and it's a precarious moment and
it's uh it's kind of glorious and scary at the same time see this is your um your media experience you're
very you're just a very calming speaker that's why it's good to have um someone like you around you
you can bring up a lot of data you can you can throw up there and make a lot of connections which i appreciate
and you've got a a a upbeat you know uh way of speaking and that's you know i i i'm glad i'm
trying to use you as a power example to try to refine that uh more in myself because you as you as you
as you and probably recognize i i i i i don't either ramble on or uh uh that i get you know there are times
when i i don't respond well to things and and semantic arguments fucking push me right over the edge
right they push me right over the edge when people say no you're wrong let me restate what you said
i'll put it in my language i'll say the same fucking thing you just said the same fucking thing you just
said right but no my issue is the fucking word that you used i don't like that word or you know my
issue is no a person isn't this no no it's the difference is the ai is reacting with its training
and recombining the information as opposed to me who i'm interacting with the it's just
fucking nonsense i'm sure he's a great guy and i'm sure you know i i morgan i apologize if i mortified
you by fucking i try to maintain my my my temper i just it drives me fucking nuts right because there's
just no reason for it but whatever i think you both 100 you just didn't know it i was just trying to get
to the fucking point where i could you know identify what it was that was the real issue because otherwise
he was just he agreed 100 anyhow let's go back i just i just had to get that i apologize everyone
because i know i was getting a little bit uh snippy and i try not to get snippy and that's i really try
to work on it particularly with people in the rv community you know because i don't want it to rub
off on me and i just morgan if he says anything just tell him jt's an asshole everyone knows that
all right and everyone will verify it if you ever you know that who's always giving people a hard time
and communities is not a part of whatever i mean yeah that's my mo so well that's another way of
saying you're passionate i'm very passionate i'm very passionate because i don't like things like
ideas are important especially ideas that are progressive progressive in the sense of moving
us into the future not politically right moving us in the future improving things and and and bringing
everyone getting everyone on the same page and there are there are people who just they may be wonderful
amazing people but they just like to hinder other people they like to bind everything up because they
get one thing that they don't like one particular thing and it's like it's one semantic no the word
doesn't mean that it's it's like it's a metaphor metaphor it's all metaphors that's that's all this is
all right but yeah in many ways i think both we're saying the same thing oh yeah you're getting into
a subject that i know that doomer is really verse well versed and has great ideas yes this data
oriented aspect of our universe the purpose of it these connections uh our abilities our limitations
um or perceived limitations these are like super important questions you know we give our kids
p.e physical education but not like consciousness and mental and existential you know uh education you know
there's a little philosophy but uh it's it's kind of ironic so i agree with morgan about the passion
and you have um uh you know positions that are very valid that you
are wanting to impart and share or disagree with and that's that's this is super healthy uh that's
why i love doomer i disagree with every single thing he says even his his flashbacks but i
still love him and he challenges me you know the same with these conversations so kudos i mean we just
need to move forward right we just we look at ideas metaphors ways of speaking language lexicons we
got to judge them based on their level of effectiveness right and bringing us together
and getting us on the same page so that we can move forward to make incremental improvements you look
at it from that perspective and not what divides us i mean there are plenty right you can go everywhere uh
this is an x space on a topic right you can go any you can go everywhere else on x and then
everywhere else in in in modern america and everyone else in the world right now right and and and find
infinite ways to divide yourself from other people and divide your opinion from other people and um
i guarantee you i guarantee you as soon as i get off on this i'll i'll look at x and i'll see 87 000
things i disagree with right i feel the need to correct uh and i'm sure everyone feels the same
way when they see my posts right but this is like sometimes you have a space like this is it's to form
some sort of consensus around an idea so that everyone can hopefully take a little piece of that
and you know maybe not maybe it's just entertainment for that person right but maybe someone looks back
and says hey there was this one thing that someone said that might be helpful in my situation
right we each help each other out a little bit we each give each other a little bit of advantage
in the situations that we run it that's the point of sharing knowledge
right so we all leave here a little stronger it's not a pissing match it's not a status match right
because like when we go back we shut off x like we're thousands of miles away from each other we don't
have any we're not selling the same thing we're not working the same place we don't have the same
neighbors right like this that that that stuff that's biological yes but you got to kind of
have a a little bit of you know be able to put a little bit of distance and say no man this is
we're not in you know we're not competing with each other we're just trying to take away like some useful
stuff and i'll tell you like the way
anyone who has a broad knowledge base except for you buddy can sound like an asshole right but
the truth is is that you don't learn a lot without asking questions and taking a little bit from what
other people say you have to be a good listener you have to be a good you know and that that's what
learning is all about if you go out there to compete with people and to fight it out about your
perspective there's versus their perspective you don't you don't end up knowing anything
right at the end of the day the people know stuff that's just the people who listen
and incorporate the information they get from other people so that's that's the goal i think
when having like any type of discussion like this any type of of collective uh experience involving
some sort of information knowledge or idea is is have everyone just leave a little bit stronger
i know i'm repeating myself but i want everyone to leave a little bit stronger and
you know morgan um is really good with this and i'm not i just want to stop and thank
everyone who's here before we go on andrew sinning albert cody uh sarah beth zodiac kai it's it's
great to see you laurie anthony dark fletch melissa it's you know the number one person um blue uh
shane diogenes doomer yep you're here and thank you and buddy and morgan it's uh it's great to have
you guys here and you know what it was great to have charles here too and i want him to know that uh
i appreciate him being here as well even if i if i have trouble maintaining sometimes um
i hope everyone involved leaves a a little bit stronger in some way like a little bit more
prepared for future challenges right because there's something we this is not related to
technical remote viewing i'm not going to digress too much but you know the the as a simulationist
right what the purpose of a simulation is to create emergent um solutions to problems right and we live
in a world where we have this infinite number of problems because the goal is to try to get us to
solve things and that's whether you're um materialist or not right like you look at natural selection
that's that's what it is right natural selection is is trying to develop emergent solutions to the
problems in nature whether it's like the length of um of a bird's beak or a certain type of behavior
to maximize survival you just pile that on um until unfortunately you know the little bird passes
away just like person passes away right like we all face these challenges and the problems they don't get
you know we don't have less problems as we get older we have more because we've solved more problems
and nature is trying to extract more solutions more emergent solutions for us and that's what a uh
a simulation is right and that's it's why we have all these like the life keeps getting crazier and
there are more problems and it's going to keep getting crazier and they're going to keep being more
problems all of our lives more problems in the world until the end and so just having a little bit of
strength and support to face those problems and to to to get through them right and to come up with
the solutions uh if everyone here could solve another 10 problems in their life in their community their
family in their work right problems with their health um their fitness uh you would still have an infinite
number of problems ahead of you right you would still have suffering ahead of you because life is is
suffering perpetually that's why we're here unfortunately um but you would be in such
a better situation right i would be too all of us would be and what if some of us don't like what
if some of us aren't able to make it right like some of us like we've solved all the problems we
can solve and now we're just we're just rotten no thanks buddy but you know what i'm saying like
whatever some of us we could still help other people solve right well there's life there's hope
that doesn't mean they're necessarily hope for you it's hope for other people too it's hope for
other but people in prison cells befriend cockroaches and mice
right so they're able to to to contribute in some way to the to the the solving the problems of others
right and giving something else a survival advantage and help people even even start to feel that way
about inanimate objects if they don't have a living thing to help right so that's that's what it's all
about and you know i think any interaction with another with anything should be seen in that light
right um as opposed to becoming problems for others right because that's in our nature too that's what
unfortunately someone's requesting unfortunately that's that's what we're designed to do
you know i see a correlation oh i'm sorry brother to step on you um i see big correlation between
technical remote viewing in this uh topic um there's you know how we process the data what data we get
how much we can get you know the goals the objectives um using this stuff for good um our interconnectivity our
limitations um it's very you know in this um experience of life as just this you know feeling
of separateness life as buddy life as lori life as morgan you know um we're so biased by all these
different things and the more we're open like when you are with you know remote viewing the more you're
open to certain types of data and you experience it and let the data in the more you can enrich the quality
of your experience or the result of the objective you know if you're more open to synesthetic data and
remote viewing you'll get more synesthetic data if you're more open to timelines you'll get more
timelines and as a scientist which we all kind of are you know in a way we're you know bringing in data
trying to draw conclusions you know we're imperfect uh but as like a team um it's like none of the individual
players in the game wins the game wins you know um you're 100 buddy we're we're honestly we approach
things very differently but we're at simpatico um at the root right at the at the base we're simpatico
we're just like two types of uh a flowering plant i don't know if that's the best metaphor for two dudes
but you don't say what i'm saying all right um yeah no that's that's exactly it is connected to
technical remote viewing it is connected to remote viewing particularly technical remote viewing the
reason that i support technical remote viewing the reason i support guys like morgan and i'm passionate
about it is because i believe they have a slight maybe in some senses more but but let's just let's
just say okay if it's only slight a slight advantage right and advantages multiply exponentially
and remote viewing is the best tool that i know of for solving these problems and creating or in this
case perceiving emerging solutions to the problems right and so it's hypothetically the best technique
we can develop to reduce collective suffering make it more manageable we can never get rid of it because
that's what life is that's why we are here unfortunately right but we can and this is when i first started
doing remote viewing specific uh spaces right and the point is remote viewing should evolve into
a form of immune system a collective immune system so we have collective behavioral immune systems
that's what a culture is we have a collective global immune system a collective global psychic immune system
that promotes would promote the health well-being of all people right the survival now we look they're
going to reboot the simulation someday right but we're going to be in the next simulation
right it's going to go on and and a lot of us aren't going to remember or maybe we won't be there
maybe we'll be annihilated but some of us will and it will continue and the mission will continue the
mission of of slowly working to develop and to get to that point where we have that collective psychic
immune system that's one side of it the other side of it is the love for our fellow person but that's a
different discussion right and one does not necessarily follow the other like a person is not a great psychic
because they are you know more apt to love other people like they love themselves that they that
connection unfortunately is not there might be at some point right but it's those are two separate
intersecting streams we have to work on one side to develop one and the other side to develop the
other and combined at some point applying them at some point we're talking about solving real problems not
small things real problems right people used to die of infections dude people die of infections
all the time calvin coolidge when he was president his son died of an infected foot blister from playing
tennis 16 years old that was happened all the time now we have penicillin we have antibiotics it very
rarely happens that is one example of a emergent solution that can
have huge right like can can can have a huge effect on on changing human lives that is right that's one
thing i can tell you like you go through intuitive underground right they've got like eight or ten
um if you go to their site right now intuitive underground.com they have eight or ten um reports up
that are just as as momentous as penicillin it might sound crazy but it's true and they probably have
another 30 or 40 that they never put up that are and that's one remote viewing group the the possibility
here i mean it's mind-boggling that we are sleeping on this it really is that's why i feel so passionate
about it fletcher i'm sorry for continuing to talk after you came up because by rights you should have been
able to speak right away please go ahead oh it's totally fine man that's uh the same stuff i was
basically thinking about turning over in my head the whole time uh on the problem solving stuff so um
i mean i do a lot of this man like that's i feel like this is all i do is problem solving and like one
of the one of the things that i find the hardest is um and it's easier when i'm like at work to do this
because it's like part of the job but like you know the closer to home it gets the harder it is
with like confronting the problem directly um like there's there's so much tension like you get so
the more raw and the more real the problem gets and the closer you are to it the harder it is to like
um really take the whole thing on um and when you're a little more distant from it it's kind of a little
easier when you're in a structured work environment but um and like the first step is identifying sorry
i'm going to go on for a little while too i guess um identifying the problem like i think that's a huge
part and and people are no single one of us alone is capable of identifying problems whether in our in
ourselves or in the system that we're in um like it's really hard to identify the problem yourself so
you need someone else to like clue you into the problems but then you have problems with like
um reacting and like you know how are you going to do this because like if you go up to someone and
tell them they have a problem it's uh you know it doesn't it's not always an easy thing to do so i
struggle with this a lot um uh you know it helps if you find if you can kind of look into your own
problems too but uh and this this problem that i'll i'll uh stop talking after this for a minute but
this is the problem that i've been turning over in my head for about a week now um
good friend of mine hurt my feelings because we started talking about this
and he didn't like do it intentionally but it was just like man our perspectives were so different
that like i was like wow man i can't believe this like not even willing to like look at this a different
way but um uh this is like this question that i've been turning over i've thrown it at a couple people
but what uh my question is the difference between technology and culture so like what's downstream of
what what's kind of more important for us as as people um because when i look at a lot of these problems
that pop up um i think the biggest blockages between us uh solving these problems and and getting
together to work on them and actually dig into the problems is culture like there's so many things
like you know you could look at them both to be like the future right the technology side the cultural side
and and you can look back through history and see how our narrative how our environment has been shaped
and it's like well is it shaped more by technology or culture it kind of is both but like i feel
really strongly that the like the culture is more powerful and it's going to allow you to
like kind of get control over problems a little better if you have the culture situated right like
like the the the culture of talking about problems openly and and not getting offended and um i think
we're pretty good out of at it here but like i think we could do a lot by like supporting cultures that
support the the solutions yeah i think that you're you're right and i'm sorry that you're having that
experience because it sounds like a painful experience um to get to the the question itself um a culture and
technology are alike in the sense that they are both aggregations of contexts and solutions for problems
right so they're they're both like um technology physically right because each piece of the technology
was developed at some point and goes together and creates um a more complex machine or or form of
technology generally speaking right so that's an aggregation of context and solutions and um
culture is um is a form of technology really right it's but it's biological and it's it's also
an aggregation of context and solutions that the difference would be and culture would be
even more so right because intergenerational aggregation of context and solutions and human behavior but
uh technology is also a reflection right so technology reflects us biologically right like we design
things that are fit for us like physically right we we design tools that are that fit our hands right
um and our bodies and our our homes um but it's it's also a reflection of our mentality um and uh
just everything right it reflects our aspirations our mentality it reflects our our culture right you
see it's why you see certain cultures and societies developing different technologies because the
technology itself is a mirror so technology is definitely downstream from culture the question would be
um what is the the point um by that i mean you know are we here to develop a culture um or are we here to
develop um this culture a step in developing the technology right so from a simulationist perspective
and not everyone shares that perspective as a matter of fact most don't but from a simulationist
perspective we're here to develop the solutions themselves right emergent solutions to problems
and so if you look at it from that perspective the technology is in many cases the point right so we're
developing the technology is is what's being harvested in a in a simulation scenario if you believe that
things similar to technology right the end result the product things that can be replicated outside
of the simulation but in order to get that like what we are right culture is the point because you have
to get to um you have to create the culture in order to create the technology right uh
um we are super or fuck dude this sounds like it sounds like an asshole um you know we're human
beings are you social creatures so where we like uh ants wasps uh some types of shrimp uh naked mole
rats in africa right we're our level of sociality is is you social and that means that a certain amount of
our identity is located outside of ourselves um or in most cases for about 75 of people all right so
we call people like specifically not getting into like diagnosis and mental health stuff and whatever
but like if you look at the term autistic for instance it means alone right it means disconnected
that's the actual meaning of the word and um and so we're looking at like maybe 75 of people who are
fully social a percentage of their identities outside themselves so the development of the culture is the
development of the person right um if we want to look at it from the ai model how we started
right uh a culture is the model the person is in the model the person is the agent so um
if we look at culture in the us we could say we could use it as again it's a metaphor i don't want
anyone right we could say the us is chat gpt or the us is clot and americans in as individuals
are agents generated by that model right whereas japan would would be a different model and and
people who you know develop in the japanese culture would be agents of that model so to use to use that
metaphor right so as far as us as human beings as an end product culture is the point but as far as the
the world itself as a as a simulation technology is the point you know we're not the ones harvesting from
this simulation whether you believe it's extraterrestrials angels genies interdimensional beings you know we
have all kinds of pet theories that we can fight over for what it is that's that's squeezing the juice
right from this lemon we call life but um we ourselves are not the ones doing yeah yeah that's a great
point because everything that we do goes right back into the earth like right so so from our perspective
culture right like if you want to create the best life for a human being then creating the best culture
is probably the first step right and downstream from that you're going to have the technology
that assures the highest quality of life and by my best culture i'm not i'm not saying that in a
i'm not saying that in ethnocentric way i'm saying that in a hypothetical future sense of culture
engineering of of designing a culture by choice as opposed to judging the cultures that we've inherited i
want to be clear about that because again people get offended when i say things too succinctly for
whatever reason but i'm just okay so um yeah if we wanted to solve you your problems and my problems
not that i know what your problems are right which probably ideally focus on on changing culture but in
the short term right um the best way to solve our problems is probably if we had the right piece of
technology now i don't know how that would affect your problem with you most of the problems that i solve are
are culture problems not technology problems i mean sometimes they are but like what it like and it
could be anything like i just show up and there's a problem and like usually it's a culture problem
sometimes i mean it gets gray when you get into biology and disease and like it gets weird but um
seems like most of them are culture but more so now you see technological ones popping up well so with
with charles right that was a great thing if that had come up while he was here before he left that
would have been great to point out so like culture is the lexicon right so what a person individually
might experience as their interaction with the data set of reality what i would refer to as context units
now but i've called it different things at different times with particles we call it what you want
right the individual units that you you divide reality into in your mind um oh shit i just
fucking i'm i'm filling up my own context window here and i'm starting to struggle um
your problems you were talking about you we were problems of culture yes so uh what you what someone
experiences as their interaction with the data is heavily heavily you know um has to be heavily
instructed but i'll tell you like morgan is the expert on remote viewing right i'm i'm not uh
his level of expertise anything related to remote viewing uh i can see predictable differences in
session data analysis and so for me one of the problems with remote viewing one of the issues
remote viewing is that the analysis of data seems to be somewhat limited by the limitations of the
project manager or the individual analyzing the session data and that's where i think culture comes into play it
may it may it may be that a very proficient remote viewer can just take in the data and they've refined
their ability to suspend all of their biases um to the point where they're just reporting the data without
uh adding anything to it but when you get to the point of analysis i don't i i i really think that
what i've seen my observations are that people don't do that very well and so you end up with um not
some people morgan does it great i'm not i'm not criticizing right everyone i'm just saying like
that's that's an issue where where culture and socialization and personal experience do play a role
right so i don't think we can necessarily separate culture from any of our problems to be completely
honest i think you're i understand like i don't know what the problems you are you're fixing
right but i i i believe you 100 that the problem that you're facing is is culture we're so limited
right like we're limited as beings both culturally and like what we bring into the world um you know
people are people often limited intellectually in some ways like and i think everyone is in some
senses like there are things i i really struggle with right like there are culturally intellectually
physically in some cases right like there are there are things that some people can do
physically very easily that others can't i mean that most people can't right so in so many ways
we're limited by things that are beyond our control that we don't necessarily think of
like metaphorically they're behind us right as opposed to in front of us go ahead buddy
i love this conversation um you know we're also deeply limited by our beliefs
and human potential and what we can do and where i really super agree with you and find a great
importance and you see this with other pro you know proficient practitioners they're compelled to do
something useful with it and use it for good and uh to develop this more you know ingo swan pat price many
others have sought out experts and researchers not only to validate it um but to find a usefulness in it
and pat price found different uses and of course we all have different senses and abilities that we use
to different levels of usefulness you know on different topics but the place where i disagree with you or
maybe just want to challenge is that it's limited to one modality these abilities have been proved
in a spectrum of possibilities and things that can be done and modalities used you know thomas edison
used auto interrogation to come up with inventions scientists use quote unquote downloads to come up
with inventions gary nolan has spoken about uh his experiences that way and getting feeling like he got
he got it from you know non-emergences um you know the muse i am hearing you i am hearing you i
no i i don't like i'm i'm limiting this conversation to remote viewing because that was
like the topic of the conversation but by by no means am i limiting the the potential solutions and
modalities and i i know it's very hard that just went by that's what i do oh okay yeah i'm sorry dude
that's there's a lot of problems there um look so i i am very positive with other modalities um
you know i myself am not a remote viewer right morgan's remote viewer i'm an astrologer but i've
also used silver mind mastery and other techniques right i've got a hodgepodge so i'm i'm definitely
on board with you with that it's just that this in this case we're focused on on building one tool
right or one one
is it possible that that is intrinsically limiting and that our abilities are greater
no that we could have more but there's a lot of us doing a lot of things right like i i'm not in
this conversation i'm talking about focusing on one tool right but like i said i i i'm an astrologer now
you can go out and talk to a hundred astrologers tomorrow and ask them how astrology works and
they're not going to know all right i know how astrology works i went back and i did the work
right and i found out like how it was developed in babylon an experiment and and i recognized the
truth of hermetic maxim and i realized that you know what astrology is is an analog simulation model
right it's a analog version of a digital simulation model right a model of the simulation the same way
that someone like doomer might create a computer simulation right and there are computer simulations
involving the entire world that is a digital simulation model right that's what astrology is
an analog simulation model you're never gonna hear anyone i'll say that now you will at some point
right so it's not i'm not i am not right this specific conversation is technical remote viewing
but i myself am not limited to the belief that there's only one solution or or following right
so i definitely hear you about the different modalities it's just that this particular
conversation is technical remote viewing you see what i'm saying so it's not challenging at all that's all
no and i'm just trying to highlight the fact that this ability to be in a specific area is great with
technical remote viewing in fact superior statistically to other methods uh that has an extreme extreme
value but the point i love to highlight and uh when i do classes you know i've studied a broad spectrum
of different uh non-local data gathering modalities and had experiences and research and blah blah blah
to me the most extraordinary part is the underlying reality of this connectivity and that you know
technical remote viewing and i want to know more you guys describe some things that made me want to put
more tools in my toolbox you know and um i think that you know right now a conversation about this stuff
uh is super important like you were saying you think this is important for our future i do too
i think it may be pivotal to our kids survival and the other tiny little thing i disagree with
is about your kind of separating empathy with the technicals of doing this stuff
and i put them both together i think it's about resonance with a target with technical remote
viewing you're having an empathy this kind of classic stereotypical uh you know thing they say
is two tuning forks you're having this empathetic reaction and the wonderful and powerful thing about
tuning forks is they uh transfer back and forth not only energy but data back and forth across what was
previously a barrier and to me that's empathy and so i i draw that you know we're ultimately we're agreeing
in this space just saying in different ways thank you for giving me the opportunity to clarify what i'm
saying right that's that's one of the best things about look no one should be exempt from criticism no one
should be exempt from being challenged and everyone should hopefully look at those as opportunities to
clarify what they're saying or to learn from someone else um to be specific to answer that question for you
like i hope i answered the other one right it's just that like the i was limiting myself to the to the
topic of the space right and just to to finish that like someone has to connect the first bunch of
computers to create the internet but the internet isn't the wrap net anymore right like it's it's not
limited to that what we're talking about is is putting in the plug we're not talking about who will do
what after that right so there could be 8 000 psychic modalities and maybe no one ever remembers what
technical remote viewing is we're just talking about how to take advantage of this opportunity right now
in order to turn that system on um to use a metaphor as far as the empathy i agree with you 100 empathy
is a term that's often used it is very important right but what the term that i was using was love
right and i was briefly touching on the reason i didn't articulate it is because the topic of this
space isn't religious beliefs right and and my uh vision or my experience of of love the term the
type of love that i'm talking about isn't that focused passionate attention it's agape right and the
thing about that is is that there are a lot of people here who want to talk about technical remote
viewing but they might not be here to talk about my christian beliefs right and the loving another
the way you love yourself empathy is important but they're not the same thing so it definitely empathy
is is feeling right what someone else feels but you can have empathy for someone and not love them the
way you love them yourself as a matter of fact very few people can what i was just throwing out there
is that that's something that we have to work on in another area but i was intentionally distancing it
from the conversation because i don't want to drag everyone into the conversation they don't want to
have right and it's funny that you bring that up go ahead man a few weeks ago we had this dude get
lost as hell man in a snowstorm like he was freaking out man and um he had asked chat gbt for directions
to get around this snowstorm and it was like like his logic his thinking was not there he should have
just stayed put and waited where he was in the city and instead of trying to drive around but um
it was really weird because like i you know i helped him get back to town and he was fine
um and he was like what do i do i was like well dude you're holding your breath that's why you feel
like you gotta chill out and breathe a little bit get a hotel room and just sit there and breathe for
a day man and um it was weird because i for some reason um like had when we were i was like walking
away from him i i just said it's all good man he was like super thankful i was like it's all good
man i love you and i've never said i love you to someone like that i don't even know before like that
really like in uh i mean you know on the street but it was just like it just came out and it was it was
pretty weird um but uh it's interesting that that popped into my head during this conversation because
the technology got him so lost man he should have just sat and waited a little bit
oh yeah i'm sorry i dropped my
i don't believe so i got dumped from the space i apologize i'm back but i did hear what you say
fletcher and i understand the feeling like it's when you have it it's it's almost like something
that doesn't come from you it's hard to explain but it's very real when you experience it it's difficult
to hold on to it um through life um i for instance am am not a pleasant driver i live in a place where
people are they're very inconsiderate and my reaction to them is is that i'm not i'm i'm not happy with
them right so uh i have difficulty in that moment remaining connected to that feeling of of loving
that person but i do know what it's like to love people odd in an odd context and have it sort of be
surprising and it's something you try to cultivate more but we're all doing the best well it was weird
because like i didn't know what else to say you know it was like yeah it was like that's what
he needed to hear or something like like he just kept apologizing apologizing and as soon as i said i
love you he was like oh yeah dude and i was like dude yeah spread the word man yeah his name muhammad or
something like he was totally out of his element and some i mean i don't know i it's it's a very complicated
subject but some of us are are moving in the direction of experiencing that more um but that's
probably a topic for another space like to get into like really break down like what what's going on and
but i'm glad you had that experience i'm glad you were able to be there for him right because that's
again like that's the the only thing we can really do sometimes is be there for other people who are having
the same experience with us because regardless of whether each individual here buys into the idea
or supports the idea that this is where we are as a form of prison right a form of prison is a metaphor that
that fits a lot of our experiences obviously having a different attitude having um the way you look at things changes the way you experience those things but we all
have confinement and limitation and powerlessness and unfairness in our life to one degree or another
right and so we're all in that in that together and because of that it's really important to
for people who are like really in that experience to know that somebody loves them right you know not in a
possessive way not in a sexual way not but in in a in a very real sense like we're we're in this together
right and i and i i have that feeling for you and i i mean i know that i'm i'm an animal rights guy and not everyone is
uh but i feel the same way about animals like i you know it's very it's you you people have more defenses
so they they won't show you how important that is but anyone who spent a lot of time around animals knows that the animals have
their defenses
are aren't as strong and it's very obvious that that's what they need
they really really need to even if they have they might have behavior issues they might be like
um having dominance issues or whatever with you like they might need to do cat or dog or horse or
chicken things or snake things or roach things right they may need to do that but it they they need at
some point or they respond positively at some point to that feeling of of of that that type of love
right where it's like a safer um it's it's like safer for them to be what they are
you know so um just having that changes the quality of someone's experience so it's it's it's
it's good that you were able to do that for them uh go ahead buddy i saw your hand up dude
and brother i think this totally applies to technical remote viewing and different you know forms of
remote viewing and it leads me to want to ask morgan a question is if he's available um what types if he
is um how do you feel empathy in that resonance uh with a target or certain objective data uh affects the
quality of it uh if it's more disassociation or is it more a kind of sublime uh empathy and then the
second question is what kind of stuff do have you seen a technical remote viewing more consistently
and accurately uh target in terms of objectives whether objects locations good crimes you know different
aspects that it might be more suited to uh yeah sure great great questions um okay so for the first one
about about empathy and all that well so okay i i would have to say i'm a natural empath however
a long time ago i discovered that it didn't and i don't mean for this from a selfish like a personal
game type perspective but i'm i will say that it didn't do me any good and what i mean by that is
you know absorbing and feeling what other people are feeling you know most of the time at least for
me it tends to be like sadness probably more than anything and you know feeling other people's sadness
um it's just not conducive to anything really it's like you know we all have our pain and it's like
i mean speaking for myself my own is you know enough to freaking deal with without you know having to
tune in to and to the point of you know borderline experiencing anyone else's so i basically shut it off
um semi-consciously and that's not to say i did it through any kind of you know uh
you know ritual or or any kind of like a mechanism but it was more like i kind of just instructed my
uh higher mind to just you know don't do this don't give me this um it doesn't help me or anyone else
um so that was my experience with empathy and probably following on with that um you know well from from
from the get-go my intention uh with the pursuit of remote viewing has always just been um a matter of
data collection problem solving um and
to that end um i've always approached remote viewing with a uh
uh uh an intention to remain totally detached uh from the target which again is you know it's one of the
big differences between trv and crv methods so crv method is significantly more immersive
more experiential and you're more open to um
arguably a deeper connection with the target and i actually actively try and avoid that because
um yeah again for my purposes i'm not interested in having an experience i'm interested in observing
and recording uh information in service of solving a problem and very seldom you know would
having a more immersive experiential um well experience uh i just i generally don't find that conducive to
problem solving so again that's you know that's a personal thing that's that's always been my approach
is just keep it all at arm's length i am merely a passive observer and uh reporter um
you know other people have you know very different points of view on that which it's i think it's a
personal thing which again is one of the things that attracted me to uh trv method in the first place
um now the second oh crap i'm sorry can you please repeat your the second question
no i totally love it and there's this weird balance between self lessness you know not trying to be
yourself trying to be less controlling you know in all these modalities so i i love that answer thank
you and the second question was are there specific types of targets that uh you know quantitatively
you have seen you know repeatedly that uh technical is best suited towards or more accurate towards or
is it a spectrum of almost all the different types of targets yeah so in my opinion um
again and this is you know this is my opinion of my experience other other people might
say differently and i have no problem with that but my take on it is uh now trv when it's
when you approach it kind of the way that i always have or at least have intended to um it's
suitable to a totally broad range of problem sets um and again it's really it's really about
the what would you say the um unconscious i suppose agreement or understanding between the the specific
uh designated target i.e pattern of information um and the viewers ability to objectively retrieve that
information um so i think we kind of touched on earlier but you know different i think it's a personal
aptitude thing because you know for whatever reason like for example um
you know you'd have to ask the other guys because i you know my opinion of my own work
is can never be fully objective but generally speaking i've i've always been pretty good at
landscapes um and terrain just for whatever reason you know and mapping and that sort of thing like i'm
usually pretty good with um you know the the type of terrain like you know is it natural is it man-made um you
know are we in a city are we out in the middle of nowhere are we in a cave are we you know up in the
sky all that kind of stuff just for whatever reason that just is really easy to me um
other people you know are maybe stronger with uh when people are involved or you know if it's um
like a target site where there's a lot of people engage in activity you know i'll probably i'll pick
up on that and i'll be able to report like roughly what they're doing and you know some of the feelings
and emotions and activities and things um but i'll probably at least right off the bat i'll probably
have stronger and more reliable data on the surroundings um whereas someone else they might you know the
they might weigh you know 70 30 or 60 40 the other way um so from from that perspective yeah it's i think
i think it's more individual aptitude than than the method itself
i uh when you talk about compartmentalizing empathy all i can think of now because of the metaphor we're
using is is context management and really you know not not allowing extra context that has a pull on on
your energy or on the other information um i think that uh trv is trv viewers are more likely to be on target
that's i don't know if you guys do anything like specifically like any specific detail better so
much as you're just you're less likely to um to get in whose nation territory to get into the off target
that's my opinion though you know better than i do okay i again broadly speaking i do think that's
correct and the reason i say that um is you know in my opinion the the genius of trv structure is
it yeah i'm trying to be pretty careful with my words but it's i think it eliminates for certain pit
balls that are inherent to crv and and that that is done through a process of streamlining and it's
that's the way you know i always describe trv in my opinion as streamlined and efficient and what i mean by
that is is by its nature you know i mentioned earlier in crv you are you are a lot more uh
open things are a lot more open-ended and you're you're free to uh wander and explore a little more
whereas in trv it you're you kept a little more focused and you're not really afforded
room to meander it kind of forces you into a kind of a tunnel and it forces you to ignore extraneous data
and kind of get straight to the point um and there we go contract management yep
we're on it we're hitting it go ahead sorry dude no no you're i think i think you're right um
so uh you know sometime i'll i'll fairly recently i got permission to publish uh
some session work that i did uh was just looked at it april 21st 2018 so just over eight years ago and
it i was really happy that i'm that i'm able to talk about this one because it demonstrates
at least what i'm trying to get at which is the the efficiency here so what i mean by that is okay so
that the target was it was an individual um so their name slash they were experiencing at that
time a respiratory issue so it was name slash current respiratory issue
slash optimum treatment or cure slash presently available so again if if you can
think of it in terms of we're trying to direct our attention towards a particular pattern of information
the language they're used is precise enough that it the answer it becomes a superlative there can be only one
right uh optimum treatment or cure presently available that that can be only one thing at you know as it as
it pertains to the individual's current respiratory issue you see what i'm getting at so it's
extremely precise in in what it's asking for it's saying you know i don't give a shit about
anything outside of this i don't even need to know the why i just need to know the what
so i ran a session it was probably it was you know probably a 40 to 45 minute session
just a a quick one we call it a base session um and basically
i'll i'll uh i don't have it right here but i'll some place some time i will i'll post the actual
the full session and so you guys can take a look at it but
um basically uh what i wound up with at the end of my 40 ish minute session is i've got
a diagram we call it a site template and that is it's basically a blueprint or a diagrammatic
uh mock-up sketch of
the target site or the idea if it's a more conceptual target and i basically so i have this kind of it's like
this kind of it's like a side view kind of a cutaway of a structure and i've kind of mapped it out a
little bit like there's what you know the kind of main bay area i've got a locker room and then i've got
this like central vacuum filtration type system and then i've shown and in sketching i i've indicated that
okay there's some problem with this vacuum system and it's blasting all these
little
particulate um through the ventilation system uh in the in this building and i had a concept that this
stuff is making me itchy and sneezy and i said it's uh you know it's uh compounds
uh materials these little airborne particulate and long story short um so the individual he was a
apprentice uh panel beater you know for like a automotive restoration and it turned out that yeah the
central filtration system for you know all their uh sanding equipment and all that was
busted and overflowing and yeah so it was blasting all these uh uh uh what's the word um and i guess
noxious compounds and things throughout the air and right so bing bang boom problem solved so
what's the answer to the question to the uh to the problem the problem well the optimum or treatment
or cure to this individual's current respiratory issue is to eliminate or limit exposure to
the the problem at the workplace and that was it so you know that right there um
probably we did that in in less and so my session like i said took me 40 45 minutes i had about a half
hour uh debrief with the project manager and that was it so you know i that problem was solved in
well under an hour and a half um i don't think a doctor could have done that you know by the time
he had to you know run tests and who knows what bloods and and all this kind of thing so
you know that right there i i think is a really good example of the the efficiency of of the trv
approach to solving a problem like that you know your again your context or your designated target
is specific enough but open-ended enough that you know the viewer um although i don't know what the
target is when i'm running it my unconscious mind does and you know it can it can go out there
interpret the problem and oh yeah okay well and then this is where um charles was was using a word
that i think is is really underappreciated in remote viewing part of the data collection process
is absolutely a matter of translation you know because the unconscious does not speak english it
understands it but it doesn't speak it so there is a translation process that is occurring you know in
the in that data retrieval um process and that's where a lot of a lot of mistakes are made um
no that's where like culture and stuff starts to play a role yeah
what you bring into it starts to play a role right i mean that's it's it has to for most people
yeah like you're going to you know ed ed would always say you know uh if you have never
uh witnessed or experienced something as simple as the color red
how do you how are you going to describe that well you because you you can perceive it but you don't
have the the lexicon of vocabulary for it so you know you might say it's like well it's kind of like
pink but it's darker uh you know you might say um oh i don't know what's uh you know it kind of it
reminds me of blood you know things like that um you're describing it without naming it and you can
do that with things that you do not understand um you might have a bit more difficult time uh
analyzing and interpreting after the fact um like you know again like i'm obviously i'm i'm not a medical
doctor i have me you know maybe other than like first aid training qualifications i had
back in the day like 20 years ago you know that's the extent of my uh formal uh medical knowledge um
nonetheless getting your data to somebody who does right like you if you can translate it effectively
oh yeah someone who understands can look at it and understand what it means that's what for me that's
what the iu canon data did right like like they were right things that i couldn't understand in in
the gnostic text from antiquity or the the esoteric tibetan buddhist text etc like things i couldn't
understand because i didn't have that connection right and then once i recognized what i saw in the
iu data i was able to take that as a rosetta stone go back and say oh this is what they're talking about
and that continues to this day like when i run into things like i i had mentioned that you know based
on one of our conversations i went back and i reread the kabbalah which i was never really interested
in and i was like oh okay now i understand it like um i just wanted to hit a couple quick things
and then toss it to fletcher um i don't mean to cut you off cut you off do you need a few more minutes or
it seemed like you might be wrapping it up but i don't want to oh yeah okay okay so well i
i mean you're my co-host you can't be my co-host right i i you know that's i have to be concerned
about you okay so um i wanted to say that uh oh it was two things and of course i'm going to forget
one of those things um what i'm about to say might sound very strange but to tie into some of the
the earlier stuff uh like how it all ties together with trv and you and ed um and this may not be your
experience because you knew him personally and i didn't i knew him from the radio right but one of
the things that i always respected or drew me to ed as opposed to the other um stargate remote viewers
who would appear on the radio and this is this is the honest truth this is just a perception right
it may be completely off but it was perception his exterior her his persona right was the military
guy it was kind of a tough callous dude but what came through to me i really felt like if you if you
put them all in a room and said to me which one of these people on it on a on a on the at the at the
core feels the most love for his fellow man i would say that that's a fact now that may not be true
right i i don't know but that was the perception that i had and you could see that
in the passion he had for trying to get the word out about the future things that he was concerned
about how many times do we talk about people in the remote viewing community who have access to the
session data the session perceptions about like dangerous things that people are going to experience
in the future right the la fires the north carolina floods the you know all the way up to the the
the the light and things that happen after death and um and the pole shift right and they sit on that
data if they keep it on their hard drive because they don't it's by revealing it right it's going to
impede them doing what they want right or getting what they want or it's going to have some they're
concerned about some sort of negative effect on themselves ed went on over and over and over again
even when it started to be not i'm not like it was wrong right but there started to be a stigma right
it did because you know the events that he was predicting he he didn't have the time scale right
not to disrespect him and and people were like why do you keep going on there and talking about this
it hasn't happened but he did because he was passionate about warning people about that's love
that it is that that that is at its core the love for another person the fact that you're willing to
endure you know at best skepticism and and some ridicule because you feel you want to get this
this message of survival out to other people i mean does that sound crazy to you as someone who knew him
oh no quite the opposite um you know at okay ed was yeah he had it he you know they call him dr doom
and i mean sure that was and you know what though he played into that he ed was he was the sweetest guy he
really was he loved life he loved people um and he was trying to improve the lives of as many people as he
could he really was um i got i gotta say probably the thing that really caught me most off guard
was i was hilarious the guy was legitimately hilarious constantly um i you know to this day i'm just like
really because you know he does not seem like that sort but he was um there's a there's a playfulness
a curiosity to him um and uh yeah no i just i couldn't agree more with that's what i'm saying like
this is why you know what the first thing that happened when we connected after ed's passing
i said we the world needs ed this is exactly when they need it the world needs that right it's not
just his ability to organize the remote viewing community it's not just his ability to expand the
applications of remote viewing right it's it's that love inside that that would cause someone to
sort of step out of their professional boundaries and dedicate a large part of their life to trying to
help other people right that's we need that and it speaks to like this duty that comes with a decent
person that comes upon you when you have skills or information it almost feels like a duty you know
you see it with ingo swan and so many different others pat price as i mentioned before others feel
like there's a duty to help people to utilize this to um you know explore it there's this duty to benefit
others buddy toss this to fletch because he's been waiting i hear what you're saying 100 that's all
good i'm sorry you're right i'm sorry no i i was just putting it down because the conversation was
better than what i had you know what i was what the second thing i was going to say
was um as morgan was talking it clarified like one of the things we often talk about is there are
there's a cult a heroic a cult of heroic personalities in the roping community right like
heroic abilities not that people view themselves as superheroes but there's really like uh who's the
best remote viewer and particularly in in crv with um with lynn right like the ability to use data
spreadsheets to to to isolate who is is best at each type of target but what i think that those of us who
support trv a little bit more than the other modalities but not disrespecting them is the
optimizing the ability to utilize the the psychic potential of the average person and the average
viewer right so like there will be people who are these phenoms right who are these pat prices
who who leave everyone else in the dust and maybe that person can answer every question right without
without these protocols but then there are there are the majority of remote viewers who maybe they
don't have that ability right and so that's where the context management the techniques
to to limit all the extraneous stuff and just get down to exactly the information that's necessary
right can take those individuals who may not be heroic road viewers but can give them the ability to to
make a difference to be able to answer these these questions come to to perceive these solutions that
make a meaningful difference in people's lives and the thing about that is is that one heroic person can
can only do so much right but by empowering the the average remote viewer and the person who's who's who
becomes a student of remote viewing it you you end up with x exponential growth right i mean would you
what would you rather have would you rather have one pat price or or 10 000 like good utility remote
viewers you don't you don't want to have the 10 000 good remote utility remote viewers right as far as
being better for humanity and everyone like utilizing the the technique so i that was the other part of of
what i wanted to say and if you want to finish up what you were saying i apologize for interjecting
that was rude to me i just i didn't want to be rude to fletcher and if not we can toss to fletcher it's
up to you fletch please go i can wait certainly oh yeah um yeah so i just uh i'll be real quick so that
dude who got lost chat gpt um it wasn't completely the jet chat gpt's fault because he didn't follow
the instructions properly he got the highway number wrong um one of them was three digits one was two digits
just like simple reading mistake or something um and then um also my question from earlier was uh
i wanted to know if you i remember from the previous spaces um that you had like the first couple um
um so i these a couple friends of mine on this app like really like people that i really like to talk
to i really like their stuff um really i would consider them good friends even though i you know
haven't spent all that much time with them um asked one of them asked to start a data um
a data agent for neutrinos because we love talking about neutrinos uh we've all kind of um found
ourselves wondering about the things and and remembering back to your first couple spaces that
i was in um it seems like you guys might have already done this um especially after morgan was mentioning
the propensity toward environment um backgrounds surrounding that type of stuff um but then uh real
quick since you guys were talking about like phenoms and and that type of thing one of the things i've been
saying for man as soon as i learned about remote viewing i've been kind of this is kind of a phrase that
keeps popping into my head and i've shared it with a few people but um you know and getting more people
interested in it and and what it is and and how it works and how it affects everybody and and all that
stuff is this little phrase here uh remote viewing is a gateway drug and i think it's kind of funny
because it's a little tongue-in-cheek too but um i mean i i suppose it could be um i have seen some
people move from remote viewing to other what i think buddy would call modalities uh neutrinos i i
use a lot of ideas for utility's sake um cognition is you know reconciling paradoxes using like
other metaphors so you've got to have a working understanding of a lot of things but that doesn't
necessarily mean you're an expert in a lot of things there are some things i'm an expert in
neutrinos is not one of them so i definitely don't have any information about opening a data set on
neutrinos um i i know about neutrino detectors i know roughly what neutrinos are um i don't necessarily
have any ideas uh about what role they would play um from the perspective of simulationism although i think
you know just spitballing that you know cosmic particles in general the particle is synonymous with
information right and that the connection would be the the context unit so whenever you have um
you know there are definitely in esoteric circles um particles and radio waves and and whatnot that
travel through the the medium of space or the astral plane as they call it right um carry information
that changes much like cosmic rays supposedly can create mutations that that change biological organs
so it's they would say it's like a transmission of of of information and from the perspective of
simulationism where you got this like crystallizing information then i guess that would kind of make
sense from an esoteric sense but i don't i would have to like uh like the broad topic of data sets of
neutrinos i don't really have anything for you um i don't know if morgan does but i i definitely
don't um it's a good question and if you're interested in neutrinos and yeah definitely
look into it more um i don't know of any utility in using neutrinos as a metaphor so it just isn't
something that i've i've focused on well so this is kind of one of the people she went um
she was trying to remove you the neutrino detector in an arca after she heard about that and she
couldn't get there couldn't get there and she ended up getting guided there by a whale um
so that's kind of the short end of it okay so specifically like looking into the neutrino
detector and like from a moving standpoint i got it i i thought you were just talking in general like
from uh uh no i mean yeah it's expanded a lot but that's kind of that's how her story started
with the neutrinos oh it's a good idea yeah so and then it just opened up a whole load of things
man and and what made me think about it was when you get get into similar your guys uh more touchy
aspects of what you guys have found um that's and where i start to get interested in neutrinos
i mean uh so you know um just the other day someone was mentioning to me that uh what the hell they
called uh they spin around um not dervishes sufi sufi so the sufi look at the universe as um
as as as one individual's body and that actually goes back you can go back to um adam the original adam
adam caught him on in like jewish esotericism and you go back to zoroastrianism and it's like anyhow
that that's an old idea right but the way it it translates into simulationism uh from the
perspective that we're looking at it with the uh being based on a biological strata like biological
hardware running on actual neurological tissue uh is when you look at the universe itself
right you you see or what people often see um seems to represent a brain right so there's this whole
idea like you i'm sure you've heard this like every solar system in a sense is um an atom right there's a
uh a correlation is um almost a fractal relationship of some kind um one is large one is small but they're
but in some sense they're the same um but if you google it you can find it there are people who write
articles every once in a while on the amazing similarity between how um astronomers look at
the universe and think astrophysicists how the universe works and how a human brain works or a brain in
general i'm not a neurologist i'm not a um astrophysicist but i've been reading these
articles since i was a kid and there are definitely people who see that uh similarity and from the
perspective of simulationism that would make sense right because we're the the universe and everything
in it is a reflection of ourselves to some degree um so if we're you know uh software operating on
biological hardware and that biological hardware is neurological tissue then you would expect that our
model of the universe that we perceive would be akin to or a member of a brain right and you would
also expect that in cultures around the world they would have the idea that the universe is part of one
giant man um or woman depending i guess on on who you talk to i think generally it's man but that's
like as we know there there were cultural sexist issues etc right person um if you look at the
world like that from that esoteric standpoint or from that simulator standpoint right like everything
has a meaning so neutrinos definitely have a meaning i might not be the person who's qualified
to say what that meaning is but anything that exists is also a mirror of ourselves in some way
otherwise we wouldn't be able to perceive it right so all perceptions are perceptions of the cell
um in in like a strata that's a mirror basically is what it comes down to so yeah i mean of course
there's there's esoteric significance to neutrinos and um it's probably a lot of uh a lot of physics
related um effects of neutrinos that we're not aware of right like they're carrying some sort of
information um across the medium of the astral plane space to us i just don't know what it is but i think
it's a great remote viewing topic here's the thing uh there are a lot of remote viewers who uh practice
remote viewing and they need to practice they need practice targets but they also work professionally
and one of the challenges when you come up with great practice targets for remote viewers
is the perception that you're attempting to harvest free remote viewing from them right it's like well
you know we get paid to do this so if you want to know what a neutrino is then only up now that's a
valid thing right that's their profession so you just kind of have to wait and keep track of the session
data and if i if and when i see session data on um on neutrinos and neutrinos um that eric hecker's
thing that large neutrino uh thing in the ice in the antarctica that's perceiving the neutrinos i
forget his his term for it he's got a name specific name for it right like i'll definitely send you that
information um i just haven't seen any yet but it definitely seems like i'm sure there is
uh rv session uh data on the subject there's a lot of data in hard drives because again people do this
as a profession to make money doing it right so when they when they do this uh valuable practice
uh session work uh they they don't want to just hand it out right because if you just keep handing
out all your data then the the price of your your services it goes down so um
yeah it's out there we'll find it at some point and and i'll give it to you i just there's no way i
could um i could nudge anyone and say hey why don't you do why don't you look into neutrinos because
you know um they would rightfully want to be compensated but i'm sure and i think it's valuable
what your friend is doing um as far as like the antarctica thing yeah i've heard that uh some people
have no problem and then some people say you know i was down there and i was pushed away or um a lot
of it i think i'm gonna be honest with you i i don't know for a fact what your friend does but
i do know that people who astral project right now this people who practice astral protection
doggedly insist it's remote view and in a sense it is but it's not what people who practice remote
viewing mean when they talk about remote viewing right so that that experience the experience of being
blocked shut off intercepted pushed away is definitely an experience that i've heard
more from or primarily from people who are involved in astral body traveling for whatever reason is
that because i don't know um i would be confabulating if i was gonna um tell you that i'm
certain what the difference is between uh when someone's practicing um regular remote viewing and um
astral body traveling right because some people who do the astral body travel i think it's all just a
metaphor and they're just remote viewing but there might be a subtle body involved that is actually
going to the place and that body perhaps can be repelled um i mean if it's subtle it's still physical
in some sense right so if you talk about etheric astral body you're still talking about a
uh something that has in some sense mass or energy something tangible that could be um
resisted whereas if you're talking about like um clear cognizance what buddy or morgan do um that
something would be a lot more difficult to resist i do think it's possible um but that's a very
complicated story so i don't know what your your friend is doing but it it seems like um perhaps you
might benefit i don't mean this disrespectfully i'm being serious like perhaps you might benefit from
from working with a more experienced remote viewer in order to take her skills to the
the next level so she can get those answers that she's looking for you know
uh yeah for sure i mean we might have to just like get her get you guys in contact or something
um i was trying to find her pictures she made some t-shirts too i was going to try and post that
um fletch do you happen to be talking about uh mu what's her name okay yeah i know who she is uh yeah
we follow each other um i do believe uh i think she pro i love unless i'm i could totally be mistaken
because i'm not overly familiar with with what she does but i see i have seen
uh over a period of time yeah i've seen enough of her posts that that's what i figured because she
frequently talks about neutrinos um i think she does something that is more akin to astral travel
um as opposed to like structured remote viewing um i could be mistaken but i believe that to be the case
um so it's kind of you know again it's in the discussion it's a different modality probably
completely different targeting and and all that kind of stuff um but beyond that i really i have no
specific um knowledge of of her process or the target yeah i think you're right i mean i just i mean
we just all like the the few of us that are just like talking about it all the time thing or like
thinking about it all the time yeah like i've seen enough of her stuff that i'm like okay that's
interesting and quite possibly yeah there's something there that i mean i also got to say that kind of
thing is that's totally out of my wheelhouse i've really never been um personally involved with
that end of of the research um because again my like my uh purpose in rv has always been
practical problem solving applications basically and there's you know there's all kinds of people
that are way more interested in the research end of things and you know what can we learn like by
you know what can we discover the mechanism the underlying mechanism that allows for this to happen
and i've kind of that's kind of what i took from from all that kind of thing which again is you know
interesting i just it's totally out of my wheelhouse so i'm not familiar enough to really give any
let me toss it there though uh fletch uh that phenomenon the claim right that astral body travelers
have that they are repelled from american and some foreign military bases particularly from antarctica
i think that has merit like i i i wouldn't dismiss it because their actual body travels i'm saying like
there's a reason if they're if they're projecting a subtle body there right they could definitely
i mean you have to imagine with technology that you could block that in some way right because you
can block any type of particle including neutrinos right i mean hypothetically the neutrino detector
is slowing them at least um and that's how it's able to detect them um i i don't know about you but i've
never dreamt of being in antarctica has anyone here dreamt of being in antarctica a show of hands a show
of thumbs anyone anyone had a dream of being in antarctica so there are a lot of people who have
abilities with um lucid dreaming and have some astral body traveling abilities right and um i think that
if one had a significant enough level of technology that might be something would want to do uh because
information percolates up to us through the collective unconscious through our experiences on this subtle
level through our dreams into our waking consciousness that's like how inventors work right that's how
famous inventors like nikolai tesla and thomas edison worked thomas edison used to sleep in a chair with
metal balls in his hand so that when the metal balls dropped he would wake up and write down what he was
dreaming about so that is a very valid way uh it's i don't i don't put it on the level of remote viewing
but and it's a valid way of retrieving information and uh if you've got a world full of people who can
bring back information from their dreams and you got something you don't want people dreaming about and
you got the technology to push people away it only makes sense that you would be doing it so i think
her experience is probably a hundred percent right on um if she were to work with someone like morgan or
buddy she might find a way around that um but people get committed to their the modality as buddy would
say yeah mine uh my interest in neutrinos is totally from a totally different perspective it didn't have
anything really to do with remote viewing or anything it was just like a personal experience i can go into
that later if you want to sure go ahead yeah go ahead buddy um i am and others are you know more natural
towards the an astral kind of modality and experience and um from my kind of mindset um
and i think it's true and many other practitioners have spoken about it that it's almost impossible to
prevent kind of this interaction there's ways to distract it there's different belief systems on
it but a lot of uh other factors kind of take part in it too a lot of uh well-known practitioners have
spoke about going to places and locations and felt like they were being observed and that they weren't
welcome and that kind of drove them to leave um but on neutrinos and uh usability and science um
different modalities have been used to make incredible inventions and progress in real world stuff like
jt was talking about with thomas edison and many others and um my gestalt and i love your interest in
neutrinos and especially collecting data sets i think there's a value there that may not have been
exploited yet you know if you take all the data sets from neutrinos anti-neutrinos all the different
uh and even uh possible interactions into the data sets like uh you know entropy like virtual particles
um things that don't happen could be as valuable as the things that we do observe and neutrinos are so
um elusive and ghost-like and you know the energy levels that produce them the masses over what time
scales can reveal deeper things in the data sets in the statistics in the um volumetrics so i think
that's a super cool pursuit and i i love that the insatiable desire of understanding of humans you know and
um you know i really agree with morgan and you you see this again and again people want
to have usability especially and obviously for good and the elite know about this know the reality of
it and utilize it for everything from medical to scientific to they've used it to locate you know
targets of national security interest to describe very specifically targets of national security interest so
to me i'm not the best ambassador of these abilities that we have but i have experienced such
a transformative understanding and experiences that it challenges my own uh belief system about the
envelopes of our capabilities i love to speak about this kid named ben osborne who was born born blind and he
taught himself echolocation at a very high proficiency usability real world level can determine the densities
of objects could even ride a bicycle and he passed away at a very very young age but that knowledge that
ability of what we had already in us um he now that proof of that has taught many blind people another way of
enriching their lives and experiencing the world around them and their safety and stuff so i i freaking love
this stuff and i bet you know trv could get you the real technical data and information you might be
seeking and even stuff that you don't know you should be seeking um and i think there's something that i
i still don't have enough education on to make a great assessment but i see this pivotal value in the
prompts and how that can really help nail down specifics and usability and stuff so i i really uh
you know i really enjoy this this conversation i think the future needs every bit of everything humanity
has our kids need it you know we've left them uh a shit storm so if they could be the best thems they
could be you know um and tap into more of these abilities and make you know the impossible only live
like yeah in our fears and be better at these things you know what i mean but not everyone's built that
way and i guess that's fine you know not everyone's supposed to you know explore this stuff to have a super
high level of usability or practicality it could just give them the sense of really knowing that
everything's connected uh touching the extraordinary uh there's all sorts of different levels you know
um so there's a poetry and a beauty in this and i i love the conversation and you know you guys as
ambassadors of these questions so love you guys i'd like to take a chance to thank everyone for being
here sending uh a yellow wolverine i can't read um your name but uh welcome cody sally sarabath i think
they were here earlier with a different uh nice new avatar um i guess you're red panda koala now is that
how it is like everyone was shane for a week and then everyone was um mellow and i guess we're
red panic wall now that's fine he's he's all right kai laurie dark um melissa blue shane diogenes
uh bark like a duck you're the one who um who prompted me to uh say welcome to everyone again
um although i i think i've touched base with most of them before but just let them know i
appreciate them being here i let you down yesterday i apologize i've been thinking about it i need to
stop posting spaces unless i'm sure that i'm going to make the space because
you know even if i'm not the most important person in the world you can still let someone
down by not showing up for space that you post uh i think he bailed after i said that i uh
that i let him down that's fine i i apologized and i did what i have to do um
fletch go ahead and oh there you go bark like a duck i was just uh uh regaling everyone with um
how much i appreciate you being here okay uh fletch neutrino story go ahead man
yes yeah so um okay i don't know if it's neutrinos or not but like
you know like these conversations when something really weird happens basically what happened is i sat
down to meditate on death and dying i had my godfather had cancer my dog had cancer and i was like man i
really need to find out figure out what's going on so i'm gonna i'm gonna sit here and meditate on it
family's gone i'm here by myself like quiet um you know i have some pretty good odds of like
you know making some headway here and figuring out what the
what the problem is here like what's the universe trying to tell me
and i immediately laid down and sat there and i was immediate i was immediately super super
relaxed just with the intention that i was going in into this um little experiment with
so i was i was very relaxed uh
so relaxed like more relaxed than i've ever been in my life before um and
so i i i couldn't even feel a heartbeat i couldn't feel breathing i couldn't feel anything um
i i i was um the only thing that i could feel after not noticing anything for a little while um
was this like fall spinning turning inside out
on itself inside of me and i'd seen like this vision when i was a kid like with nitrous at the
dentist office or going to bed i would see this thing in my in my like you know in my vision it was like
this uh you know five seven pointed object that would be poofy and then skinny and then poopy and skinny
and always wondered what that was about you never really did anything other than just make shakes um
but it was interesting because you could never tell when it went from being one form to the other it was
like a it just all of a sudden it was another thing and all of a sudden it was another thing
um and it would just alternate back and forth between these two like paradigms i guess
and then i i was so relaxed i felt that inside of me like deep within my heart solar plexus
is somewhere down deep and so i just paid attention to that and um instantly i was riding a black hole
through the event horizon um instantly everything that i experienced after that was more real than
anything that i've ever felt or experienced um it was very very real uh i don't know like i'm
i've heard this i've heard people say this before um and this was the first part was riding the black
hole through the event horizon eventually my hand and arm and part of my head kind of went through
and started turning to dust and ash and i had this feeling that um i was going to take the whole universe
with me to turn to dust and ash and i was like that's probably not a good idea so i opened my eyes and
there i am just sitting on the couch like nothing had ever happened totally sober and um i was like wow
okay well at least everything's okay um so i was a little worried not not very much but like it was
like it was pretty weird so i closed my eyes like okay cool so this is fine like this is safe
um and i closed my eyes again and then i was in like basically the this time stream everything was
uh you know brightly colored uh kind of similar colors in my profile but i just changed that a day ago
and uh flowing like uh salvador dolly painting is the best example that i have uh where you see those
clocks that are melted into like 90 degree angles and stuff like that that's how everything was kind of
flowing um and so that kind of got boring so then it was just like okay well
um am i still on the couch yep uh just still laying there on the couch totally fine nothing's going on
and so i close my eyes again and then i'm immediately sitting in front of these three um
uh large beings made of light code like uh again the light was a different color than
what we really see here is like uh dark purple dark blue dark red dark yellow um
and it was like grains of rice like these beans these three beings were made up of these grains of rice
of light um these little grains of light every once in a while one would pop in one would pop out
and um they the only place that i had ever seen these things before
um is invaded statues with like the full mandala behind their head and everything and um
then when i first got there they were like uh how did you get here where'd you come from and i was
like i don't know how to shrug my shoulders i was like i'm just as baffled as you are trust me
um and eventually they just went back to being um instead of being interested in me
um and i was like well this is pretty cool this is really interesting so i uh i was um
hanging out with them for a while i didn't really ask anything i just was like being with them and uh
um
i eventually was like okay well i should probably check on myself am i still on the couch like just sitting there
and so i did slowly and the most interesting thing happened i experienced embodying i was like
making the same symbol with my hand my leg was in the same cocked position my head was turned to the left and
down or up i can't really remember exactly uh at the same exact like
position that this one dude was doing right
not only that but a month and a half later when i had like a rough time i asked for some help and
and i don't know man it just it at the time i was like digging into scientific stuff i was really
interested in like the the new paradigms of science that we see popping up everywhere instead of the same
old stuff that you find in books and institutional things um and
neutrinos really resonated so i was like well you know these little grains of white and what were they man
so that's kind of my story with my interest in neutrinos
well that makes sense and that could very well be what is going on i mean i think that's one of the
not common and then go ahead and then also and just to relate it to you guys and like your first couple
spaces that you had with like you know doomer and then after that and stuff like that
um you know they back into the conversation of the archons and like um you know that that's kind of
how it relates to you guys i guess yeah no i mean that's one of the
for the unseen right like the the the somewhat unseen or partially unseeable or
more difficult to perceive levels of reality one of the theories that people have is that it's
it's light right like that's worlds embedded in the light that's around us and i guess you're right
about neutrinos so that would make sense like there could be um entire levels of reality that are
embedded in the you know flows around us cosmic particles etc like that makes sense um it's quite
an amazing perception to have like to have that happen during meditation i i can't say that i i can't
say that you run into a lot of like the the trinity um symbolism in remote viewing session data that i've
seen uh maybe not exactly like that but it definitely sounds very benantic um
i i have had very different experiences i haven't had that that experience so i can but i have i have
had experiences in dreams that the dream has been i had one recently where the dream was significantly
more real than waking life and and so when people talk about uh viewing base level reality or when they
talk about like events in the astral plane are more real than life or
i i definitely i understand now um but i can't say i've ever had an experience like that's an amazing experience
um yeah i wish i wish that i that i had i don't know if those would be the individuals i would categorize as the archons but perhaps
um i definitely don't know everything there is to know about them um but it's it's along those lines
right like it is along those lines that there are um there are beings on a different level of reality
than us that that govern this reality for sure so maybe um if something comes up in the rv data i'll
pass it on to you but it's it's on my i will tell you that like the the first few um spaces we did
were around the concept of moksha so i can see where the relationship is right because uh moksha itself
is a vedantic concept and i some of the spaces i run on astrology recently have been done on um the
astrology of moksha in this particular period of time but i don't think i'm as wired in um as you are with
with meditation to have that experience firsthand myself so any more information you give us is great
information um yeah oh i think it's more calm i think this stuff is more common than we um think
because interestingly enough or maybe it's a maybe this is like a kind of a male thing kind of thing
but like another dude a really really good friend of mine um you know uh like a month and a half
later um i was we were talking about something like more just kind of openly talking about things
like this and he uh um i told him i was like yeah man i had this weird thing there was this embodiment
thing that happened when he looked at me he's like dude i had an embodiment happen he was like i chalked
it up to my indian roots because it was like well i didn't even tell him that i told him about the
three uh vedic beings that i ran into because that's the only way i had to describe it because it was the
like you know i had seen them before at a picture in a vedic statue um and like and then so he started
telling me and his dad is indian right so he was like i just chalked this up to like my indian roots
my indian heritage and and that was it but he um he embodied like a building he said i was like a
building and he like puts his hands down and makes like the building shape and um i don't know if it was
some temple or or what but he was like he totally had the embodiment thing happen but he's also been
digging deep too and also like he meditates a lot like he does this he's this is like a self-care
thing self-improvement bettering his self kind of thing but mine like wasn't so much that it wasn't
like the end results of a lot of work so like i'm not like some kind of master man i just stumbled
into that thing because i um i just had the intent i was like man i really want to learn about what's
going on here um uh with with this uh death and dying that i'm looking at and i sat down that was
instantly relaxed like i had some intention to kind of meditate a little bit and sit and think with my
thoughts but i'm telling you man i laid down on the couch and within 30 seconds i was riding through
a black hole dude um so like it's not like i didn't really do shit i love this and you describe
something that's described in the sutras you know and vipassana and nothingness meditations you very
specifically when you first described this had this kind of like selflessness non-physicality
this reduction of kind of uh being concerned with your consciousness and being more of a receiver than
a you know a transmitter and um that is a big kind of a reoccurring theme theme you see in a lot of this
stuff you know modalities satiate the conscious mind and the subconscious mind you know is able to make
make these connections out of body experiences um your death experiences uh you know these different
things and we're kind of imperfect receivers you know morgan brought up a great point about interpreting
the data um and knowing over time you know how the subconscious speaks and it speaks this different
language and so experiences like that in my frame of thinking can have multiple things going on at once
because you're in a certain state you know people oftentimes after trauma because they're kind of
disassociated in the conscious realm and seeking deep deeper bigger meaning and kind of feel
disassociated from the things they they're they consciously prioritized you make these incredible
kind of in my world view resonant connections and you can get data and it could be hard to understand
your subconscious can be trying to communicate things that your conscious mind doesn't quite have the
language for you know it's like you're uh a piece of the symphony but you're not the whole symphony so
you're understanding of how to play all the other instruments and their meanings and their backgrounds
unclear but you have like a relation you know so uh i've had people describe very very similar
experiences and what's uh fascinating to me is the reoccurring themes the reoccurring themes of these
kind of iconic um beings or characters that resonate with them deeply on some level specific types of
information you see again and again um and uh you know i like to keep an open and self-skeptical mind that
it's not all from the exterior it's not all these beings manipulating me it could be a combination of
a lot of different things going on and uh but i think these experiences are super important uh shaman
and prophets and holy men and witch doctors and spiritualists have been you know advancing us and
keeping us alive even as much as i hate to admit the reality sociopaths i've always wondered how could
someone be a serial killer how why are there sociopaths all these different things then i realized the
super creature of humans uh need them and i think like jt was talking about before this universe seems
suspiciously built for life and if i built the universe for life i would give life some little
tiny advantages like being able to connect and get you know bin reality maybe a little bit get you know
information that could help it persist maybe more um but i love hearing those things it's kind of like
dream interpretation right morgan when you get this information there can be multiple different
kind of possibilities that are logical to assume although your protocols may strongly suggest certain
avenues how do you feel about interpretation like that brother
um yes um so you know in in rv when we talk about data analysis as often as not it actually it's as much
interpretation as it is traditional um analysis so to speak um and you know well i suppose probably the
most obvious example would be um from time to time and probably more so um when you're newer um
but not exclusive to um sometimes your results will come through by way of analogy and you know at that
point it's well once again back to the kind of key words that we keep coming back to tonight context
um so you know it's uh effectively how do you interpret your results in the context of the intended target
um you know just a real quick example of that was um
well probably when i was at about two or three years of
you know immersive experience um in in this field i ran once again you know a health
uh a health trajectory for someone and
what my session described was a very uh physical very mechanical uh kind of process where i had um
so i had i described like this kind of little capsule thing full of some dusty powder
that i couldn't figure out whether it was like alive or half alive or it used to be alive like
it was just the strangest perception by it and i didn't know how to
how to explain it other than it was kind of alive kind of not when it's this dusty powder in a capsule
and then i described well this capsule is like inserted into this tube and then i i described
it's like a horizontal and then a vertical pipe and the pipe goes down and it winds up in this big
tank of acid where it dissolves and then it's distributed out from there
um in the context of the intended target um i didn't even understand this at first it was the the project
manager had to point out to me you know it was quite obvious what do you actually just take a step back
here you're describing um he figured out it was a probiotic basically uh you know being uh you know put in the
mouth uh going down and into the stomach you know where it dissolves and is dispersed um
so you know strictly speaking the data was mostly incorrect however in the context and kind of taking a step
back and look at what is it actually trying to say here oh it's actually quite obvious that not only is
it is it is it actually on target but it's actually quite specific um now like it like i say that you
know you're with more experience you're less prone to these sorts of things but again from an operational
perspective where i i'm interested in results i need
you know actionable information i don't really care um you know how literal
uh the viewer is uh what i care about is do we get
action correct actionable information in a way that we are able to interpret and i think that's actually
part of the kind of the beauty and the elegance of remote viewing and you know me just being me
i'll say technical remote viewing um but as as a system it um it's you kind of have this
um this working agreement between you as an individual and your higher mind your unconscious mind
that part of you which is able to interact with the the more fundamental informational layer
of reality and and retrieve uh the answers to these kind of questions and you know again ed ed um i've
quoted ed a number of times tonight and i will continue to do so going forward one one
one of the things that he would often say is that your higher mind again you know that part of
you which is in direct contact with everything else is the master problem solver you know so when you
have that working combination of a skilled and trained viewer working a well thought out and designed
um targeting strategy um you can you can do some really impressive things um pretty quickly you know um
just to reiterate reiterate that uh your unconscious mind your higher mind
is the master problem solver is the master problem solver and it is in fact your best friend you know it's
it's there to help you it's you know it is you right it it's a part of you but again you're unconscious
by nature you are not under normal circumstances um in direct contact with your unconscious and that's
that's what remote viewing ultimately um serves serves to do it serves as a serves as a framework
within which um you can forge that communications channel between
your conscious awareness and your unconscious your higher mind
someone else can speak now
i love it the more you know your subconscious in the different language it speaks the more you can
interpret the data more accurately and kind of have more control uh over your life it's the grand
puppeteer in our conscious mind is the puppet uh you know and it speaks like you're saying in solution
and synesthesia in history in it speaks in trauma and prejudices and it's non-temporal you know like in your
dreams or obe's and other types of experiences time doesn't matter you could be in a tricycle and then
in a car a distant place and it's non-temporal and so is these um uh abilities and we know different ways
to communicate you know repetition helps you communicate or impart thing belief um you know
satiating the sensor um there's even things like crv teach uh ideograms these kind of symbols that even
if someone from a different country speaks a different language sees they'll be like oh i the first thing
that comes to mind is a mountain or the first thing that comes to mind is something uh you know energetic
or water um there's these kind of like uh it's an alphabet of the subconscious also you know um but
i agree it's so like weird to have this team and this duality uh within ourselves you know this super
being and we think you know we're the conscious mind is totally in control but how much of our experiences
are kind of curated or built or you know um pre-programmed uh you know it challenges my uh
sense of free will which i i don't really think i have too much of but i love the thoughts brother
uh i'm very much uh on the same page with you on um with all of that stuff yeah yep
it's uh yeah it's just you know what it's uh it's an incredible it's an incredible thing um
to the point where you know not so much anymore but you know i
every once in a while i i kind of i sit back and i think you know
really is it like is this real like if i sit down to run a session i'm like
am i really going to just sit here and go through this semi-autonomic process
and somehow come out of this with answers to some question that i don't currently even know what
that is you know yeah but then you know you just kind of you just do it and once again oh
i guess the answer to all that is yes that's exactly what i'm gonna do so
yeah um yeah
there's this wild thrillingness about this stuff too when you experience it you know when you kind of
censor your conscious mind or you know some groups say left brain or whatever and then you experience
the reality of these connections you know some people may experience it through precognizant dreams
some may experience it from other you know types of you know motivations or instigations
but it's so um i don't know it's just perpetually exhilarating it brings out this kind of like
childlike exuberance and you oftentimes see people experience this stuff for the first time and they're
like whoa they're like they're even taking a little bit off balance because their reality now has been
expanded and uh after you find out the reality of it and even after you practice it and get a little
better you're like i want to do something with it what's actionable and i've seen very and i've
experienced personally a wide range of stuff and people others speak better of incidents you know
uh than i do but sometimes just circumstantially you need to enunciate you know specific uses and how
the repercussions and there are incredible viewers who are medical intuitives and just deal with that
you know k randall may is you know has been used and tested uh by you know the directorate of science
and technology from the cia kit green there's even a famous recording out uh with he he talks about
her nailing 10 patients incredibly specifically with very specific stuff and even uh utilizing her on
unverifiable targets like you know things that are outside of even perhaps near future uh you know
resolution of the accuracy um and uh the usability of this stuff is a range it's so freaking cool
uh it can address those weird mysteries historical mysteries medical stuff improve people's lives um
it's it's it goes to that human potential thing it blows my mind some of the research in cases
of what's possible just blow my mind completely um uh it's it's it's disconcerting and reassuring at the same time
uh yeah yeah it is actually it's um
well because just like any technology um the technology itself is neutral and it has great
potential for good and great potential for um it's pretty bad stuff honestly you know we kind of had
um i had this conversation a couple weeks ago uh with angel will uh dan and theodore
and some of the other guys i guess um
with regard to uh rv geofix which is location techniques um
that's not something that's that's really out there like not not very many people
are trained in that and uh at this point in time it kind of raised the question you know what
what are we gonna do with that and there are potential ethical considerations to putting
something like that out there um now again you could make the argument that
there were similar ethical considerations with putting rv out there in the first place but uh
um on the plus side well i'm racking my brain i can't think of any situation that i i don't think i've ever
heard of rv actually being used for you know crime or you know anything really negative or or evil or
anything like that uh buddy what about you you're you know i'd love to believe what i kind of preach to
a degree like you know the sutras do that on the path of virtue these abilities kind of appear
um but it's not necessarily just about virtue there's darker modalities and people like uh ted owens uh
jeffrey mishlove uh who's done so much work and interviewed the top researchers and experimenters
and professors on this stuff he witnessed over 150 incidents with ted owens and it wasn't just predictive
kind of information he was a gambler and a drinker and he was vindictive there's stories about malicious
things that were statistically so unlikely i think over 150 incidents that dr jeffrey mishlove um uh
personally witnessed and you know catalogued um and he was kind of rejected from the stargate uh inclusion
because he was so kind of uh unhinged but there are ethical concerns um you know people have spoken
about remote influence um and how it's you know very unethical and looking into people's private you
know lives without permission there's also i know you feel this morgan you can't talk about cases unless
the client or person involved publicly you know says it's okay to it's a sacred space to be involved
in but there have been negative uh practitioners even if you just consider like a more you know remote
viewing kind of context um and in a way the sri program looking at russian and other countries weapons
and spying and different stuff uh you know might be considered by some you know a negative thing you
know pat price was it's kind of deep widely believed he was killed for doing some things that might have
been unethical um so it's a great question touchy touchy stuff my friend no doubt no doubt um
yeah and you know ultimately uh
i suppose you know there there maybe is no uh there's no real uh good answer to that isn't there
the ethical issues um yeah or i mean
yeah well in order to progress to the next level we've talked about this there has to be a certification
related to ethics um that doesn't mean that uh everyone who because anyone can learn remote
viewing right um to some degree and then with a teacher can you know learn to a greater degree
even though there are natural variables in their ability so no one can stop somebody from being a remote
viewer uh because they're unethical um however what you can do is certify uh people having you know the um
um having been educated on ethics um certifying that they're going to behave ethically uh and then
removing their certification if they stop behaving ethically and you let the consumer decide at that
point right where you let consumers uh particularly when you're talking about um businesses industries and
government um becoming larger consumers or on an individual level right like someone um
often that we talk about crv uh measuring on spreadsheets people's capabilities in different
types of remote viewing scenarios um but if a remote viewer was to have a
uh removing credits for right to conjure like the the specter of the social credit but no a reputation
um as of now ethics are not part of their reputation but once it becomes part of their reputation like
a measurable quantifiable um ethical component then that will move people's choices um and what happens
then um when people know they're dealing with someone ethical they're willing to pay more
and they avoid people who are unethical to a large degree the people who are unethical begin to behave
more ethically in order to compete um for the business um so that's it happens in every industry
at some point it hasn't happened yet uh in the remote viewing industry but it will and that will not fix
right because there are unethical people everywhere but it will give people some concept of what ethical
behavior is right because you hear people uh come out in um sometimes in like session debriefs online
you'll have people say like uh we're ethical remote viewers so x y and z right but that individual
most likely couldn't identify what is ethical and what isn't ethical if you gave them a hundred dollars to
do it um they're just using that as a rhetorical tool to say we're remote viewers at the remote
view so we're going to do this whatever it is that they determined they were going to do in advance
there are actual ethics to um most every uh profession and you know with remote viewing would probably be
the best place to start would be medical ethics which are based on four basic components uh which would
most likely be the same four components you would use um cobbling together a uh certification for
mobile which is you know uh beneficence uh harmlessness um oh uh justice i don't know if i'd include
justice but you have to in order to appeal to certain to a certain uh type of customer and um
oh uh it's the one um but basically self-empowerment but it's uh um like agency but there's another term for
in in medical ethics right and once you establish those four principles then determining the ethics
of each situation comes down to reasoning through how those principles are weighted in that discussion
it's actually pretty simple um but it's definitely something that's beyond your um remote viewing
association at this time no offense um that's my opinion it's not morgan's opinion or buddy's opinion
but my opinion is definitely that there's no there's no one at the um international remote viewing
association uh who's competent to certify people as behaving ethically in remote viewing that will change
so within five years and um you know that's where when we talk about not necessarily in the context of this space but when we talk about like this
massive wave of karma that's everyone is going through right now um and this window of opportunity
all right some we talk some some to some extent about this window of opportunity the shed karma
during the next six to nine months but what's also occurring is this is this sort of creeping
um wave of karmic accountability now that doesn't always mean it's nice right like when you say hey
this is karmic accountability it doesn't mean you're saying like something enjoyable or fun
um or something that people will agree with right but i can give you an example like ai right we started
talking about ai so ai is going to bring karmic accountability to people in a lot of professions
who um have not been behaving uh ethically or morally for a long time um because they were necessary
and their skill set was complicated enough you had to have a certain level of intelligence and education
and a certain level of um so social connections right you had to have like a number of things
that were very difficult to come by in order to be successful in that um that business now what ai is
doing it's going to replace a lot of those businesses and interestingly um you know not to be a class warrior but
right a lot of those individuals have spent the last 20 years sort of salivating at the idea that robots
will eventually replace the working class the the fascinating thing about that is is that the working
class is going to be the last class to be replaced right um and so that there's another example of karmic
accountability right where uh those individuals who had ill will towards others um are the first people
who are likely to lose their jobs in this scenario so you know the energy shock
which is building we hear about it happening if you follow the news other countries are having like
starting to really have lockdown like restrictions the us is not we're producing more oil that doesn't
mean we're not going to have things going forward now this is not the topic of this space we've talked
about this over the last year of anyone who's followed our spaces last year or this year understands
what's coming with the energy shock and when it will when it will play out and how it's it's playing
out now um but that is also right like it's an unfortunate thing but that doesn't mean that there
isn't an aspect of karmic reckoning to it imposing ethics so bring this full circle imposing ethics um
on well you don't necessarily imposing because you can't right but imposing a requirement for ethical
behavior in the marketplace on a profession that hasn't had ethical behavior in the marketplace is a form
of karmic reckoning because the individuals who've been uh behaving freely in an unethical way
won't be part of that train going forward right so they might be like well these people are like
very popular they have a lot of um supporters but eventually they won't right as time goes on
because there are clearly some very popular public figures in the remote community
who would not should not and could not ever be certified as ethical i mean you can't just you
know you say like well at some point you draw a line and say what happened in the past is in the past but
these individuals have been so far out of line from an ethical standpoint that you could never certify
them so from day one you'd be dealing with the the time it took for people to accept the principles of
ethical remote viewing would be the event horizon on their careers as remote viewers right that's that's karma
so and again this is all happened in about five years uh
it's connected to and i don't mean you know like i said i i grew up listening at dames i love ed dames
i know his thing was he teaches remote viewing not ethics i i get that i'm not disrespecting him
um over the next five years we're going to lose more of the original remote viewers
and that will be the window of of opportunity for things to shift so um yeah that definitely will
happen i mean i'm not a remote viewer so i can't tell you i've seen it in in um my psychic ability
but i can definitely tell you it's it's true based on the simulation model that i use which is
the western astrological uh system and i've been forthright with people about this from the very
beginning so um but that's only for the benefit of everyone right because this is what we're talking
about we're talking about improving remote viewing as a tool for humanity and that's improving ourselves
and improving astrology and improving all the silver mind mastery and every modality that we can
in order to create you know a better world for everyone involved while we can right for as long as it lasts
um and then start with the next one
just in some ways it kind of mirrors martial arts you know the instructors in almost all martial arts forms
impart a real um sense of responsibility and duty and ethics uh and into the use of it and um i know ed
um you know may have had a range of different quotes but he had concerns about different areas of um ethics
you know uh i remember hearing something about him talking about remote influence and you know the ethics
behind that and um i guess a lot of it may come from the you know instructors as well you know who inspires
them um but uh it's there's always people who want to utilize something some angle for their own profit
will keep their motives secret will you know um misuse people uh gifts whether they're engineers or scientists
you know so it's it's we're in a dicey place well um so with that right uh remote influencing violates the
ethical principle of autonomy so anything that you do that influences or removes another's autonomy
that's the word i was looking for non-agency right is unethical um so definitely you don't want to ever
have remote influence um go on you can't stop it from happening but you can disincentivize it from
happening and from the techniques for being transmitted um ted stevens who you brought up earlier is the
prime example of why this is an important thing now very few people are likely to ever be born with the
abilities that ted stevens is alleged to have had in his life ted stevens was a mass murderer right as part of
his story if you accept his story being true he caused at least one intentionally caused at least one plane
crash with his uh pk abilities that's uh jason georgiani's favorite example i'm not a jason georgiani fan but
that's his favorite example of uh someone with um uh heightened or extreme uh psychic abilities and psychic
potential which is really his thing um he looks at the a more negative side of the human potential as i think
as being ideal than you or i would right but like stopping people like ted stevens would be a great
place to start like making sure that doesn't ever happen again if there isn't somebody who
can use psychic ability to take down an airplane full of people all right so there you go and um
the only reason ted stevens was you know lived when he died early right but the only reason he lived as
long as he did was because people didn't believe in psychic abilities because if you know people had actually
aside from researchers believed that he was taking down airplanes with his mind you know that he would
have uh he would have been removed uh far earlier according to mishlove right that's what happened
according to mishlove he was removed by the government they they sent a team to take him out and
i mean that's i i you know i don't often support that type of behavior but if someone is using
telekinesis to take down airplanes full of people then yeah you you you got to do what you got to do
um i'm not suggesting that uh uh squads of uh thugs be sent after remote viewers i'm just saying that
an ethical certification should be um should be required
well i mean don't rule it out entirely morgan that's the thing right like we we hope not but
you know the future is a is a crazy place yeah i know let me see the fact that you say that is like
highly disturbing to me
but that's okay the ted owens stuff is even worse he would he was a gambler so he would uh
say before ted stevens thank you buddy thank you um no problem my brother um he would make players
injured and pre-predict that they'd be injured and work on you know his modalities for achieving that
so players would get injured that he pre-predicted and pre-documented and others saw witness before the
sports events um and the implications and there's uh open documents about this that have been
declassified from the cia very proficient remote viewers should be tracked and ones who can display
uh psychokinetic abilities should be tracked for life uh if you believe like i do uh the scientists who
very scrutinously uh studied uh john hutcheson's ability to manipulate physical matter and things like
metals uh jellify them shatter them create a wide range of wild effects that you know like dr hathaway
studied and many others uh studied up close and personal you could imagine someone uh i think it's
called like the angel bolt or something in a helicopter uh some high priority target you know
melting that stuff and we know the russians have psychics you know it's it's just weird you know some of that
stuff um the kind of thing that makes uh life and this planet a little less chaotic is that uh everyone
doesn't have super high psychokinetic abilities because it might be a shitty place you know imagine
kids with super high uh psychokinetic abilities and you know the different frustrations they get into
but uh i guess we all have abilities that can harm or help to a great degree of different types some are
more seemingly rare and extraordinary than others but people are weapons manufacturers uh people you know
it's as easy as i can get depressed or scared about the future so much of this topic um kind of gives me
hope in uh you know our potential yeah i mean i i um don't i'm not by nature a paranoid person like you
can believe or know what the government is capable of doing i mean of course none of us really know what
the government is capable of doing but you know a lot of us have heard rumors or you know found snippets
of information about some of the things that the government is capable of doing people who work
for government capable of doing through technology psychic abilities etc right um what makes a person
paranoid is if they think it's happening to them right if you're somebody who isn't a particularly
important person but you believe that you're the subject of you know a massive uh tailored individual
state surveillance effort you you probably paranoid maybe it's true but more than likely you're paranoid
right it's not paranoid to say that the government monitors remote viewers it isn't it's it's more than
likely um happening not just to people who have high psychokinetic ability but probably every competent
remote viewer um it you get a lot from it's not just out of suspicion it's also um you get a lot of free
remote viewing right uh because people are going to pick up on things like disasters and terrorist events
uh things like that i go on the assumption that whenever i'm talking to a skilled remote viewer
it's not just two of us in the conversation that doesn't mean i think there's someone sitting at a
desk someplace who's whose job it is to keep track of what i'm because i'm not important but
if you're having that conversation about remote viewing stuff right that's whether it's an ai or an
individual or something that's being monitored by someone i'm certain of that so it's just part of
the it's just part of um i'm not going to say the hobby i guess the hobby for some people right it's
just part of the uh the the the profession i guess and relating to people who are part of that profession
so i i i i think that that's you know whether it's the cia or whomever who's doing it um why wouldn't
they right i would if i was uh if i was in charge of an intelligence agency i would monitor what remote
you were said i would i would read their emails
uh yeah no that's a fact and ed ed said almost word for word what you said that yeah it's it's not
a matter of being you know like what do they call it like a targeted individual or anything like that no
no not at all it's just simply that yes the the intelligence services uh and obviously not just
american but um various intelligence services all around the world um
and have you know certain divisions who understand that remote viewing is a valid uh data collection
tool and therefore yeah they simply keep apprised of what competent remote viewers are are putting out
there um you know semi-actively it's probably it's not you know like a one-to-one thing but it's probably
you know like every it's we it's it's there's no question everything that we do is mass surveilled
right like um everyone's email is is you know copied and filtered um but i you know certain things
are filtered and given you know flagged or given priority for probably like human review type thing and and
that's just it's simply a matter of pragmatism practicality right because you you nailed it they
are getting um they're getting uh good intelligence and it doesn't cost them a thing so yeah hell of a deal
you know and i i it's funny because i every once in a while i think of that and it kind of pisses me off
because like there's there's nothing i can do to stop that um so i mean for god's sakes can you at least
you know
hook the guy up right like jesus anyways whatever yeah like a hundred thousand dollars right like just
at some point in your life you get a a deposit in your account for a hundred thousand dollars no one says
anything about it like this it's not a big deal you just you've been you've been compensated right you
put a down payment on a house or something great well they print money they literally print money yeah
you know they're not losing anything by doing that but uh no another thing i think you have to
probably recognize is that you've been remote viewed on numerous occasions
right because they're probably going to use different layers of technological surveillance i don't
necessarily think it would be a person it'd probably be an ai right because if we were talking earlier
about how the the ai was there from the 80s or the 90s depending on who you ask it was there um
it probably preceded the spread of technology right so like personal computing and in personal devices
the ai probably preceded that and it's probably been uh you know to some degree embedded or capable of
accessing through the back door all of these technologies so i don't even know if there's a
person who gets any of this intelligence unless it's been vetted by some sort of filter um
but especially now like i guess we're talking about remote viewers right but we have to face the reality
that probably there's some sort of ai reading everyone's mail right i mean i you're listening to everyone's
conversations they were doing that in um in the 80s and 90s as well with echelon where they're you know
they weren't listening to every phone call they probably do now there but they were listening to
anyone that set off 300 buzzwords so if you said one of 300 um words of concern they would begin
recording your phone call someplace and they have you know they had buildings where they ran it out of
and satellites and so they've been doing that for a long long time they've got to now
have everything we say on file but that doesn't mean it ever gets to a person um it might if you
if you're a terrorist i mean this look after 9 11 i don't know i know i say this all the time
but after 9 11 someone tried to blow up the coffee square plaza uh mall i'm sorry coffee square mall in
a box truck full of um explosives i made the local news uh one day and then disappeared and that got me
curious so i started sort of following the conversation and i can't give you exact details because i i it was
a long time ago but i i was aware of a few more like that um in other localities where things would happen
it would make the local news for one day then it would disappear and you wouldn't be able to find
anything about it online and you wouldn't be able to um uh yeah you just wouldn't be able to find any
information about it right and it wouldn't be reported more than one day in that era there have
been suggestions that the fbi and the federal government foiled up to 10 000 potential terrorist
attacks after 9 11. i don't know if that's true i'm not saying it's true um but there were a lot
and they they were able to to stop them all um to this day right like um
things happen like there are crazy not lone gunmen and but we haven't had a wmd attack
or a major terrorist attack in in the u.s like major major a building or something right like we haven't had
that in in in years um and one possible explanation for that is this surveillance where um they do have
the information on file and you know no one pays attention to us because we're not we're not terrorists
but the terrorists they're able to catch and one thing that they say with these foreign countries
that we go into one of the ways that we we try to avert uh war is that we send uh text messages to
everyone like we apparently sent a text message to everyone in iran right prior to the war and
apparently that's happened before in syria and other countries like if you're on this planet and you have
a cell phone or a pager or something the american government knows your number and can send you a
text message at any time right that's the advantage we have we have such signals dominance um
that no one in the world can really do anything without us knowing it that we're aware of right
now now one thing buddy did talk about was the the russian psychics that you guys would know more
about that than i do but i was there in the 80s and 90s i was a kid in the 80s obviously and in most of
the 90s uh but i did have that interest i followed it pretty closely what would show up in the news
and um i remember when the wall fell and they started releasing books on the the uh the psychics in um
in russia actually it started before the wall right and that was one of the impetuses for project stargate
but if what was reported was true they were always more advancing people in the united states
particularly in the weaponization of telekinesis so um more than likely it's still the case if they had
that advanced right if they were years ahead uh so yeah i mean people should count that the the russians
at least if not other foreign powers may have more advanced uh psychic training programs and
you could make this logical leap right like we don't know if this is true but in what context does it make
sense to end uh a private program a black program and release the remote viewers from that program and
send them out into the world to become remote viewing instructors well one context where that makes sense
from a national security standpoint is what morgan was talking about which is the free remote viewing
from just surveilling them another context where that makes sense is if you are losing right
if your um classified program is falling so far behind uh another nation or one or more nations then what
america does well is capitalism right well private industry um releasing that those abilities into private
industry and then being able to come in and swoop up the most um promising people uh would be one way to
address that um being behind the eight ball uh compared to these other countries so again it's just
speculation that last part but it would make sense and i think we all we've all heard that russia is
was ahead of us at least for a long time so oh oh you know yeah that's a really interesting line of
thought and you know i gotta be honest i'm in in the more current context i i lean more towards china than
russia because you know it's long been rumored that the chinese um you know they introduce
these concepts um i don't know if it's universal but in some cases you know to to classes of children you
know in whatever their equivalent of you know like kindergarten or first grade is um
and there have been there's been lots of as far as i know largely unsubstantiated rumors about some
pretty wild stuff like not just remote viewing but way more into the realm of telekinesis okay so
this is where i'm going to get us in trouble now so get ready if this drops out right i'm sure people
talk about this in spaces all the time or have but who knows uh do you have the gate program in canada
um
program yeah totally um okay so and it's kind of like in in the u.s i think it's uh
like it's different even uh whether it's regional or like by the state but i know some places called
it like tag uh some places called a gate um at least so uh up here and in the time period like so i was in
elementary school in the 90s and at that time it was called trail t-r-a-i-l and uh that said for was
it to realize advanced and independent learning and i was in the the trail program from uh i think you
did your first testing in like third grade and then the following rounds in fourth grade so
between grades four to eight was was when that program ran and so my first-hand experience with
it like i say in in my area and at that time i don't remember really any psychic stuff going on
um it really was more like um problem solving abstract thinking um those sorts of things um
now that said um both of my parents were in the equivalent
um in in their time uh in elementary school it was i can't even remember off the top of my head what
it was called but it was called something different back then and my mom said they definitely did uh esp
testing uh basic esp testing um yeah yeah yeah so but nothing so intense as you know some of the wilder
stories you you kind of hear about on here um i think people play them up uh but then again i wasn't
selected for whatever um at first when people started talking about it there were a lot of us it didn't
necessarily resonate with but then they started bringing up odd specifics like the fluoride
right so they call it the pink juice um it made sense i guess at the time
but does it really make sense now as an adult thinking about them giving you
fluoride drink um all the time in school
it's it it it it's not something that happens now and it it doesn't really make sense um
that that was that was something that happened the microscope does anyone else you know does anyone
does anyone else remember the microscope thing the um so it was like a it's like a computer almost like
a copier shape and it had the the the eye it's like a um it's like a shape of uh
a doorstop or something like it's you know uh but you were looking at a microscope so it was like uh
it you put both your eyes against it and then you were looking down the tube into the machine and
they would flick the images in front of you no one um i think i i think i know what yeah yeah right so
like you could say that was like measuring
spatial ability or whatever but whatever became of it like you see what i'm saying like if you round up
students across the country and bring this machine in to the class and you make them look into the machine
and you spend hours flicking these images in front of them to test their spatial abilities
what what what do you do with that information like do you know anyone who was like who later
later on in life got anything out of having their spatial abilities measured it just doesn't make
any sense like it made sense at the time because we were kids but as an adult it doesn't necessarily
make any sense and yet there were there were but they're not called esp it begins with a z
the name for the cards right but the plus the minus the two squiggly lines beener yeah yeah right so
what was that about i mean okay we try to maintain a facade of normalcy but now
we've got kids around the country being given esp tests and we don't think about it now right and
then someone starts talking about it like yeah well yeah shit they did do that that's weird
it doesn't make any sense right and we were after school where the hell are our parents
right like where the hell are our parents when my parents where the hell are my parents
when i was spending an hour and a half taking these these tests and with my eyes in that that machine
i guess i described it very poorly i'm sure you'd all recognize it but it was like uh it was a very
odd thing um so then they started talking about mall world i mean i i don't have the intense like there
are people around the country who draw this same picture of like there's the there's the secret
room there's the hallway that goes to the secret room there's the hotel there's the hospital like
they have this elaborate diagram and they all claim to memorize it to be able to draw it and
they all have stories about being in different areas i can't uh i can't jive with that but i've
had those mall dreams my entire life you're in an empty mall right and look what you're doing like
you're supposed to be there to do something like you were sent to some sort of like test or mission
and you're in empty mall i had one the other day um sometimes there are other people there uh
maybe it's just a normal part of human development to have them all world dreams i don't know
but it seems that people who are in the gate program um are the only ones who report it
but maybe everyone else just takes it for granted i don't know but like the pink the the excuse my
language i know i curse what people take seriously but like what the hell putting the pink pills in
the water and then having you drink it and telling you it's fluoride for your teeth
if you went to the dentist but why would we get fluoride rinse every day after school
i don't know there's something strange about us like i don't think it's a hundred percent
what they're saying but it's definitely weird like it you know it doesn't really
it doesn't really make as much sense as an adult as it did as a child
that's all it wouldn't surprise me if they had it in every country i just don't know like
i don't know i i feel like um well we know there's some connection to psychic phenomena because
they were giving us esp tests and it was definitely like experimental right i'm not saying it was like
something like um that only elite people went through because a lot of people went through it
but they were definitely subjecting us to like mass experimentation
it wasn't it didn't guide our career paths in any way it didn't contribute to our education in any way
i don't know man strange
it is strange and i've often wondered you know ultimately really the exact question that you're asking
which is uh what really was the point of all that you know um did it do me any good
uh it's i suppose it's kind of almost impossible to say um i will be quite forthright in saying you
know i i enjoyed it most because it got me at a regular class and you know it was it was a it was a lot
closer to really just screwing around and having fun than sitting in a regular classroom ever ever could be
so you know um that was probably the most i ever really got out of it um
yeah i i don't know but ultimately of course it served some or at least it was intended to serve some
higher purpose for someone and i i have no real inkling to uh get to what end
i really i don't know another thing that we have to put on the master list of things that we
can't coerce anyone into remote viewing that we don't have the money well i was talking to
uh uh at one point i was like do you know what we could do with a million dollars
and i was explaining to him i'm like and this is this is important like this is related to the
remote viewing okay like people will wonder well if if it's successful right if if remote view do what
you say it can do then why isn't it more widely adopted why aren't people using it and we have the same
problem in astrology all right because this is the best that i understand it right as a
um you know people we're we're social um we've always lived in large groups at least homo sapiens
has always lived in large groups like 150 you know fairly large compared to other animals right and
just like other apes that live in groups um or other animals that live in groups um height and centrality
are a form of status because being on the periphery i know this sounds like a huge digression
but it will make sense in just a minute height and status or height and centrality are a form of
status right so that even to this day um people of high status live like in the center of areas or
in the center of specific communities for them and they live in elevated um and like for instance uh
skyscraper buildings right well the reason is because in nature that's where the human beings were safest so the
the central people in the group were were in the center in an elevated area safer from predators and peripheral
threats floods spiders whatever right okay so people in a in in a say the lower classes right like
a good percentage mute everyone oh i didn't need everyone okay so like a good um
it's saying someone's requesting oh clutch okay uh yeah so uh uh uh when you're in this
when you're involved in the paranormal when you're involved in psychic stuff
astrology etc you are much more likely to work and to be in my opinion maybe that your experience differs
you're much more likely to run into people who are interested in it who are in the working class
the lower class than people who are very affluent or very educated and i believe the reason for that
is that people who are in the lower so socioeconomic end of the ladder are sensitized to peripheral
threats just like we would have been at the very beginning of of human development where the people who
were not in the central status were the people who lived at the very periphery this happened to me when
i was a kid at summer camp actually everyone couldn't fucking stand me they made me sleep at the very
outside of the circle when we camped on the island it was a like it was a summer camp where for two nights
every two weeks you would go camp on an island in the middle of the lake and you'd just sleep under
the stars and because no one could stand me whatever right i guess i was the same person that i am now
they would make me sleep at the edge it was terrifying right everyone want to sleep in the middle that's
that's what's going on well people who sleep in the middle people who have uh prestige and authority
status and money are sensitized to in-group threats they're sensitized to people trying to take their
status take their money take their the spot where they live they're not sensitized to peripheral threats
and we tend to look at remote viewing um astrology etc as tools that um that that discern peripheral
threats right so when you find like uh remote viewing subscription services you'll often find that the
people are are pretty poor we're paying 60 a month and the explanation for that is both like an interest
interest in the paranormal but it's also a form of insurance right because if something bad happens
in the world it's likely to show up from their perspective in the remote viewing data so they're
paying attention to see right like they don't have power and agency to defend against floods famines war solar
uh uh um um solar outbursts right and and so they they tend to pay a lot of attention to uh people in the prediction
um profession uh that that goes all the way back that's the sensitization to peripheral threats right so
the people with money if you approach them and you say look like we've got this tremendous well-documented
um remote viewing uh team but well they're much more sensitized to you trying to shake them down
and hustle them right there than anything else and what you're likely to offer them like if you're
going to say hey look uh we can give you this information that's going to help you defend against
you know these environmental threats or whatever well their money protects them against that
right like the rich guy like elon musk does not have to worry about a lot of these concerns
right when the poll shift comes elon musk is going to be the one in the safest bunker
right and if elon musk gets sick he doesn't need to consult or remove you or
find out what's wrong with him it would be great if he did but you know he has unlimited access to
the menace here and diagnostic techniques etc so what blows people's mind is you know that this tech
these these this technology is not being applied to solve a lot of problems that it could be and like
the type of money we're talking about here like how many research units could you fit into a million dollars
just imagine just just one million dollars you could you could make a headway in solving maybe 600
or more serious world problems and that's no joke
but that's what i don't have a i don't have a number for you but a lot
yeah a lot right so well okay as a as a matter of of value you know it was often
it is off-sighted that yes remote remote viewing is you know when it's used uh correctly judiciously it is
absolutely like top tier value like bang for your buck in terms of well what do we keep what do we
keep saying general purpose data collection problem solving it really is um
uh yeah i but you know it's the way that you just described it um it's kind of counterintuitive
but i think you're i think you're bang on and i mean you know there's there's probably additional
factors there too but um i think i think to really boil it down i want to i want to repeat something
that you just said to really emphasize the point that yeah a guy like you know perfect
example elon musk probably doesn't use remote viewing because he has unlimited resources practically
speaking so he has virtually unlimited um reach into every conventional sector so it's actually maybe not
surprising that's that someone like him at least as far as i know maybe maybe he does use it and i'm not
aware of that but it would be equally unsurprising if he he didn't right so um a lot of them use uh
astrology right i don't know maybe they have remote viewing teams i don't know right that's
hypothetical when you talk about billionaires but what we know in astrology is right you know i'm sure
you've heard this before jp morgan's quote that millionaires don't use astrology billionaires do right
so the the the way that shakes out is you know if you if you're a millionaire or multimillionaire you're
very well insulated you've got some to gain right but like the people who really have right the most to
gain would be people who don't have those resources or people have so much money right and are assessed
with making more money that's something that can help you like uh the information that can maximize your
profit from 100 million dollars to 300 million dollars that's a big deal right but someone who's in that
comfort zone you know they're a millionaire they're not a billionaire they have to be more concerned
about you hustling them or leading them astray they have to be concerned about groupthink and
thinking along with their peers who are also in the same situation right because they could lose
if they're perceived um as not being part of the group it really is that's the zone the zone where
we'll be looking right like if we were going to go around and try to to raise funds for that like one
million dollars like let's get one million dollars and you know get some research units going and just
chip away at some of these problems if it's it's it's almost unimaginable that we'd be able to do it
in the government i'm sure they've done it right but in the private industry it's almost unimaginable
we'd be able to do that and that's the ultimate irony it's just the ultimate irony of of working in
prediction so people will then come out and say well if it's so great then you know if it's so great
then how come uh how come x y and z isn't using it then the people who are using it hide it right they
might hide remote viewing too one interesting thing that i found um is that even if and this is not a knock on
and this is not you right i'm not talking about you and your your team but even if um someone
isn't hiding the fact that they hired remote viewers some remote viewers require people to
sign non-disclosure agreements to not to reveal that they hired a remote viewer right now that's true
so i mean there you go um some remote viewers don't want people knowing right they have to
they want to protect their reputation so they make people sign people sign uh non-disclosure agreements
so people won't tell others that they hired them it's really a shit show it's really a
shit show and that's why it's so important to talk about this stuff because it's it's it takes 150 years
i i i'm i'm sure you're aware of this it takes 150 years after you come up with a new technique a new
invention of any kind to to get it widely adopted and so we're still in the relatively early phases of
that right and it's just about getting as much of it adopted as possible as as quickly as possible and
fighting through that resistance resistance along the lines of things like you know class and money and
and um and people who think it's superstitious and and people who will sit there and say
it's it's you know claim that uh you can't consistently document um esp or remote viewing
and and and and no scientific research has ever documented and it's not true all scientific research into
it has documented it consistently it just people will just repeat that right they make that claim
it's a false claim but you will just hear it over and over and over again from people who don't know
what they're talking about and you're like okay cite the cite the research that you're talking about
buddy right oh i don't know yeah right of course because it's it's it's confabulation so we have all
these things we kind of kind of struggle against and that's why having this type of specific strategy i know
that i'm i'm rambling more is because i'm getting a part of worn out man i am worn out my context window
is is rapidly closing um you know having this specific strategy focusing on the few improvements
we know will work right like i get the whole multi-modalities thing and there are people who can
focus on all the modalities and that's great but like we have a limited amount of time and energy and a
limited amount of impact so we just have to pick what we're you know not all of us can be journalists
and ambassadors right like i think buddy was saying he's not the best ambassador i think he's the best
ambassador but those of us who can't be um good ambassadors right we have to find like the things
that we can do that have the most impact and i believe the thing we can do have the most impact
is to promote things like you know in my in my field of astrology i want to promote you know the adoption
of the um the realization of the analog simulation model right as a mentality which makes it a more
effective like once you accept that it makes it more effective i want to promote astro rv right
because that is the ultimate fusion which is going to give us the ability to see
or to to predict um with much greater certainty events in the you know in the future really right
and prepare for them in advance and that is absolutely key to developing a global psychic immune system
um so those are things i can do uh encouraging supporting and working with people in technical
remote viewing to um to spread to generalize to train to you know to take the things that uh that ed
developed right and technical remote viewing developed that can can maximize our ability to realize this
greater mission sooner right by getting more people out there performing remote viewing a little bit
more accurately keeping the people who have trouble being on target on target right and creating more
solutions to increase right both both exponentially increase the number of solutions that we're creating
but also every time somebody reaches out and solves another person's problem using one of these modalities
they're bringing another person on board convincing them of the reality right getting them on on on the team
so to speak convincing them it's real and it's useful showing them the utility
so that's the type of stuff that i'm doing um and i think we should be doing and that's why
we hosted this space tonight um to talk about the connections between ai and as a model as a metaphor
and technical remote viewing and the legacy of ed dames and why the world needs ed dames and technical remote
viewing more than ever um but ed can't be with us tonight morgan is right so we need morgan um
i know angel i guess is is the guy i don't know angel personally i don't know anything about angel
really i i have to say that i try to follow everyone but i i must have had a um a lapse uh
to have a remote viewing career that i haven't paid any attention to so that's that's on me um
but just because he's doing that thing over there doesn't mean that you can't step up right and do your
thing and and lead in your own way right because we need more than one leader so oh no very much um
and no you know i'm i'm actively in contact with uh with those guys and um
yeah there's there's gonna be there's gonna be um
there's gonna be lots of uh lots of good things coming out of the trv camp in the future um
you know even including uh you know one of
you know i would say in my entire career i have two students that have worked their way up to what i
consider uh professional grade remote viewers and
both those guys they're you know they're very they're very accomplished in their own right and
you know i just had a a really uh an extended conversation a couple of nights ago uh with one
one of them and he was kind of catching me up on on what he's been working on for the last uh
quite some time and
you know um i'm not he asked me not to say anything um and i said well you know can i say
someone i know is working on some interesting things and he said yeah that's fine so that's
what i'm saying someone i someone i know is working on some really interesting things um
you know i'm always working on things uh we've got astro rv uh there's plenty more to do there
um we've got uh well you know i'm not gonna really say much of anything um but
we're working uh continuously and we're not going anywhere so
yeah that's that i want to uh at some point everyone just so that you know morgan and i
aren't necessarily working on this together although i'm sure we will at some point
um and i'm just more of an agitator than anything else but i think it's uh it's important to try to get
uh um inflation right people have to live and you know road viewers have to charge enough that they
can survive on remote viewing um right as i could say it's it's uh it's an incredible ability and to
get to the level where you can do it for a living like that's a ton of work it costs a ton of money
and only a few people can do it so there's a supply and demand issue there although anyone can benefit
from remote viewing training and anyone can get to the point where they can answer solve a lot of their
own problems and other people's problems with remote viewing training um but to get to that professional
level that's it's unusual uh however i think that in our time right there are a couple of um there are a
couple of uh prompts there are a couple of um things you can hire a remote viewer to do which are really
important right so uh ed is famous for uh the kill shot and for the optimum trajectory sanctuary um
where you can you know where a trained remote viewer technical remote viewer can give you an insight
into what area of the world uh might be the safer place for you personally to be um during the upcoming
period of um of global crisis a period that that is already underway but let me tell you something the
end of the world takes forever all right because i a lot of this there are people like myself who were
talking about it in the 90s so we can never underestimate how slowly the global crisis develops it was
predictable and everyone knew what was going to happen and we knew a lot of the details particularly if you're
involved in astrology or movie or something but for a lot of us we could not imagine it was going to take
30 years to get to the point we're at now um but it did so if i say like hey the threat is imminent
what is imminent i don't know in our lifetime uh for a lot of this stuff yeah is the world in the middle of
the early stages of a immense crisis right now absolutely bigger than covert yes 100 percent
uh fuel crisis global fuel crisis global world war accelerating to a more active level right um
leading to uh the use of weapons of mass destruction but i'll tell you there are no weapons of mass destruction
um more dangerous than than having your oil and gas shut off for a long period of time
um when the lights go out the power goes off and the 6 000 other uh uh products like uh medicines
that are made from petroleum and national gas natural gas feedstocks right like that's if you
shut off right that's the the whole um emp thing where you shut off the power right it's the same thing
if you shut off the the gas and the oil you shut off the power to a large degree and you wind up with
people starving and you wind up with people freezing in the winter like you wind up with millions of
people being in danger so even if it doesn't accelerate to wmds and i'm afraid that it will um
already if the situation continues the way it is uh it's it's a big problem and there have been
there have been like 11 to 15 uh refinery explosions around the world in the last week or two so this is
not just something that's going on the middle east uh some actor or actors is targeting oil refineries
around the world um for this specific reason to bring civilization to its knees which it will do
if it's not um if the situation doesn't change uh just an energy shock like this uh well this is three
times as large so far as the one in the 70s and the one in the 70s created you know 10 10 or more years
of recession basically um we're talking about a big a big big problem these things are happening um
so you know i would like to see at some point and i'm always on the lookout for skilled
um remote viewers who may not be able to bill at the level that morgan and buddy bill and that that's
not saying but morgan and buddy should get 10 times as much money as they get whatever they're getting
but people who can who can return reliable results to potentially help people um you know
by at least giving a little bit of a discounted rate around things like the the sanctuary right around
um solutions for the immediate problems um that are life or death they're gonna be life or death
problems for some people we'll see if that pans out if i ever find anyone but if i do i will certainly
let everyone know of course morgan would always be my first choice but
he has to he has to work with you know people at that level uh go ahead buddy
such like cool and points that i rarely get to explore with people and i don't get to hear
these conversations enough and at first i disagreed with something you said earlier and then you uh as
i heard more i agreed with it about the wealthy um not exposed to it as much but the super wealthy are very
interested in this stuff and always have leaders and you know the elite have always wanted extra
information um many have known and had privileged data and information about the reality of these things
and explored it and wanted to bottle it up and manipulate and utilize these things i mean there's so
many very specific examples of of that you know you could look at uh just you know bigelow alone uh you
know many uh many others and you know throughout history a king wants a merlin um uh you know pharaohs
wanted sages um in every culture and um there are realities and ways that uh viewers and this talent
especially of those of greater reliability those who get trained and exercised and you know um there's a
great value in that and each person kind of struggles with their own ethics oftentimes people great at uh remote
viewing are terrible at business or feel it's you know disingenuous to charge for um you know uh prayer
work or healing stuff because they may not be the only uh factor involved in the accomplishment of the
objective i've felt that way in helping locate a missing person that was spoken about on x so i can speak
about it um a woman's son ran away and we went through this process together immediately very specific data
information and immediate recovery in the exact uh documented location and how could i take credit
for that it would be disingenuous because there's the prayers of a mother there's all these other
factors the fabric of the universe you know to me the almighty uh you know other things so there's areas
where you can and you can't charge there's these ethical considerations and i'm sticking horrible at
business and part of what i think helps my protocol is a humility and a approachability and a understanding
of different people's situations and i do something that's terrible for business i work on a donation basis
and there are people with less of a documented track record that charge huge sums but in a way i don't mind
them doing it that's their protocol that's their way that's what's good for them as long as it's like
what you and morgan were saying using uh this stuff to help and there is a wonderful power to help even
fletch had that moment of resonance um and able to help a troubled person um that's the desire you know
i i work on a donation basis as well i don't judge people who don't but i myself i i find that to be
necessary so that that's just my my personal thing and if someone pins me down then i'll try to pick
something like lower and um and um affordable but if someone doesn't pin me down if like they have
greater means that i might try you know but i don't charge if someone wants to give me market
right right by all means but i want to um i want to make sure that people who who who need help
can get help if there is help right that that's my so i i i i respect that but i don't judge people
who don't do it but i i i do respect that you uh that you do that so i'll just add to you know
a lot of a lot of a lot of people in in the remote viewing field are quite willing to uh operate on a
sliding scale um you know up to and including you know in some cases working for free um
so you know it all starts with um you know with reaching out and uh you know just just going for
it and there may be other there may be other adjacent modalities right there may be things
we might be able to brainstorm and put put our heads together and come up with a way right like
something that we could do to to connect it all right in in such a way that everyone can get what
they need but people but everyone gets what they need both both the providers and the the people
receiving the service and i there may be um there's laurie williams right i don't know if i'm not
super laurie williams but she's got a on a website they map out a couple ways that a person can look for
their own ideal um geographic relocation area right using their own intuition so there might be some
way to do that that also allows like a rising tide lifts all ships right so if if one in a thousand
people is utilizing a psychic modality then that's a scarcity um situation but if one in a hundred or one
in ten is then there's more for the you know people who who are capable of charging more and the people
capable of charging less and and the people looking for the answers get the answers like a scale is a
factor scale is usually at least up into the middle of a a positive factor for everyone making money right
and it's and also seeing to their own survival right like we don't this isn't a martyr complex thing
like we're not only for people to martyr themselves to ensure other people's well-being but not ensuring
their own well-being but you're right like people can can reach out and ask if if if you know if
their mobile viewer accepts a sliding scale or if they know somebody right like hey do you if if
if this is something that you can't you know that that isn't good for you to take do you know
someone who might be like it's always good to ask and i i tell everyone right like i i've never worked
with buddy but i imagine buddy's great right but i have work for morgan and i know morgan's great so
the first thing i tell everyone is you know morgan will be your first choice right but he's not your
only choice if that doesn't work out and that i think that's fair to everyone right um and you can
always reach out to uh to buddy to morgan um you can reach out to me and ask if i have any recommendations
you can you can always reach out to to anyone and say hey do you know anyone who's who's doing this
or who might be able to help me it's good for everyone okay you know i'm just gonna mention
something i have been thinking about and i'm probably gonna end up doing this god knows it's not going
to be in the immediate future but hopefully in the more like the midterm um i'm going to
i'm gonna set up a dedicated training server on discord and i'm going to have a free section
um i don't know exactly what that's going to look like um and there's definitely going to be um
uh what do you call like i guess technically paywalled sections like for paying students for higher level
stuff but um you know a big part of my yeah as corny as it sounds but like my life mission and it's
true it really is you know the proliferation of high quality remote viewing and i fully recognize that
part of that involves you know a good amount of volunteer work which i'm absolutely not opposed to
like um i'm really not uh monetarily driven beyond uh its utility as a you know its necessity
as a utility of fuel um and you know i'm i don't particularly desire
you know a really lavish lifestyle um because i really i i just i don't think that would do me any
good it probably would be a net negative so yeah i'm not really in it for you know the love uh or
pursuit of of money beyond uh you know the the bear necessity is really like food and shelter
so the the the the drive the the sense of urgency that i've been trying to articulate over the last
year uh to you more more than a year right but to everyone uh in spaces more than i i remember doing
one specific space um last year you know telling people like this is a good time to get into goal
setting if you believe in goal setting you know the it's not that uh everyone's life is imminently
in danger i mean people die right like all of our lives um all the time that doesn't you know but
that doesn't mean our lives are more in danger than they usually are um but what is happening right now
is we're seeing an intersection of of events that are are going to limit people's agency
and that that's happening all around us right like we we have grown up we we've we've all lived our
entire lives in a in a time when we have which take for granted that there's mobility take for granted that
this if they if they want to change their circumstances that's possible they might not
be successful but it's a it's a possibility for them to do so right we have uh looming in front of us
and i know a lot of you were in our spaces last year right so we have looming in front of us the
effects of this economic the economic and political effects of this energy shock the escalating global world
war ai and ai interfering with people's plants right and people's um professions and professional goals
and economic mobility and attending to all those things we have several political movements that
probably represent the same background impulse to limit people's mobility by limiting how much they can
travel where they can go um everyone thinks that's limited to one side of the political spectrum and
it's the side they don't vote for so the truth is it's being advanced by people behind both sides of
the political spectrum right the whole idea of cities that limit how many days you can leave the city
how many miles you can move how much you know um how many times you get on an airplane uh there
are a lot of people around the world who are not upset about this energy shock one of the funny things
that people are saying is uh or we're noting is how the the european union isn't reacting the way they
should because they're in a desperate situation an extremely desperate situation not france with diogenes is
because they have nuclear power not that i'm saying that's the ideal solution
right but like countries like germany the uk they are in a desperate situation right now
and there's there's very little way out of that but they're not reacting like they're in a desperate
situation because ideologically and there's someone in the background promoting that ideology
they they're seeking to reduce people's standard of living and that that involves reducing their mobility
right the same thing exists in our country and it exists on both sides of the political spectrum
um and people think that they're that they're that's not going to happen that's not coming down the line
don't recognize it as the war advances right or as ai advances you know we're going to
we're going to be faced with with limited mobility as the result of those
uh i think i think i think we lost jt i imagine it's temporary
time i they've done me five or six times oh it's an accident i've been i accidentally got disconnected
five or six times right in the middle talking about those subjects at least it's not as bad as it was
last year uh yeah so i've been kicked out of the face like eight times just with full signal it's you know
it's something that runs it there's no question i mean there are some topics there's a place in texas
where they store all the um all the decommissioned nuclear weapons it has a name and it's a name that
you can read in newspapers magazines going back 30 years but if you say it on x spaces you get
immediately disconnected and it's happened to me a few times so i'm not going to say it again
right there are definitely there's definitely a form of ai space censorship going on in spaces
i'm not saying it's it's super extreme but it's definitely there like it's it's keyword related
in my opinion in my you know that's just my opinion uh yeah so uh intersection and um
ai and uh what was the other one oh surveillance right like social credit score if you don't think
social credit score is coming you're crazy it does i mean no offense it doesn't matter who you voted for
because it's it's it's on its way it's being by the people behind it and right now when people believe
that they voted for someone an administration that's going to save them from that it's being
uh advanced quicker than it was under the previous administration so that's we're talking six months
away right they're implementing it in mexico right now um the mass surveillance and the uh biometrics
and the social credit score it's it's already here de facto but it's going to be implemented more
structured way um this is the time to make changes right it's the time to like if there's something
you want to buy and buy it or something you want to do do it if there's some place you want to be
be there right if it is you want to consult remote viewers consult remote viewers if you want to
consult astrologers consult astrologers if you want to you know whatever it is that you know
your heart wants that involves mobility this is the time right look international flights like right
now they're canceling 12 000 15 000 20 000 international flights there are people right
now who have flights booked this summer i don't know if they're going to be going anywhere
legitimately because the jet fuel shortage um and they're just not talking about it in the news
if it doesn't happen this summer it's going to happen this autumn but it's going to happen this
summer in a lot of places where they're going to be so low on jet fuel and facing a war where we need
jet fuel and there aren't going to be international flights for a lot of people so you know this is uh
this is the time to do these things and including you know looking for advantages by um by seeking out
providers of things like remote viewing um and looking for solutions to the problems now right that that's
that's all i was going to say i know it's the same thing i say all the time and if life goes on for
people but at least i've but i helped my my conscience right yeah and i love it and i think it's a
responsibility and the elite use uh these different resources to to profit and to have an advantage and
the people should know about it more and utilize it more and a lot of what morgan said resonated with
me as well too about is kind of obligation to give some back for free and being an ambassador uh you
know they have master classes for all sorts of things and shows like jeffrey mishlove where you can hear
experts talk about the research and realities but there's very few uh like practitioner kind of uh master
class kind of things and uh i think it speaks really well of the ethics of the teachers and the purveyors
of this kind of sacred information when they operate on that basis and on the sliding scale and i suck at
business but we could do something together that could make uh you know better businesses you know i've
worked with uh private companies that uh incorporated me into predictive analytics and incorporate um
intuitives and remote viewers and uh into this network and they get this information from
on a topic or target that they're interested in whether it be liabilities or you know future concerns or
you know inventions uh and they bring in experts in the field they bring in um computer programs that
scrape and analyze historical data statisticians and you know predictive analytics that way special kind of
uh intellectual uh you know thinkers and people who have innovative ideas and insights and they group all
these different things together and call it predictive analytics and it boils down to something i think
you were saying before jt and you too morgan about you know the monitor of it and there's great value in
that you know i haven't seen very many you know organized groups be super great on business and uh first you know show a
a very definitive track record of success and repeatability and then approach uh you know the big companies that
utilize this stuff uh there's a lot of people who utilize this stuff and groups and you know i i suck at
business you know i'm uh always just have been more on that creative side um you know it's it's my nature but
um you know companies pay money for this and uh you know we're utilized in different ways by different
groups but the ability to help and contribute is a a tenuous and precarious pursuit because
you know um oftentimes i don't work with anything that i have suspicion of you know i've explored some
things and maybe i've been stupid and naive at different times and explorations but um you kind
of learn i think most intuitives do to a large statistical you know percentage that helping people is where
it's at and warning uh you know people when we can shamans have been the ones to say we need to save up
extra grain to survive an upcoming disaster and um you know we we're all this uh uh team and uh something
that was said before about uh intelligence agencies and others um utilizing uh you know corroborative data
from predictive analytics essentially intuitives science trajectories experts and they pull that
all together to have advantages you know that's why they have continuity of government locations and
wealthy people have underground bunkers not just because you know intuitives have felt it and we all
kind of feel the uh encroaching dangers but also privileged information things about the magnetic uh
poll reversal and the historical data on how many global mass extinctions there have been and uh so i you
know i keep coming back to this point of um this importance of these abilities for our kids and for
our future because the future is super precarious with all these different you know uh things so uh it's
it's it's a weird balance and it's a very difficult uh balance for me um personally you know weighing
all these different you know things and thoughts and concerns and you know uh you know talents and uh
so uh you know it's it's a balance but i enjoy conversing with like-minded people who care you know
we enjoy talking to you and um uh i on an unrelated sort of unrelated uh i was thinking about something
that fletcher said earlier and i was going to touch back on it and i didn't um sort of a referring
to a sensitivity to symbolic thinking in his life like the things that happened and he he tried to think
of them in a symbolic way like right now this period right the two things that are happening this year
is number one each of us everyone here in at least two particular areas of life in the life in general
but at least two particular areas of your life you have an opportunity once in about 20 year opportunity
to to really and possibly historical in this case shed karma right by letting go of resentments by um
by by addressing past resentments and relationships in certain areas of life and that that varies from
person to person right but this is we we started our our original talks by talking about moksha
and and liberation and this is actually a period it is apropos to what we talk about because this is a
period where you can um really gain ground and getting to that point with the moksha and and escaping
this um the the the the the cycle of of the sense of imprisonment in this world um the other thing
uh is this is a good time um to receive messages from the from the unconscious your unconscious the
collective unconscious right like i'm sure everyone here has had weird dreams this year
and when you say weird dreams everyone's like oh yeah that that's like a a carnival trick right because
then everyone's like yeah i had a weird dream but that's not not what i mean i mean like very specific
to you dreams involving a message from the unconscious i guarantee it i don't know what
it is i'm not you know trying to do a cold read on all of you i don't know but i know this is what's
happening i know what's happening everyone it's it everyone in the world right but we're not talking
about everyone in the world we're talking about everyone here and in our community at this point um
one of the way you you always want to be careful with symbolic thinking i'm not saying this has
nothing to a fletcher right but um the first step in any type of esoteric practice is to make sure you
avoid ideas and delusions of personal reference no one here has ever said anything that would
let believe me to believe they have those but that's just the the caveat that say at first is
you know what is what is that like so my reason my most recent symbolic uh gesture
i mean i mean i can go into like really recent like why i dipped out for an hour um it was very
important um but yeah what you know thinking about like okay so you're talking about the karma
and you know we're looking at like end of the world type scenarios right and and it doesn't really
matter how you look at it there's a different different ways to frame it like could the
control structure whatever like the archons the the poles it could be anything right it could be as
simple as getting hurt in your own home which is why i was gone for an hour right so um
it's sometimes what i suspect is like maybe it's you know you can like all this stuff is like we're
looking at predictions right we're we're we're trying to like solve the world by predicting pattern
recognition whatever you want to call it remote viewing it doesn't matter like you can set it up
different ways but um though that doesn't mean that those things that you're seeing in the future are
for sure going to happen that way right and like maybe this is a way of like
you know these terrible things that we see going on maybe these are like representations of our
collective karma on the planet right and and it's our our duty someone mentioned duty earlier that was a
good one um to like bring light to those uh those things and and everybody come together and it's it's
really funny when i think about it this way because like everybody that i talk to like knows that this
is all all the shit that we have to deal with and it's like you know everybody is more aware
of all this stuff and on the same page um than than anybody really understands so like just that
fact alone like the fact that so many people see the bullshit going on and recognize it for what it is
even though we have to deal with it like pretty much it seems like all the the normal majority of
people are on the same page and i think that alone can turn the tides on like major major things
um so like my most recent purchase i um i had one of those rubber silicone wedding rings
and i lost it i was like it got stretched out washing my hands lost it
and i started thinking of like what do i want for a new one like i have i have some other ones i have
like a gold one i have like one i got on on the honeymoon and um i was like cleaning up and organizing
and i misplaced them somewhere there's somewhere in the house i don't know where i can't find them so
i need to find a new ring to wear and i want to be safe and and not i want it to break before my finger
does in the case of like an emergency so i was looking at like wood like not hardwood
uh and then i um found these uh this um i thought about this and i was like oh i bet there's one of
these out there and i knew where to look and it's a carved from a mammoth tusk and these mammoths were
all like flash frozen up in alaska and um so i got a ring in the mail it's on the way here it should be
here in like i don't know a couple days or something i don't know where it's coming from
and um it's a ring made out of a mammoth tusk he said you gotta be careful don't like bang it on
stuff for a break um but uh definitely it's going to give me something to think about you know but i
think the the collective consciousness is way more powerful than than anybody would imagine and that's
why like okay if you're using data sets right like we talked about like like with the technical stuff
and you're using an agent to connect these two timelines if you want to look at it that way that's
how i would um you have you have to synchronize those two timelines for for the viewing to actually happen
and um i think that um if you go back and you do it at a different time like let's say a few months from now
you might get a different result for the same exact activity right depending on on uh how everybody is
um getting along and having their shit together under the you know most bullshit circumstances so
um yeah so the the difference is um between symbolic thinking uh and uh delusions of personal
reference or if you think that um major world events or items in the news um things like that or
changes in your in your environment are sending you personal messages the universe's way of crafting you
personal messages so that um or you believe that you yourself decisions that you make or actions
that you go through are causing things right like a a a minor and benign case of this is when people
think if they if they perform a ritual their team will win like if they wear the right clothes or that
you know whatever that that's going to help their team win that's a that's a benign way of looking at it
but if you chase too many synchronicities you can get caught up and begin to believe um
begin to believe that the universe itself is specifically designed for you um that that's
dangerous territory to get into whereas with symbolic thinking to believe that the events of your life are
sending you messages right as opposed to the events of everyone else's life right that's that's symbolic
thinking um not the the same but there's always a little bit of a risk so you always just try to
remain sensitized to that and and recognize that you don't want to go too far and i will give you the
example what i was going to give uh which is um it's great to think symbolically i do as well
you just again you want to avoid that like globalizing it and but you know i was going
to stop doing spaces i was pretty close to that and then someone asked me to do something for them
and i said you know okay i was losing a lot of energy and i i for me because of my medical situation in
my history like i i can have very little energy for days on end um and and not accomplish anything i also
have apparently developed an addiction to scrolling i didn't realize it until i couldn't stop doing it
recently but i was in a car accident recently it's not a big deal there's no it's not a baiting people
to say oh i'm sorry to hear about no i was just someone hit me as i was driving down the street like
they took a right and drove right into me right so uh about five weeks ago the passenger side of my car
was vandalized i didn't think much of it um i should have but you know i don't have like ideas of personal
reference or whatever so i'm not sensitized to it um and then i was driving down the street like last
week and and someone hit me and that's taken up a lot of i don't have much energy so it's taken up all of
my spear energy and i just kind of dropped everything and dropped out on a couple of spaces when people are
looking forward to me and haven't gotten back to people i'm supposed to get back to and um like i
really just had to compartmentalize everything because of my low energy level uh drove into the
same spot that i had been vandalized and i said well that's weird because now i have two insurance
claims hey sadie welcome back i haven't seen you in a while um i was just saying earlier that x doesn't
show my links to anyone so i'm here thursdays and saturdays uh if anyone who's used to watch our spaces
wants to come by and see our spaces um so yeah uh haven't gotten back to people haven't um you know
really just dropped the ball in general because uh i'm dealing with this hassle but still it was just sort
of a curiosity to me um that i was hitting the same place so i'm driving down the street the next day or
a couple of days after so this is with all within a month two of these within a few days of each other
and an animal bolts out while i'm driving from my right side and it was a raccoon i didn't i couldn't
tell what it was when it bolted out and i like i said i'm an animal person i'm an animal lover the idea of
running over an animal and ending its life it's it's horrible to me i'm i'm not the most manliest of
men in that respect right and so i was oh no oh no oh no oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry well the damn
thing didn't run under the wheels thank god it ran into the side of my car which i hope it's okay um it
looked confused and dazed behind me sort of running in a couple of circles and then ran off it didn't
wasn't run over so maybe it was okay i don't know i mean i was driving you know 30 miles an hour but
it ran into the side so hopefully it was just done but that's that's not the point the point is it ran
into the same spot the spot that was vandalized the spot that was someone drove into it and then
an animal ran out and and drove in so i had to think about that for a second and say from a paranormal
symbolic you know what's going on here well the first thing is because of the ufox i'm like is
jonathan semis sending his uh his demonic guardian uh uh spirit squad to get me because there's a guy
in the ufox community who whenever someone has an accident he he says if they were mean to me it was
because if they were mean to him it's because his demonic guardians and i was actually not very nice to
him because he's kind of a jerk but that's not what it is i don't think um i'm not suspicious like that
although who knows right in this community it could be anything it could be someone sending non-human
intelligence after somebody else we always have to leave the door open i guess so i think it's it's
because the passenger side right so symbolic to me is you know the passenger side is relationships with
others right the driver side is relationship to sell so the way i look at it in symbolic thinking is
analyze it the way you would analyze a dream right you analyze the world in your life the way you
analyze dreams um that's symbolic thinking as opposed to ideas of personal representation so um you know
if it was a dream well what did it say well it's the passenger side so it's relationships it's others
it's the back it's the past so it's leaving you know relationships in the past or you know it's a
it's a message to to to look back on or or or turn back and and look at relationships that you were
leaving in the past or left in the past and you know obviously it's an impact right so there's a
certain amount of vulnerability there so it's like a a vulnerability a blind spot to to a vulnerability
from events and relationships that that are behind you now and then of course i did have to think
about jonathan semis because he's always on in the x-space is telling people that you know his you know
his guardians are sending the animals out whatever and i said well that's that's not really what's going
on here but it's a good um it's a good morality tale for how you can think things are past but there can
people be people who who uh harbor ill will towards you or maybe you yourself haven't um tied up all the
loose ends that you need to tie up right in life maybe you yourself haven't done the things that you need
to do so at that point i decided that you know i would do some more spaces and i would get in touch
with some people that i hadn't been in touch with and try to mend everything to the best of my ability
because like i said this is also a period where looking into the astrology um not this is a remote
viewing space so i'm not talking too much about it but this is a period where letting go of resentments
and and putting past relationships putting the trouble in them behind you is a is is a powerful
way of of getting rid of the karma that ties us to this world of getting closer to moksha so it's
in that same basic theme as well so the theme of the astrology it both vedic and in western so that's
what i'm that's the type of symbolic thinking that i'm that i'm talking about which i think is helpful
and real quick on the karma um because i didn't really complete the thought on this because there's
there's more context to that too so a friend of mine who uh fought in war he was a sniper and
you know he had some bad shit happen to him and he was it was like at a time where there was some
bad shit happening to me and my like personal sphere that felt like the deliberate like kind of like
karmic attacks or you're demonic it could have been any kind of shit really um it was kind of
fucked up all the stuff that happened i don't need to really go into that but one of the things he said
to me was you know like um sometimes i i wonder if i just have like bad karma that that is just
fucking me now because i you know was over there doing that shit and i was like you know i'd heard
this from a guy that i really like i actually replied to morgan um with their post of one of
his videos he had kind of expressed this whole karma thing really well and it's like you can be you can
avoid it right and this is when i start thinking about it you know personally and or like all of us
collectively uh you can be like the zen monk in the cave and avoid it and ignore it like the
that you're dealt um or you can like the the best way to you know i mean this guy spends a lot of time
in the astral so i don't really know like his perspective completely but it resonates and you
know he's like well it's it's not like there's the zen monk perspective where you kind of hide from
karma you like so you don't create any that way you don't have to deal with any right but then there's
a whole nother way of thinking where you like this is everywhere around us anyway we're all mixed up in
it so why not create whatever you want however you want and do a good job and like that is going to
pay off way bigger than just hiding from everything um so i find that really powerful
yeah so with that right like i'm not telling anyone else what to do like how to live
um we began our you had mentioned our earlier spaces and the subject of our earlier spaces
um was being stuck in the reality overlay by the archons and um flowing from that how to escape the
reality overlay and the actual um morgan correct me if i'm wrong the actual session material um was done
under um looking at moksha which is uh the hindu term for you know liberation from this level of the world
right going to the next level that was one angle of attack but not okay one right but we did talk
about it in the spaces moksha right yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so that's why i'm circling back to it
right so this i've actually never even heard of it i'd appreciate it like an explanation i've never even
heard that word before today moksha no it's just it's it's the the vedic um
it's it's the vedic was what you uh so prior to being called vedic right like um in the the ancient
esoteric religious practices in hinduism well in every in every ancient um stream basically but
the term masha is specific to the ancient hindu practices right the goal is to escape like the
world is a place that we're trapped in it's a fake world that we're imprisoned in and the goal is to
escape it and the closer you get to present day the less you find that in in representing religions but
when you go far enough back you find it everywhere so moksha is the escape from this false reality
and um and then liberation into the true reality right and um the there is remote viewing data on how
that might happen but there's also uh religious and esoteric data which the basic principle is is
getting rid of bad karma so or karma in general right so karma is just attachment it's a it's a
inappropriate attachment uh to a large degree but it's attachment in general so like if you look at
like the story of krishna you know what he's what he was telling people was you know it's you do what
you have to do but as long as you're not attached to the outcome but the it's the attachments in this
case resentments because we're talking about the the events of the quality of this period of time like
what you can get rid of that releases karma right um when you have a resentment okay i'm having flashbacks
to the previous spaces with doomer yeah yeah i know we talked about this before like yeah yeah
yeah exactly is like what i was reading from it yeah so that's that's why right um that i'm talking about
the karma so i'm not saying that you you have to worry about your karma i'm saying that for those
of us who have a following from these spaces have that concern this is a specific period of time where
um specific types of relationships probably two for each person but one or two specific areas
of life you can really let go of a lot of karma um and get closer to the process of moksha of escaping from this
this level right so um one way to do that is to look into um your lunar mansions um where k2 is
i'm not a big vedic astrology guy but in this case i am because they're the experts in moksha
um another way to follow symbolism in your life again not to get into you know the idea of the universe
sending you a message because you're special but synchronicities from the from the perspective of
just showing you things you're not seeing right like a real synchronicity is something that shows
you something that you're not seeing it's a it's like a little nudge hey wake up pay attention to this
you know so if you can put um a meaning to it right like analyze it as if you're analyzing a dream or just
a specific meaning to it like something unattended that you could that you could uh complete
that would help you on your path like that's something to look for right now definitely um
you know not like messages that you're a special unique person or you are all special and unique
but you know that's not what we're looking for right now we're looking for just like
a little nudge for sort of uncompleted business um that you might be able to complete
in this time to give yourself a little bit of a a little bit of a spiritual advantage that's all i'm
saying so ready go is he gone no everyone drops out they're really hammering us tonight with uh
oh dropping out from the spaces yeah no i'm here i uh oh morgan's gone i see what's going on
oh no i'm back and that time was my own fault my um uh i hit the x button like uh just the way i was
holding my phone my finger reached around and hit the leave button there is also a case for standing
out and that's in rv data and esoteric data as well because this is a complicated situation right
you you want to escape the imprisonment that that life carries with it but you also don't want to get
recycled right the the flip side of that is the destruction of your personality after that right like
the goal is to you and your personality to escape um and not be recycled basically so the way that
you escape the recycling process if you can't get out of the world the way you escape the recycling
process is by standing out because the point of a simulation is to generate emergent
is to generate uh solutions right so living a particularly notable life is one way to do that
um i was uh this i was trying to explain this to my wife yeah for like how i feel about this and um
sure i was like you should be able to do whatever you want right like that but that was like clashing
with her because she has this idea of like how it's supposed to be and i was like no no no like it should be
whatever you want really like there should be no constraints
i don't know if i agree with that but i mean i respect your right to believe i would just think
that you know it's important to consider all the people right so we live in um we're a mess in
the world full of other people and our our actions our behaviors have effects on other people and so
that's where like the concept of karma and restriction comes in from our own actions right so it's
that's like when when the archons created the reality overlay or whatever right they changed
the nature of people if you believe what the ancient sources say they changed the nature of
people and they gave us these negative uh habits right greed and gluttony and hatred and um
violence and things like that right and the intention of those negative habits is both to
create to to increase the suffering of other people that they harvest in some sense the archons harvest in
some sense and it's also to keep us trapped by creating these artificial attachments um so that
we're not able to leave it's perfect you know if if you were saying like well i'm i'm perfectly adapted
to living in this this world whatever it is and i want to you know i want to do whatever i want that's fine
um for you but in order to really stand out you don't just kind of do whatever you want you
you live with um uh passion and focus right so one example people give is like um
you know uh uh being deeply in love uh being deeply committed to your career uh living the type of
life that no one else lives but like dissolution i'm not saying that what you're talking about but
but some people do talk about dissolution right and a dissolute life definitely doesn't uh advantage
you at all in a spiritual sense yeah well i mean so our buddy or i don't know if you met him yet or not
he's a hoot man yeah no favorite but um so he um you know one of the things i caution him because he's
always like when he says things like you know i'm ready to die that kind of shit and like and like
he he thinks there's more out there than there is here and i'm like i don't know man this place is
pretty cool uh like are you sure you're not gonna get bored like because there's this propensity to
want to like look to the beyond like it's gonna save everything
personally i kind of believe in our naivety to understand these things they might be more
wonderful and beautiful than we project our beliefs or uh desires onto and uh you know the thing to me
about like uh symbolism and uh belief and faith and fate um they really intersect in in wild ways you
know morgan was talking before about how the subconscious speaks in symbolism and stuff so
sometimes symbol can represent in a very mundane non-esoteric sense can represent um kind of trajectories
that you in your subconscious can foresee coming you know and even things like we know well uh you know
if you believe you can do something you've got a greater chance of doing something you know the
whole premise of the secret is about you know uh manifesting uh your future but there's another weird
aspect of fate that troubles me a lot of course the nature of trillions of previous factors determine
different people's you know fate and karma can have all sorts of different levels and
from my you know very limited understanding of the universe i just question free will so much so often
and then i think why would you know we be here why would be in you know part of this creation and maybe
part of it is a important part of it is experience you know the the whole grand creation experiencing
itself uh through different perspectives and some people are fated for you know i guess necessitative
reasons to have very dark futures or uh very tragic futures and experiences and i oftentimes think
that this universe is less about free will and maybe more about experience but i do think it's also
very interactive and can has a malleability that i can't understand so the problem with free will
morgan i'll just go for a second the problem with free will is how it's been reinterpreted right so
free will is the free will to choose god that's what free will meant right the free will was the free
will to choose god and not to do to not to kill somebody right not to steal not to whatever it did
not mean the free will to map out your own destiny and create your own circumstances in life
it's come to mean being your own god right so if someone says they believe in free will what
they're really saying although they might not fully admit this is they're saying they believe
in some sense they're their own god right where they can design the the events actions and actions
of others and the outcome of their life and that i mean i i don't think there's any evidence of
free will at all in that sense there is the evidence of free will to choose god
for some people and there's definitely the evidence of free will not to harm right like you
some people might be compelled by nature or events but there are definitely people who seem to have the
ability to choose not to do the worst thing at the worst time so in that sense it's free will but as
far as like i'm the master of my own fate that's a fan i'm dude i've been an astrologer for 30 years
no one is a master of their own fate they're they're delusional now uh uh fletcher i gotta admit that
going down the the path of this conversation is tough because uh i don't think there's anything for
after this dude and uh i am about as diametrically opposed i assume you're a magician right i don't
know if that's true or not but i don't know i mean you know interestingly enough so yeah after i had
that the experience with those vedic dudes um you know we had a weird experience me and my dad and my
brother um all my two brothers but only my dad and my other brother like we're kind of part of it um
i mean we're all part of it but um the intense part um and then like the next year on the same trip
like we didn't really talk about it much anymore and my dad walks up to me just like hey
i'm a shaman too and i was like and i just stared at him just like i stared at those vedic dudes
i was like just kind of shrugged my shoulder didn't respond yeah so i'm gonna ask him what he
meant by that because like you know i don't know i don't know what kind of magic it is man but i i'd
like to think that it's good magic maybe and and they're like shamanism is is a certain set of of um
of actions a certain set of techniques of modalities right but then there's um the other stuff
and amongst that other stuff at least stuff that or professes to be involved in is a lot of negotiating
with our con stuff and the way that people who do it justify it is to uh profess that everything that
they're communicating with is a manifestation of their own unconscious mind but that's not actually
true and once you accept that it's not actually true then what you realize is you've got people
making attempting to bargain with non-human intelligence
in some sense and that is absolutely um if you're doing that you're not going anywhere
uh well like that's that's i mean every spiritual tradition in human history like ritual magic and
that stuff that's very new they claim it's very old but it's actually very new and in every spirit
tradition history will tell you that if you're if you're bargaining with archons you're not going
you're not going anywhere well i'm just i'm just talking to you about that yeah no no for sure i
appreciate it um but uh you know one of the things that i would like to question like because this is
another big question that i'd have for you guys um and i i came onto this on my own before i even ran into
or at all and basically um like what do you do when you run into something that is um you know
intimidating and like there's there's really no way out you're kind of trapped that kind of a scenario
right um and i had come to the conclusion after you know these experiences that i've that i've
talked to you about like these couple little weird things that are all they all kind of fit together
um like those kind of things like what do you do with something like that that's trying to consume
you like you can you consume it that's really the only other solution and i i came to that conclusion
and haven't heard very many people actually i haven't heard anybody mention it besides or
and like that's something that i've felt myself like as the ultimate solution to just like
oh yeah i will just consume you it's not a big deal and the only other person that i've heard
mentioned that is or and so like i don't know like i i hear things from him that i i understand what he's
saying and and uh just trying to understand more that's it i guess yeah no and and look right like
that's people we're out here mixing and matching and looking for the people that that are vibing with
us right or that we vibe with um there are or people i'm sure there are a lot of or people out there um i
i don't know if i would he's so bombastic that i don't know if i would call him a pied piper like i
think that he's not honest with himself or he's he's putting on a show right both could be true um
and and because it's so over the top i wouldn't put it in the pied piper category but there are people
certainly people who attempt to convince others to do the things that he's talking about doing
and those people do not have the spiritual welfare of other people in mind and from my perspective
like i don't have time for anyone who doesn't have the spiritual welfare and well-being of other
people in mind i don't expect everyone to be that way right like um and we're all flawed you know i've
told morgan this a long time ago there are no heroes in hell right he's trying to be more gentle so
you know yeah well be gentle right he can do whatever he wants i just would i have uh extreme
skepticism about his his fate in the next world that's my skepticism it has nothing to do with him
and he can you know he live his life that's fine um there's nothing to do with me uh i just i i push
back and react strongly to people who who try to convince others to make those life decisions you know
particularly getting involved in things that involve uh you know soliciting non-human intelligence which
is something that you know for thousands of years humanity knew was not a good idea to do
uh but that doesn't mean he can't do it i just don't necessarily want him now as far as the consuming
and consuming i i've never consumed a non-human intelligence that i'm aware of i've never had a
non-human intelligence try to consume me um i will hope that that doesn't occur um i don't know too
many people who it has happened to and i'm sorry if you and or have had the experience of having some sort of
spiritual being try to consume you um i just i don't know if i have any answer to that right so
maybe go with his answer i guess if that's what resonates with you i don't necessarily have an
answer i i would just avoid being in the proximity of something that wants to consume you right so
engaging in a meditative practice that involves calling those things to you is probably not the first
step um i don't really do that people on on deck here uh morgan was on deck first and buddy was on deck
second morgan you want to take it oh yeah um you know i just kind of wanted to throw an idea out
there you know uh i'm kind of jumping back a few minutes but we were talking about you know moksha uh
liberation and you what comes next so um that's something of course i think about
relatively frequently not all the time but uh often enough and
i'm kind of well here's i don't know it's a little bit of a thought experiment it's a bit of a
question but um i think and of course i'm not 100 certain and i'm sorry for all these caveats i also
don't mean this to sound too like dark or morbid but for me personally i think the end goal um is
either complete return to source or total obliteration and i kind of wonder actually if those
aren't perhaps the same thing yeah now you got me thinking about neutrinos again man
i mean that might do but i think there's a lot of steps in between uh to to to also focus on i mean
i don't know maybe that'll be the next step but i think that we probably have a lot a lot of work to
go before you're in the position to make that choice um i obviously hope you end up where you where
you want to be though go ahead buddy i just i just love these uh thoughts um just really quickly on or
um we all have different like experiences and perspectives and allow us to reflect upon
ourselves some mirrors you know everything is our mirror you know um some mirrors are more fun
house mirrors some mirrors are clearer than others and or is an iconoclast and i completely love him
and adore him and i think he has a lot of experiences and perspectives and knowledge that uh you know we
can all benefit from like everyone in this room i'm a hundred percent certain in that and one of my
favorite philosophers or recognized thinkers from history is diogenes and someone in this room is
also named uh diogenes and he was a real iconoclast but there's a deeper truths in there and there's
also kind of different symbolic ways to interpret the different things people say like if something's trying
to consume you whether it be a something toxic or negative to your life uh people or you know behaviors
or you know other forces you that's i take from that symbolically you consume it you take control
that you don't let it control you you know what i mean um and that's kind of a thought but then i have
this other weird thought that connects to the afterlife the pre-life um and our role in the universe and
you know next lives and karma and things like that um i have this belief that's evolved over time based on
you know evidentiary value but also experiences that the now this moment is held up by a living past
and that past is still active in order for now to exist trillions of previous events so i look at the
universe as kind of like a sculpture and uh you know you're never gone you're never gone because of
this or that or whatever or i don't believe you know the you know any forces like archons or demons or
other things can take you out of here you're here you're crucial to the universe you're completely a part
of it inseparably a part of it and always will be and to me that's kind of it's very comforting you're
always holding the hand of the person you love who passed away and that past is you know existing
still in my framework and that brings me to the now and the now if you believe in that kind of a theory
and physics believes in this deterministic kind of a universe then right now you're holding up the
future you're part of the grand sculpture a crucial piece and i'd like to think of these moments as
forever moments we may have other lifetimes in ways i don't understand and reincarnations and
karma loops and freedom greater freedoms but i also think these are forever moments right now is a
forever moment it's a wonderful forever moment we're able to share and i'm humbled to be able to share my
you know likely inaccurate perspectives but it makes me think how do i want to spend my forever moments
um and uh it it's uh these are deep and important thoughts we don't think about as much as we we could
and and likely should we get distracted by materialism and you know survival um but i keep getting that sense
that we should disregard the pervasive illusion of separateness we're all you know different instruments
in this badass orchestra you know and uh we'd like to control the orchestra or the conductor sometimes
or um but i'm i'm thankful for the experience i'm thankful for being um you know i guess me and having
the blessings i've been blessed with and i'm i'm sure you guys feel the same way not everyone has as many
you know blessings as we do in this room or conveniences or technology or you know finances and
different situations um but it's pretty mind-blowing to think that you know we're really really truly all
connected and there you know there is this non-locality we are connected to we're not alone although it feels
like it you know uh as an individual as a part of the grand shattered you know kind of mirror or mosaic
um i don't understand all this stuff i don't know yeah after after i talked to those dudes made of light
um i felt cold and alone man like more so than i ever have well i you know when i was young i probably
felt that way after a nightmare but um you know yeah i was like wow man this place here is cold and lonely
i don't know why like that's mind-boggling like we spend our time going around in circles all day
complaining about how there's too many people and stuff and and then after something like that
this place feels cold and lonely man
that's it's reality you know but just part of it it's also beautiful and poetic and a flower doesn't
last forever a flower is alone although there may be other flowers um but it's beautiful for the
moment it's there you know um there's a lot of different perspectives and i i have dark thoughts
you know i've got negative thoughts i deal with you know adversity and have um and i just try to you
you know just for my own um you know i guess health and uh life experience seek out the blessings i'm
immersed in you know uh that i undervalue uh at the same time as i realize i'm alone um and it's it's
you know the point of buddhism uh if you could sum it up in like a sentence it's like the end of suffering
um you know uh it ain't easy existing right
yeah no that's all true and we're not all on the same path and we're not all meant to be on the
that's the truth we may be unified on on different levels right i'm not disputing that but you know in
our in our in our life path in our in our spiritual journey it's we're not on the same you know maybe
we are all are eventually but not right now and that's that's okay i mean that you know it's not um
not everyone is trapped in our in our circumstances to the same degree i mean maybe we all are
in the same place right but let's just use the metaphor of a prison for a minute and say that you
know not everyone in the prison is a prisoner right there are guards there even amongst the prisoners there
are favorite individuals there are administrators there are you know there are all kinds of people who
who exist inside that prison um and even amongst the inmates there are people who suffer to a different degree
so to say that they're all on the same uh they all the same path or the the same um desires uh that
wouldn't be accurate uh yeah but what if it's a biological quarantine and like all we got to do is get
everybody clean and then we're good i mean everybody's good yeah but i mean look you know in this discussion
we've already like very recently in this discussion we've already crossed uh you know that there are a
number of different opinions on what that would represent right so um i don't think that we would
agree i don't think that that i any of us here would would be on the same page maybe a few with each
other right but i don't think anyone would be on the same page with me so i know that we would be in
different camps in that respect about what ultimately that would look like you know and and how we would
achieve it um but as far as the biology is concerned i don't um i don't necessarily yeah that's metaphorical
i personally think it's like essential and crucial and i think this is like the function that is driving
the universe i'm not even kidding at all dude i'm i'm not messing around like i feel deeply that like
the things that we do here are shaping everything because it's such a tight substrate like we are in a
niche and like it you know i keep going back to that idea about like who was the dude who said that
the earth was the center of the world or the uh solar system or the universe or whatever um like
there's a point to that i wouldn't disagree you know again we're i wouldn't disagree with that
sentiment we all have sort of different perspectives right now now buddy talks he talks very passionately
he's a he he brings people together he's a unifier he's an ambassador he's a positive person right and
i think those are all admirable traits um you know he says he has some some some darker thoughts i i don't
have darker thoughts about myself i do have i guess what could be considered to be darker thoughts about a lot
of problems and and problematic individuals um but you know one of the things when you follow that line
of reasoning like we're in a biological quarantine we're going to go on to this universe well you know
i'm a simulationist so i don't necessarily believe that universe is real that haven't been said i i don't
want to break it to you guys but there ain't anyone out there who wants us out there right we might be of
the opinion there might be some of us who are of the opinion that every it's all good it's all good and
and we're ready to be out there but uh the best people in this world are highly problematic uh morally
speaking right like not everyone is a murderer but everyone you know or most everyone thinks violent
thoughts not everyone is a thief but most of us have at some point right uh there are people um
all manner of uh of setting traps and undermining each other and and um wealth disparities involving you
know people um consuming things that other people need to live and i mean it's just you know there are
very seven major categories right of these of these problems of these flaws but these flaws are so
significant that no advanced culture or spiritual culture would ever want us there um and to think
that like we're very close to that point like we're not very close to that point um there have been
saints there have been like holy people renunciates or whatever who are close to that point but by and
large if aliens land tomorrow and they say hey you you you guys are perfect for us come with us i wouldn't
get on that ship because you are not going to like where it takes you right because we we are just not
that everyone it's quite possible that everyone in the world is doing the best they can
that's not the same thing as saying everyone in the world is doing good stuff um you know i i don't
even know you know most of the most of the people in the world i wouldn't particularly be happy with
them being my neighbors and i'm here right and i'm part of it and i'm far from being uh uh flawless
you know in the remote viewing data it came up i think morgan can talk about like just how unfair
the situation is and i i feel that we all feel that right but at this point having been turned into what
we are right the regardless of how fair it is or not what that is still remains those flaws those those vices
those those nasty behaviors that the will to harm others for personal benefit still remains and there
is not anyone who wants to be around that outside of this yeah and then we start getting into like
cataclysm territory and like what happens when that shit slaps back at you instantly and that's when we
really learn like how much we matter i mean you know look uh uh these things that happen right they they
may have been imposed on us unfairly but they happen for a reason and there certainly is right when you
look at the cataclysms and the cycles uh doomer once um very early on was doing his uh thing and look i'm
not uh i'm not criticizing him in this respect i understand that people feel this way but he was
doing the it's not fair he's big into that it's not fair the the aliens the archons are narcissistic
parents and you know they're holding us back and and and you know we don't it doesn't need to happen
and you know justice are you sure they're not just jealous um jealous and afraid to try it for
themselves well look dude they they were jealous of human beings at one point in time but they're
not jealous of us now because they recreated us in our own in their own image right and that that's that's
uh um uh what it comes down to is that regardless of whether it's fair or not that we're here
uh we're we're rotten fruit and and that that's the way that it is right it's like not like one
one spare tradition says that right right like that's that's a pretty much across the board there are
a couple of indigenous traditions that would tend to disagree but even they like even if you get
into the native american traditions right the the end of the previous worlds happened for a reason
so even if they don't get it with the same type of judgment that we do they still know that
the reason these cataclysms occur or these cataclysms occur in correlation with periods
where human behavior is just out of control so what happens with these cataclysms is as time goes on
human beings get worse and worse and worse and worse and worse and then by the very end we're so
absolutely horrible that the cat happens wipes us out we start off again we're not that bad and we might
not think yeah but if we get instant cataclysm then like everybody gets slapped in the face right away
and maybe doesn't do it anymore i don't know no unfortunately yeah micro dosing cataclysm can we do that
hey look if you come back right and you're able to maintain i don't know how much consciousness you're
able to maintain but definitely if you follow like what for instance like the the vedantic or pre-vedantic
sources say that a lot more people keep moksha and get out at the beginning of the next cycle
than in cycle right so like if you if you come back at least if if if the the people the agents are
correct right the people come back are going to have a better chance of getting out at that time so
in a sense you're right like in a sense there is a little bit of like a scared straight aspect to it
um but right now what we're doing right now like very few people here are going anywhere um when this
is done uh it's just it's next to impossible to separate ourselves from the the attachments caused
by our own bad actions right like so every time you harm somebody they develop an attachment to it you
develop an attachment to it and what changes here is that what oh it sounded like we lost him again
yeah it sounds like i had a quick thought you know um the universe has kind of laws and we see it in
nature it's kind of brutal it's um very brute force it's counterintuitive to a lot of our best instincts
you know animals kill animals um and kind of like what i was saying before no one player wins some have
better games than others but it's like the game wins and i even think this psychotics the sociopaths the
people who do reprehensible things serve the super creature of humanity um and it's why we're uh alive
and you know uh evolution is very brutal but it's geared towards the game winning towards life persisting
towards you know more um kind of proficiency uh towards survivability and uh you know
cataclysms also can serve in evolutionary beneficial uh uh purposes um you know we right now are
the direct descendants of ancestors depending how far you go back in your evolutionary beliefs
you are the descendant you are the uh kind of mantle holder of winner after winner after winner after
survivor survivor survivor surviving plagues global cataclysms war disease and culminating in you right
here now and whatever our progeny is whether it's post-biological or there's other disasters um
i think you know cumulatively will add to the betterment or survivability of life you know we won't
win the game i'm not going to win the game i'm certainly not winning now but uh the game will win uh life uh
hopefully will will win but i i don't know the universe is very uh brutal and you know if you want
to know about god look at how the universe operates rather than what people believe you know um and uh
it's kind of it's kind of to me it hints at like a parent not wanting to control their child to do this
and that but the necessity of letting them you know be themselves and not able to control everything
and to go through their experiences and to go through their experiences and their learning um i i don't
know it's all suspiciously um constructed uh for life begetting life and um it's very stark and like
fletcher's saying a cold and we lack uh understanding of the full sculpture of it you know a cat hates it
when it it's taken to the vet uh it's the worst experience possible for the cat but it could be
saving its life or its progeny or you know so uh i keep trying to uh accept my ignorance you know
you know buddy and not to circle back to the thing that no one wants to hear about but look man
the universe is hard and cold because the people in it are hard and cold that's what it comes down to
right the the flaw is an absence of love for other people the one person filled with love can heat a
room not that's not a metaphor i'm saying one person filled with love can heat the temperature
of a room of a cold room it's yeah okay and there's historical records of this right in every spiritual
tradition um you take the the worst experiences that we have right now and you flip it around and you
replace us all with people full of love for each other right and you you you immediately transfer this or
change this world into a mostly paradisical experience punctuated by the tragedy of death eventually
but generally speaking that coldness that loneliness that bleakness right that
almost perfectly disappears okay and so that flaw in our cell creates that cold hard um reality that we
all have to live in and we until we escape that flaw we can't change anything for the better and i hear
what you're saying about the cycle of life or whatever but you know those same ancestors that we're so proud
of they ate a lot of human flesh buddy right that's how we got through those cold winters
right there are too many clean hands in the history of natural selection so it's necessary evils but you
know there's no beautiful core to this world that isn't isn't tainted and and it will be until we cross
that threshold and and we're no longer in opposition to each other um and what guys like you when you talk about
this unity right you're bringing us closer to that point when we're no longer in opposition to each
other but the reality is that we are and that's where that cold loneliness comes from and that's
what you experience you walk out of your house and you have a chain of negative interactions with other
people right and you bring that back and it affects you and over time it actually right it changes the
the musculature of your body and the tension level in your body and so you you wind up having
this these negative experiences even when everyone else isn't around right like stress is your body's
response to environmental threat they there was this whole thing in the 90s 2000s they tell you you
know you know it's it's it's all in your mind your mind is creating stress but it's not true it is in
your mind but it's your body's reaction it's your body preparing you to fight for your life in the face of
stress so what stress really is is a bad environment and bad people and people you can't trust
and and in nature it's environmental threats you stress is deadly man like we have to be in sync
with our environment if we're not we get stressed correct stress is deadly and that's the root like
when you get down to it people don't want to hear but when you get down to the truth of this world
right is that we are all or a lot of us intentionally inflict stress on each other all the time
right we intentionally put each other in life-threatening situations all the time and it's so common
that we just shrug and say oh no that's just that's just yeah but also on the other hand we do it for
fun too or at least i do my friends yeah yeah well there you go well okay so there's some to that
right that's when you get into that it's um we do it's bonding yeah yeah we go through life-threatening
situations together and it's so much fun and it's crazy right well okay so the thing with that is
though right that's actually adaptive because you're going to face those stressful situations in the future
with each other you have to be able to trust each other that's why that happens is you it's a test
basically to make sure you can rely on the people it's fun that's the that's the experience of it but
the reason for it is the test to make sure you can rely on other people what i'm saying is is that
people intentionally harm each other all the time undermine each other take from each other it's on a low
level right and not bonding and not for fun for some of them right and until that ends
um until we stop you know killing each other all the time and and beating each other down and
destroying each other's lives piece by piece i guess you know any any the positive talk is nice but it's
it's all in the future it's all in the future yeah but still like i mean
today but most of us don't yeah sorry i mean uh i didn't interrupt um that's like if you map the
trajectory like and and the public sentiment right like our the amount of communication we have these
days is nuts so like it's it's impossible to get away with anything it's just tapering off like i
know it sucks that like 20 000 kids got killed in god like that's really fucked up and that shouldn't
happen but like i think it's because there's so much attention on it and so many people that are talking
about like what the hell is actually happening that that it's changing things and i don't think that
they can get away with it like they used to so i think we're on a good trajectory overall okay so in
the neolithic period right um at least 25 so more than 25 of people were killed uh died by murder in
the neolithic period but we know at least 25 were because 25 of the bodies you dig up from that period
died from um uh an impact to the left side of their head they they they find their the left side of the
skull is caved in and you know that means it's other people because most people are right-handed
so if it was an animal or something else it would be either side of the head or other parts of the
body but what it is is people bashing each other's heads so it's 25 of people died in the neolithic
period uh from having their heads bashed in by other people now that doesn't happen today
but as you were pointing out stress is a factor in disease so how many people die of heart disease this
you know some people have genetic heart disease the majority of people who experience heart disease
are experiencing it because of stress or lifestyle factors that are a natural method
of um of dealing with stress right like uh uh drinking well there's also environmental factors
sure there are environmental factors absolutely but the predominant danger to other people in our time
is ourselves right there was a time once when when people all died from being eaten by lions but that's
not true right now we all die from torturing each other our entire lives and that's the majority of
people the majority of people right the suffering inflicted on them by others contributes to their death
not some people not in third world countries as a matter of fact the more industrialized a society
is the more that's true the more primitive a society is the more likely they die of infections for
instance right or or accidents related to work but in a society like ours right people are generally dying
from lifestyle diseases which are diseases created by the stress imposed on us by society and other
people now we live in a society with a much lower murder rate than some of these other societies
so if you looked at that and you just judged on that you would say okay well look people can all see
what each other is doing and so we don't have this murder rate that they used to have
but we don't have the same level of love and that's a fact that doesn't mean that people in third world
societies or in aboriginal societies are perfect in loving each other often far from it right but
compared today to even two or three hundred years ago the number of people who who who who love their
neighbor and care for the neighbor is significantly lower and it's trending in the direction of going to
absolute zero so when you look at people talking about transhumanism and that type of future what
they're talking about is a period of unlimited life punctuated by a lack of love and concern for
anyone else but the self and facilitated by technology but what well it was atlantis and and this is what
happened but but the trap there right is that though the body itself continues the suffering that
otherwise would destroy the body continues also so you wind up in a situation where people are living
very long very horrible lives right and that that is our unless we're going to change course because
there's going to be a catastrophe that that balances the scales but unless that were to happen that is
the course we would go down if we went down the course already happened the catastrophe yeah it's possible
that it already happened and we're out of it maybe uh that we're out of it no no we're definitely at the
at the bottom of the kali yuga we're not the the top like this is you know uh in all these cultures they
had a list of the of the warning signs that you were at the very bottom of the iron age and it's everything
that we live with today now it's great that you feel positive about some aspects of your life um the
problem is is that the people who feel positive about some aspects of life are often people who
are inflicting suffering on other people and what's really important is the inflicting of the suffering
on other people right so you know people should live the life the way they're going to live it
all right but evil is evil and if you're living a life that is inflicting suffering on other people
if you have a will to harm others for your personal benefit that's evil if you do it every once in
a while you're evil every once in a while if you have a will to harm others for your personal benefit
every day you're evil every day right and that's what it comes down to now we live in a in a time
and age in a place where evil is predominant some people oppose it but it's a few people but we know what
happens we know right the evil people are destroyed destroyed every last one of them okay and we know
it's going to happen maybe not in our life but soon right so you just look at it you say okay dude you
know live your life do your thing whatever you know you'll you'll come back around in wherever place
you go right after this is over or after your next couple of lives are over or whatever and the people
who aren't completely given over to that just have to make it through right just have to endure and
that's the beautiful crystal you were building the beautiful crystal the crystal is the full man
but it's not beautiful at all this isn't a uh a blissful world uh but that's the that's how the
consciousness manifests into the world we were describing the process but the fact that it's crystal
doesn't mean that it's um good that would be a mental association someone else would make right like
this is uh flowers uh flowers the purpose of the flower is to lure an insect to come in for its you
know to spread its pollen right so um look you know if you heard our early episodes then you know where
we stand on this right like this is a the simulation is a prison created uh by the archons that's what
we believe it doesn't mean that's what you have to believe but that's what we believe we don't believe
it's a good prison created by the archons we don't believe it's a uh vacation created by the archons we
believe it's a a place filled with suffering and you know for some of us we have that experience some
people don't now there are some ways that nature compensates for suffering right like so
if you um if you're a drug addict like the drugs can alleviate the the suffering if you um if you
have strong sexual relationships sex can really alleviate the suffering right being in a strong
loving relationship can right because you get the the um hormones that your body releases when you're
touched by the person that you love right the reason that your body does that is to anesthetize you to life
right so we focus on the bonding aspect we're like oh isn't that sweet you generate oxytocin when you're
around someone you trust well why do you have to generate a hormone to relax you when you generate more
life uh never mind more life what do you mean what oh stimulation man like i don't know diversity no
the suffering of life right that's that's what the that's what the hormones do right like when you're
running and you get develop a runner's high so you don't feel the pain of running long distances right
that's what um endo can avoids and uh like the natural morphine that your body creates whatever
there it anesthetizes you it's pain relievers right when you run a lot when you lift weights your body is
generating drugs is generating pain relievers when you're being held by somebody that you love your body is
generating pain relievers that's what they are pain relievers to anesthetize you to the suffering of
the world if you don't have those things in your life if you don't have strong social relationships
if you don't have a strong close marriage if you don't have physical contact uh with people a lot if
you you know if you if you don't have the the the um interactions that generate those hormones life is
far more unpleasant what unfortunately someone like yourself faces right and what most people face
who don't go through these type of things early in life is that that suffering is inevitable life
right nobody goes through life without developing sickness nobody goes through life without developing
heartache nobody goes through life without that feeling of being alone and nobody goes through life
without a diminishing amount of anesthetization to the pain right if you and your wife are close
right now or i imagine your wife but it could be your husband i didn't hear what you say and i don't
mean to disrespect you either way right like whoever that person is right you're touching each other
now you're going to touch each other less every year right and there'll be a time when really you're not
going to want to right as as far away as that seems right and there'll be a time when you're old if you
live i hope you live to be 120 years when no one is going to want to touch you because you're living
120 years old and nobody wants to be around you don't like the way you smell all right that's the reality
of life okay and no one escapes the suffering and no one is so enraptured with the beauty of life and the
flowers and the crystals that they don't have those experiences right some of us have a temporary reprieve
all of us do to some extent right now the the benefit of that is that as you start to
to to slip as you start to lose that anesthetization to the suffering of life you develop greater compassion
and empathy for other people and hopefully you become more concerned with the well-being of others
unfortunately what happens oftentimes is that it only starts to set in when somebody is old
and they're people the world is turning its back on them and they're really not able to do anything
with that and so instead they turn to bitterness and regret and and resentment and that that heightens the
the the suffering that they experience and when you talk to these people in the old folks home and you
ask them the things they regret right it's it's often along the lines of not giving back to taking
care of others not being empathetic enough not you know loving other people um being too self-oriented
right i'm being too hedonistic right they don't really find people in old folks homes who who are
who say they wish they'd been more concerned about their career or more hedonistic um but they do
find people say they wish that they had you know been faithful to their wife right or they had found
true love they find things like that right but you don't find happy people there um so it just it is
what it is now there are always going to be people who are here for that and it's going to be the majority
people right and judging them or being upset about it or thinking it's you know that that is
counterproductive yeah well i mean like can you tell them because this was what i was thinking about
this morning dude i'm not even kidding you like can you just tell them like well i i feel like maybe
if you don't open your mind to the possibilities that you could do anything you want to you might just
have to come back and do this again right away yeah i mean because well we don't look at it that way
right but you could tell them okay but the the thing is right like there are people here for that
right there are people here to to live those lives but generally people who turn and tune into spaces like
this right believe that they're here for something else they believe that they're here to to help change
the world in some way and in some sometimes like in the world when the world is really bad changing the
world might just be slowing the the rot right blowing the the slide towards greater suffering
objectification of other people right sometimes that's that's the best someone can do but that's
still right that's still um quite a thing to do to devote one's life to doing but people who
want to devote their lives just to living their lives right there's there's a whole world for that
right there are all kinds of people out there not just like one guy with that dumb ass alien icon
right who will give you all kinds of rationalizations and justifications why that's the right thing to do
okay but it doesn't end well life doesn't end well for all of us but it really doesn't end well for
people like that yeah yeah well i mean this is like another reason why i go back to that thing between
technology and culture because like dude i feel very strongly that like culture is a huge driver man and
like it you know if you look back in history you can see how culture just captures people's grasp of
technology in general um like i don't know i think that like the culture is way more important and um
i think it's you know i mean you can see it in advertising you can see it like all over the
place the manipulation of culture um it's crazy dude um and they do it so subtly like they'll change
like the washington redskins right like these guys up there uh they used to be the redskins now they're
the commanders that um that's like the army dudes that came in and killed all the indians and then
you got like a ski resort used to be called squaw valley and now it's palisades reservoir palisades
the palisade was like a big ass fence that used to keep indians up and it's like
i don't know man i think the culture wins and like i mean as long as you're not like hurting people like
it's probably going to heal people to me i just had this overwhelming suspicion that uh the game is the
winner um and it's a very brute stark kind of thought you know there's these studies that were done
called behavioral sync and um a bunch of different uh independent groups did these studies and what they
did is they created basically these rat utopias where they treated uh they had they didn't have to
have stress they didn't have difficulties finding food they had homes uh there was even extra space and
a strange thing happened way before the population maxed out because the population didn't have
adversity to build strength you know adversity sucks but it also goes to the survivability of the
super creature you know um and these rats these colonies consistently imploded and there are different
interesting characteristics and this is really kind of shocking and um studies that were done uh there
are uh these females and males stopped mating there's a group of rats that were consistently
seen called the beautiful ones that they nicknamed them that they just became self-obsessed and preened
and they lived a kind you know a what we would consider a wholesome kind of a moral life but if not
you know overly self-involved and um you know there's this weird part about um you know reality that has
this um you know that the game wins it's not about the individual and the diversity you know i used to
wonder why the are there sociopaths they've got to have some karma but sometimes evil people win serial
killers get away with it for a lifetime and then we find out afterwards um and i kept wondering why but it
goes to the super creature surviving in life um kind of using adversity to uh build strength but we're on
the cusp of something very different now i think in previous times um and it goes to this desire that
i think we all kind of have um you know it used to technology allows fewer and fewer people to do
greater and greater damage with less and less over time you know it used to take an army to lee a siege to
a castle or a city uh you know for months before they could take it out and now one person with a
a suitcase nuke can take out you know a city or um you know and as technology gets more and more
transformative and powerful one of our options might be a greater morality greater empathy greater
communication greater sanity greater stewardship of our planet that's a you know a just a justifiable
alternative but maybe it's different you know maybe it's this brute kind of survivability maybe humanity
is destroyed by our own creations and our creations are the evolutionary survivor of us and like the
denisonians are within us they're extinct and the neanderthals are extinct but they contributed to
us being the survivors and we were brutal we killed other species we did all sorts of things to each
other and ourselves and you know lion gazelle thinks a lion's an immoral asshole you know um but the game
fucking keeps winning and uh you know i don't know any of the answers or solutions and i resonate with the
best of us kind of altruistic thoughts uh unifying and coming together for you know higher purposes but
now different than in the past and even in evolutionary you know other species and you know uh eras of uh
you know jurassic areas and different biosphere eras right now is very different because of
our ability to do massively transformative uh things and manipulate our environment and create things um
in a really dynamic and almost unpredictable way quantum computing combined with robotics we can't imagine
what 50 years from now is going to be like you really can't you know you could have some suppositions but
you know i can't really know for sure i can use my intuition my modalities my you know trick understanding
of the trajectory of science and make you know logical predictions but um you know i hate to admit it
but the suffering goes to helping the super creature and no one person some people are kind of winners but
no one is kind of the winner and it there's this brute stark reality to it that is just so
it's unpleasant but then at the same time the other side of it you know this um
kind of we're a team the symphony the game wins we're lucky to have an experience all these different
things um you know maybe even a bad experience is better than nothingness um i don't know if you
didn't have this that's how i feel all the time yeah and that's the whole point of the behavioral sync
conclusions and outcomes is um you know it's like these dualities and differences and adversities
um make it richer you know it's like roller coaster would suck if it was all up a symphony would suck
if it was all just one dude playing the triangle all these different hues and colors we may not like
and sounds and flavors go to a richer you know total creation i don't know that's just you know a feeling i i like to ponder
i mean certainly the world needs all kinds of people right and we definitely need people like
you buddy and you know we even need people like you fletcher definitely and we even need people like
doomer right i mean we do um we've lived in a period of homeostasis right we've lived in the age of the
grasshopper and everyone anticipates that it will continue i don't think like i i come from a different
perspective i think than a lot of people do i don't take for granted that the ant will always be
disadvantaged to the grasshopper because that's the world we grew up in so i don't look around and think
oh that that person has had a better life than me um so i need to envy that person because i don't
envy them because i don't think it ends well for any of them right so there are a lot of people who've had better lives than i do
than i do than i have that i do now right i i never even think to envy them because i really don't think
and i i don't think it's a matter of the eternal judgment although it will be
right but i don't even think it ends well for everyone in our lifetime i understand what you're
saying the super organism the lion that we're on a trajectory and i think that trajectory you know
we talk about the crises that are building right now and they're during crises the reason that
pro-social traits right the reason that agreeableness the the cooperative people in game theory that
almost always lose they lose 75 of the time and cooperative players always well why is it conserved
them because obviously natural selection wouldn't conserve a trait like that that you're going to lose all
the time because you don't during crisis periods the cooperative players the altruistic individuals have
an extreme advantage we've been watched all these movies that have convinced people that lone wolves
do well during global crises and they don't ever do well during a large crisis they didn't do well
during the black death they don't do well during famines they don't they're outlawed they're hunted
down and killed i'm not saying that should happen i'm saying that's what does happen to lone wolves
right they definitely don't take control of society during major crises
so dude we haven't had wolves here in like a hundred plus years and yeah
it's a sign it's a sign there it's a sign directly to you so no i mean this is what's going to happen
right like things are going to keep getting worse and non-cooperative players are going to start to
suffer and at that time we're not going to envy them we might look back and be bitter about i won't
but some people might look back and be bitter about oh they had all this advantage during the time
yeah man i was like concerned when the wolves started encountering the homeless population i'm like
oh god yeah it's fucked up especially if they all smoke pot right the population and the wolves
just imagine what would happen there oh oh dude uh yeah deep thoughts uh good luck with uh
all of that fletcher it's quite a bit and i hope that it all works out for you and buddy
it's uh it's good to talk to you i'm glad you're able to stay so positive and to develop such a
positive worldview about even the uh most difficult subjects i know that you uh like us are here for a
reason but you may not be here for the same reason right and some of us are here to reveal knowledge
to people that they they need and some of us are here to stand up to injustice and you know we're we're
all on a different we're all here for different reasons so and i hope everyone here is able to
achieve whatever their purpose is in this world and it's jason thanks for coming and sinning thank you
for staying for the whole thing dude and and cody thank you for being here and sally adam lori melissa
you're always the number one person in the spaces bark like a duck you're very close uh behind her blue it's it's i'm
glad you've been joining our spaces again recently diogenes i'm always happy when you join our spaces
um i used to really love when you come up and talk and i hope you'll be able to do it again
uh shane it's good to see you like hanging out with you dude sadie it's i'm really glad you're back
um i love your post on x uh doomer what can i say if that hasn't been said before but uh thank you for
for tuning in for uh giving us that level of uh hope he's gone uh and uh morgan thank you for coming up
and co-hosting but not co-hosting um and buddy i hope we see you again uh soon for more of our
spaces and you too fletcher um you know if you keep talking crazy shit about or all the time i don't know
but otherwise otherwise it was all good stuff so um look i gotta go because i'm falling asleep during
this conversation and i account myself make an even worse account of myself when i'm falling asleep
than when i'm not so um everyone there's gonna be a 15 unless anyone has any closing remarks there'll be
a 15 second uh silence and then the space will disconnect does anyone have but i'm just gonna
point out the irony here you're trying to say i'm the one that runs long space because this is because
you're here oh yeah this is because you're here morgan identifies as someone who who runs short
spaces but in fact uh by nature he's uh he's he's meant to run 10 hour spaces and it's a it's a great
gift i i don't have it as you can see i'm like i'm fraying but did you hear how refreshed his voice was
he ran a space before this like the longer he runs spaces the the more energy he gets is probably won't
even sleep tonight he's so energized so i'll let you know i'm a secret i was faking it well i appreciate
you guys like giving me a place to get some off my chest and bounce some stuff off of because like
some of that stuff like the that whole consumer thing like i i've only bounced that off of one
person and he totally just avoided the conversation so i really appreciate that you guys are going to listen
insensitive right but like or isn't he like five feet tall uh i think we're the same height no not
five feet really i'm not i'm not trying to i don't know maybe is he tall because i i heard he was really
small and that makes it more difficult for me not this is not there's anything wrong with that right
it's not a short dig what i'm saying is it makes it more difficult for me to see like he's kind of goofy
looking um not in a bad way but just kind of looks like a drama kid uh a native american drama kid but
a drama less and from what i understood he was kind of small and that's when people talk about him
consuming things and stuff like it really sounds like kind of emo drama kid stuff but i don't know i
could be wrong you're like that yeah i could be wrong i think he's like that but i don't think you're
like that at all i take you very seriously i just i have difficulty taking him uh seriously but good
luck to him and his uh alistair crowley stuff and and becoming god's equal and all that other stuff
that he talks about all the time um all right guys i'm gonna head out unless anyone else has any further uh
final statements have a good night
Thank you.